[Musique]
bonjour à tous très heureuse de vous
retrouver pour vivre le temps fort de la
semaine au sénat les questions
d'actualité au gouvernement
ça commence dans une heure exactement
les sénateurs vont interpeller comme
tous les mercredis l'exécutif une heure
d'échangés en direct à suivre en
intégralité sur public sénat et on va
décortiquer tout ça avec alice bardot
depuis l'hémicycle et toutes les
réactions
ça sera avec alexandre poussard dans la
salle des conférences le débat sur le
voile arrive au sénat
ce matin les sénateurs ont débattu d'une
proposition de loi pour interdire les
signes ostentatoires religieux aux
accompagnants de sorties scolaires
un texte issu de la droite qui
intervient dans un climat explosif c'est
notre premier débat dont deux minutes et
puis après la pagaille du week-end
dernier dans les trains le droit de
retrait critiqué le gouvernement et la
direction de la sncf dénonce une grève
sauvage
la gauche juge cette polémique honteuse
les sénateurs vont interroger l'exécutif
on en parlera tout à l'heure et
n'hésitez pas à réagir et à commenter
cette émission avec le hashtag qu à g et
on va tout de suite rejoindre alice
bardot dans l'hémicycle du sénat
dans une heure maintenant alice vont
commencer les questions d'actu alors
quel sujet se détache oui alors la grève
surprise de la sncf ce week-end va
dominer ces questions d'actualité
dès l'ouverture de la séance à 15 heures
des sénateurs de tous bords politiques
interpelleront le gouvernement sur la
sécurité à bord des trains et sur le la
polémique autour du droit de retrait des
agents de la sncf il y aura également
deux questions sur la guerre commerciale
qui fait rage entre les états unis et
l'union européenne
la taxation des vins français imposé par
donald trump hackett les sénateurs voilà
pour les deux millions de ces questions
d'actualité je vous retrouve tout à
l'heure juste avant l'ouverture de la
séance
effectivement aller si on vous retrouve
tout à l'heure avec plaisir et place
maintenant au premier thème de cette
émission
faut-il interdire le voile aux
accompagnantes de sorties scolaires
le débat fait rage depuis une dizaine de
jours maintenant après l'incident du
conseil régional de bourgogne
coïncidence le sénat commence
aujourd'hui l'examen d'une proposition
de loi pour interdire les signes
ostentatoires aux accompagnants de
sorties scolaires
ce matin l'atmosphère était tendue en
commission cecil sexo ils ont pris le
temps et les débats ont été houleux
ce matin la question de l'interdiction
du port du voile lors des sorties
scolaires a divisé les sénateurs de la
commission de la culture
à la sortie les sénateurs des groupes
centristes et rds eux sont très partagés
dans mon groupe je ne peux pas vous dire
à l'instant t
/
23 combien seront pour contre ou
s'abstiendront notre groupe va être
partagée c'est un sujet difficile
compliqué mais le contexte de l'incident
grave qui a eu au conseil régional ne
doit pas dicter notre vote aujourd'hui
pour bruno retailleau dont le groupe les
républicains proposent la loi un nouveau
texte est nécessaire il viendrait
compléter le texte de 2004 sur
l'interdiction de porter le voile à
l'école dans la mesure où on considère
que la neutralité en terme de laïcité
tout être renforcé à l'école et c'est
déjà le cas pour les enseignants et
c'est désormais depuis 2004 le cas pour
les élèves
je pense que l'école hors les murs parce
que les sorties scolaires c'est l'école
hors les murs je considère que les
règles doivent être les mêmes les
sénateurs lrm socialistes et communistes
voteront contre un texte qu'ils jugent
inutiles
monsieur retailleau porte aujourd'hui un
débat qui est finalement une forme
d'hystérie za sion de questions qui
doivent être traitées par les lois
actuelles de la république
aujourd'hui tout permet de gérer ses
difficultés quand elles peuvent exister
dans les sorties scolaires ce texte
arrive là et que dans les semaines
prochaines y en aura d'autres sur le
même sujet donc on sent bien que là il
ya toute une petite forge jury
électorale dans le but
de préparer les municipales le texte
sera étudié en sciences mardi prochain
là aussi les débats risquent d'être
houleux
alors on va débattre de cette
proposition de loi mais aussi du
contexte dans lequel elle s'inscrit
une rentrée très régaliennes aussi bien
du côté de l'exécutif que du côté de la
droite avec nos quatre invités max
brisson bienvenus merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation vous êtes sénateur les
républicains des pyrénées atlantiques et
rapporteur de cette proposition de loi
vous avez passé la matinée en commission
à débattre de cette proposition de loi
sur le voile également sur ce plateau
didier rambaud bonjour sénateurs la
république en marche de l'hiver merci
d'être sur ce plateau également avec
nous david belhani bonjour bonjour vous
êtes historien maître de conférences à
l'université de picardie et spécialiste
de la droite et enfin également sur ce
plateau bastien le jeune bonjour
rédacteur en chef à valeurs actuelles
alors max brisson première question pour
vous on ne peut pas taxer la proposition
de loi de la droite sénatoriale pour
interdire les signes ostentatoires aux
accompagnants sorties scolaires je
rappelle son intitulé on peut pas taxer
ce texte d'être opportuniste il était
inscrit dans l'ordre du jour avant les
événements du conseil régional de
bourgogne
seulement il a été déposée le 9 juillet
ils portent pas sur le voile comme on le
dit mais sur les signes ostensibles et
non pas ostentatoire
il est dans le prolongement de la loi de
2004 qui interdit les signes ostensibles
pour les élèves
il pose de quelques questions simples la
république à une exigence particulière
de neutralité pour son école est depuis
longtemps et père fondateur de l'école
jules ferry jean zay avec cette exigence
de neutralité
la loi de 2004 a créé quelque chose de
particulier à l'école les usagers que
sont les élèves ont cette obligation
la jurisprudence de la cour
administrative d'appel de lyon le 3
juillet impose aussi la neutralité aux
intervenants extérieurs qui rentre dans
la classe finalement il y aurait que les
accompagnateurs de sorties scolaires
or pour nous la sortie scolaire ça c'est
la classe hors des murs c'est la classe
qui sort de l'école qui se projette dans
d'autres sites mais c'est toujours la
classe
et toc la neutralité de la classe
croyance religieuse c'est le fondement
de l'école publique alors vous justifier
cette proposition de loi
tout de même il y a ce contexte a remis
un coup de projecteur sur ce texte est
ce que ça complique les choses et dit
rambo
je pense que ça complique est-ce que
c'est opportun en ce moment est ce qu a
pas plusieurs gens à faire que
effectivement doit à nouveau vouloir
légiférer sur cette question du voile
alors j'entends que finalement cette
proposition de loi a été déposé en amont
de ce qui s'est déroulé c'est bien les
jours néanmoins j'ai la faiblesse de
penser qu'elle s'inscrit comme dans un
cadre depuis deux ans de cette droite
républicaine de vouloir un petit peu
cherché à récupérer un électorat de
trouver un peu des danish pour essayer
de voir quels la droite est unie
d'ailleurs contrairement à votre parti
mais c'est vrai c'est une opportunité
vous dites donc pour la droite elle
correspond à ce qu'elle souhaite voilà
deux j'ai encore une fois un état
d'esprit de vouloir se droitiser
davantage de chercher un électorat voilà
je pense qu'elle a un problème de aussi
de corpus idéologique est de savoir
aujourd'hui à quel électorat elle
s'adresse donc de vouloir à travers
cette ces propositions de loi vont
essayer d'apporter des réponses
bastien le jeune le débat sur le voile
il existe depuis longtemps depuis 1989
la sphère du foulard islamique de craie
c'est quelque chose qui revient qui
ponctuent l'histoire de ces trente
dernières années
aujourd'hui on aborde donc la question
des sorties scolaires pourquoi pour vous
ce débat revient-il est ce que c'est
pour des raisons politiques ou est ce
que c'est parce qu'un problème de fou
bah justement vous dites que le débat
revient pour des raisons parce que la
droite essaie de chercher un électorat
la droite elle essaie de chercher cet
électorat parce que cet électorat il
existe et que personne ne lui répond
c'est pas le c'est pas le fait de saisir
une polémique pour essayer de s'en
emparer c'est parce que une très grande
majorité des français
un problème avec l'islam et
et avec l'immigration avec les
migrations d'ailleurs je pense en
premier et du coup avec l'islam qui est
une conséquence de l'immigration
malheureusement je pense juste que le la
manière dont la droite s'y prendre pour
essayer de résoudre ce problème de
l'islam n'est pas la bonne je pense de
200 il un problème avec l'islam ou avec
les dérives l'islamisme la
radicalisation le communautarisme
enfin c'est pas la religion d'un quart
des français qui justement je pense que
les français n'ont surtout un problème
avec l'immigration et c'est pour ça que
je pense que c'est un c'est vraiment un
faux débat de placer le débat sur le
thème de la laïcité en fait le on place
le débat sur le plan de la laïcité comme
si les français étaient et ai été
choquée d'avoir une expression
religieuse alors qu'en fait c'est pas ça
le problème quand il ya une crèche dans
une mairie ça choque personne n'y a pas
de parquet face à choquer quelques
livres penseurs qui sont dans des
combats un peu un peu passé mais ça
choque pas les ça choque pas les
français quand on a des processions de
du 15 août dans les rues ça choque pas
les gens et même par rapport à l'islam
je pense que par exemple dans ce cas du
conseil régional de bourgogne franche
comté les gens ne se préoccupe pas de
savoir si la femme voilée qui était dans
les mythiques à la fois est ce qu'elle
se priver pendant le ramadan et c'est
pas un problème religieux c'est je pense
que les c'est un problème culturel qui
se posent aux français parce que qui est
liée à l'immigration
et quand les gens voient un voile il
voit pas une religion il voit une voix
une culture différente qu'ils ne
reconnaissent pas comme leur culture et
qui est présente en france aujourd'hui
et ça résoudra jamais le problème de
d'empêcher les gens de le porter dans le
cadre des sorties scolaires ou dans le
cadre de david bellamy le regard de
l'historien ce débat sur la voile et la
laïcité je le disais il est ancien
aujourd'hui c'est un sujet qui est
vraiment un marqueur de la droite est ce
que ça l'a toujours été
selon vous il historiens prend un petit
peu de distance avec les cubes de
l'événement et il me donne envie de dire
qu'il ya quand même un double contexte
kicks qui éclaire un peu tout cela il y
a le contexte d'une droite qui est en
recherche d'identité d'une droite
j'ai l'habitude de dire ici des droites
et d'affirmer qu'il est de plus en plus
difficile de faire vivre ensemble des
droites qui sont marquées par une force
centrifuge qui qui qui qui fait qu'il ya
une aimantation à la droite de la droite
il ya une aimantation à la gauche de la
droite si bien que le coeur de la droite
se rétrécit
et puis un autre contexte qui est un
contexte qui existe depuis une trentaine
d'années vous avez fait référence à la
sphère du foulard de creil
à cette occasion 189
il ya quand même moins globale du
spectre politique qui est un mouvement
de droitisation c'est quelque chose qui
a déjà existé dans l'histoire des forces
politiques sous l'effet d'un gonflement
de la droite de la droite
on a une droitisation de l'ensemble du
spectre politique
il suffit de voir comment il est
dorénavant assez facile et même c'est
une fierté pour un certain nombre de
militants de se revendiquer de la droite
avant les années 90 on n'osait pas dire
qu'on était de droite et ça c'est un
autre signe de cette droitisation mais
je le répète de l'ensemble du spectre
politique
mais ce vaisseau est ce que vous avez
l'impression que l'on assiste à une
droitisation de la france et puis pour
rebondir sur ce que disait bastia nos
jeunes tout à l'heure est-ce que vous
pensez que le débat aujourd'hui il est
vraiment sur la question de la laïcité
ou réellement le débat il est finalement
plus sur la question du communautarisme
et finalement d'ailleurs l'exécutif a
beaucoup dit bon notre combat c'est pas
tellement la laïcité c'est plutôt la
question du communautarisme etc
je ne cours pas après la droite de la
droite est d'ailleurs quand la droite
qu'on court après la droite de la droite
on perd les élections
j'ai quelques souvenirs de 2017 ou même
plus récemment tournoi je cherche plutôt
courir après la république
oui j'observe que les défenseurs de la
licité moi j'y tiens la cité je protège
l école et moins les débats les
querelles des hommes pénètrent dans
l'école et mieux l'école se porte
je trouve qu'une partie de la gauche a
oublié la laïcité et moi je cours après
la république les valeurs de république
et une laïcité intransigeante avec tout
le monde
toutes les religions moi je suis papou
j'ai mis une laïcité à géométrie
variable accommodante avec les a
intransigeante avec les autres tant que
je suis très bien dans mon corps puce
laïque et la droite peut être laïque et
je suis sur des valeurs très
républicaine et la droite républicaine
et je trouve qu'un gauche on l'a parfois
oubliés on est dans la liste
accommodante
si les pères fondateurs de l'école
publique avait été dans la licité
accommodante l'école publique
d'aujourd'hui ressemblerait au modèle
britannique moi je cours pas après au
modèle allemand je ne cours pas pris
part au vote à la majorité
présidentielle
bien calé dans le mécanisme pur jus on
roule des mécaniques ce sont les propos
du ministre qui va plus loin que ce que
je dis je ne dis pas que le voile est un
problème dans la société
mais quand il faut qu'il n'est pas
souhaitable il a dit que c'était pas
souhaitable dans la société moi j'ai pas
dis lui que je n'ai jamais dis pas qu'il
faut passer aux travaux pratiques sur la
preuve la proposition de loi la ja recul
prisonniers de l'ailé gauche de la
majorité présidentielle qui sur la
laïcité et dans la laïcité accommodante
à géométrie variable laïcité positive et
ai dit moi je suis pour une laïcité
stricte pour toutes les religions didier
rambaud votre réaction
pratiquement 95% de ce que vient dire
mon collègue jeu portal c'est pas sûr
que ça soit partagé par aujourd'hui par
l'ensemble de sa famille politique
un mot sur la laïcité effectivement
parce que il ya eu effectivement un
glissement ces dernières années veut
dire laïcité c'est un marqueur de gauche
je pense
historiquement depuis là depuis 1905
moi moi je viens de la gauche je veux
dire et ça faisait partie un peu de mon
éducation voilà je militais pour l'école
publique
elle la seule l'école publique c'était
vraiment la laïcité etc
et c'est en année et c'est vrai que la
gauche un peu abandonné ce concept au
profit de la d'une certaine droite mais
pour s'en servir plutôt pour stigmatiser
la population musulmane
donc je crois qu'on a besoin de rappeler
ce que c'est que la laïcité a cessé ces
deux principes tout à fait très simple
très fort c'est un la liberté de croire
ou de ne pas croire
et puis c'est le principe de neutralité
de la part des pouvoirs publics
voilà effectivement il faut être ferme
sur ces deux principes en tout cas ce
débat sur la laïcité il intervient dans
un contexte où la droite est à
l'offensive sur tout un tas d'autres
sujets qui eux parlent plus de
communautarisme ou encore de
radicalisation regardez il ya donc on le
dit cette proposition de loi sur les
signes religieux dans les sorties
scolaires
mais dans le même temps il ya une
proposition de loi annoncé par bruno
retailleau pour interdire les listes
communautariste il y a aussi et bien le
lancement de cette commission d' enquête
sur le radicalisme islamiste
alors d'abord on va en parler en plateau
mais on va demander ce qu'on pense la
gauche la gauche allait
eh bien au micro d'alexandre poussard
puisque vous êtes avec jean yves le
conte dans la salle des conférences du
sénat
qu'est ce qu'il pense de tout cela et de
tous ces textes qui se prépare mais oui
jean yves le conte qu'est ce que vous
pensez de cette année contre le
législatif qui éprouvent ce sont d'abord
des propositions communiqué de presse en
fait c'est un arsenal populiste tout
simplement
plusieurs de ces propositions n'ont
simplement vocation qu'à rentrer et a
accumulé à développer l'epr qui
effectivement se développe dans notre
pays mais ceux qui sont responsables ne
doivent pas les exploiter et doivent au
contraire faire en sorte de faire en
sorte de les dépasser
vous donne mon micro il n'y a pas de
problème alors oui bien entendu
mais ce n'est pas de cette manière là
qu'on voit ce que je pense qu'il faut
avoir confiance
oui
oui on a un petit problème de sont donc
alexandre va peut-être vous rejoindre
tout à l'heure pour entendre un petit
peu mieux la parole de jean yves le
conte mais tout de même
la question qui se pose max brisson c
est ce que tout cela c'est une stratégie
de la part de la droite
pourquoi est ce que la droite en cette
rentrée je parle pas que de la loi sur
le voile mais d autres textes est à
l'emporter sur les sujets du
communautarisme et de la radicalisation
vous les traitez de côme italie et moi
je parle de sujets régaliens de sujets
de société
on ne peut pas empêcher la droite aussi
de se positionner par rapport à des
points faibles du président du
gouvernement et de sa majorité
il ya une faiblesse ici sur la laïcité
on attend toujours le discours du
président de la république sur la liste
est pour nous prenons à bras le corps le
sujet de la liste et parce que d'autres
l'abandonnent mais nous avons dit ce que
nous allons bientôt discutée au sénat
elle a été fait à l'assemblée nationale
avec succès de la proposition de loi
d'aurélien pradié qui est devenu
secrétaire général de mouvement ce matin
sur les violences faites aux femmes on a
aussi un train de travailler sur le
handicap
on aborde aussi des questions sociales
mais c'est que ton existe dans la sphère
publique qu'à ne pas les traiter à dire
que c'est jamais le moment sait jamais
si jamais mais sinon ce matin les
socialistes disait constamment c'est pas
le moment c'est jamais le moment oui il
faut aborder ces questions si on ne veut
pas les laisser au rassemblement
national où il faut les a portés sous un
angle républicain et moi je peux vous
dire que ce matin je n'ai parlé que de
neutralité de l'école j'en ai fait
référence qu'à jules ferry et au père
fondateur de l'école publique
il faut que la droite est un discours
républicain puisque d'autres ne l'ont
pas actuellement
mais il faut aussi que nous ayons un
autre discours sur d'autres sociétés sur
d'autres problèmes de société c'est
ainsi que la droite se reconstruira et
reconstruira son corpus de valeurs
david benyamine à la droite et sur ses
fondamentaux comment comment est-ce que
vous analysez vous êtes à la recherche
de ses fondamentaux on ne peut pas
effectivement négliger ce contexte je le
répète d'une droite qui est un peu vidé
de son contenu électorale en tous les
cas on le voit aux chiffres qu'elle a
obtenus aux européennes travail et
qu'elle est par une attirance
d'un bord et de l'autre la droite a été
toujours pluriel je le répète elle a pu
être un certain temps unis sur un
certain nombre de questions la lutte
contre la république au 19e siècle
la droite a été d'abord antirépublicaine
au 19ème siècle avant de s'y rallier
la question sociale au 20e siècle or
depuis les années 80 la question
centrale c'est la question nationale
or avec la question nationale la droite
les droites ont du mal à s'y prendre
parce que elles sont marquées à la fois
par un caractère effectivement nationale
nationaliste et puis par un caractère
libéral ou néo libéral or comme je le
dis souvent quitte à faire du
libéralisme macron paraît plus
convaincant pour les électeurs
quitte à faire du national du
nationalisme les le pen sont plus
convaincants donc la droite se cherche
un petit peu entre les entre entre les
deux et finalement elle a du mal elle a
tenu autant des murs au temps de jacques
chirac quand il y avait un mur entre la
droite et la droite extrême
on est passé maintenant autant des ponts
il ya des ponts maintenant c'est
officiel
quand on voit le sondage hoxha que le
figaro sort au mois d'octobre
57% des sympathisants et l'air sont
favorables des accords avec le
rassemblement national
on voit pour les municipales dans le sud
dont l'hérault on voit des accords en
train de se faire donc on est passé de
l'ère des murs à l'ère des ponts et donc
cette droite se vite par la droite et
par la gauche et donc elle se cherche
elle cherche de quoi survivre en quelque
sorte mais cela ne gêne est d'accord la
droite cherche de quoi survivre mais
enfin je pense qu'elle se elle se elle
se vide par la droite et par la gauche
j'ai pas l'impression qu'elle se soit
que ce soit le fait de vider par la
droite qui lui fasse perdre des
élections à l'époque de l'élection de
nicolas sarkozy
on l'a beaucoup accusé d'avoir chassé
sur les terres du front national et
beaucoup je le moc à l'époque
pardon si citer beaucoup jean jaurès où
je loge le moc est en fait moi ce qui me
frappe dans ce que vous avez dit tout à
l'heure sur la laïcité etc
c'est que vous dites que vous courez
après la république mais je pense qu'en
fait le la question qui se pose et je
lis tous les tous les sujets dont vous
avez parlé le voile pour je vois pas
trop en quoi c'est un sujet différent du
suivi du communautarisme et c'est parce
que quand on dit le communautarisme on
ne cite pas de quoi on parle mais en
fait le communautarisme qui nous pose
problème c'est le communautarisme
musulman aujourd'hui 10 communautaire et
social monde et on va parler des listes
et vous parlez de la république comme si
c'était ça le problème mais en faite le
la question qui se pose aujourd'hui en
france avec le voile avec les
communautarismes c'est pas celle de la
république c'est celle de la csn de la
france c'est pas la république qui est
interrogé par tous ces sujets là c'est
la france et vous parlez jamais de la
france le problème c'est que vous vous
opposez non mais c'est vrai vous opposer
le vous opposer le comment dire les
communautarismes aux valeurs de la
république
personne ne sait vraiment bien sûr
courir après le front de seine
m'intéresse parce que ça peut vous
intéresser ça ne m'intéresse pas je vais
courir après macro ne maîtrise pas et je
crois par rapport ce que dit monsieur
n'a mis que se dessine bien dans le
champ de la république que sur le plan
de la laïcité empathique et la majorité
présidentielle non carne pas et que sur
le plan et se pose qu'au contraire nous
avons landis quoi construire il peut pas
être le seul
mais moi je serais très fier que ma
famille politique soit sur ce discours
de la laïcité laïcité au sort de la
liberté de la neutralité qui est un
fondement de notre république
oui il ya besoin de république face
justement question communautariste nous
retrouverons un discours crédible auprès
des français en réaffirmant les valeurs
de république que d'autres tu abandonné
puisque la gauche a abandonné une partie
de la gauche
j'écoutais une somme à des terres qui
lui nous a pas oubliés puisqu'une partie
de la gauche a retrouvé abandonné les
valeurs de la république
reprenant les et nous serons dans le
droit fil du général de gaulle et
d'autres grands hommes de droite qui
était moins fort mais on va rejoindre
mairie confirmant collègues
difficilement qu'il ne veut pas courir
après front national bravo et je
respecte et je crois ce qu'il dit mais
encore une fois c'est parce que sa
famille politique est en train de faire
tu dire le choix de monsieur bel ami
votre homonyme comme tête de liste aux
élections dont on connaît dont on
connaît quand même les options les
options sociétal le le vote à
l'assemblée nationale qui s'est passé
récemment sous les lois de bioéthique
sur la pma caire ou à part quelques
individus individualités la plupart des
majorités on veut le mariage pour tous
les deux propositions de loi dont on va
parler dont on parle en ce moment à
savoir sur le voile et pimkie va
peut-être arriver
la ppl sur la proposition de loi si on a
les intéristes autoritarisme démontre
quand même qu'on va plutôt aller
chercher un électorat qui aujourd'hui
est du côté du rassemblement national
justement on va demander
jean yves le conte on espère que le son
fonctionnent salle des conférences on va
voir s'il est d'accord avec vous il est
au micro d'alexandre poussard alexandre
et agua witam c'est bon le son est avec
nous alors jean yves le conte est ce que
vous pensez que la droite court après le
front national avec ses propositions de
loi sur le communautarisme et sur le
port du voile dans les sorties scolaires
ce sont 2 propose c'est à ces deux
professions c'est un festival de
communautés de deux populismes
ce sont des propositions qui sont
profondément anti républicaine vu que
elle s'appuie sur une constatation qui
effectivement il ya des clivages et des
divisions dans la société
mais pour les exploiter politiquement
pour les aggraver plutôt que de trouver
des moyens pour les soigner est-ce que
selon vous les français ont un vrai
problème avec le communautarisme parce
que c'est une réalité il ya des réalités
mais les réalités
on ne doit pas surfer dessus pour faire
plus de points aux élections on doit au
contraire faire en sorte la question du
voile
finalement la laïcité c'est pas ce ne
doit pas être un outil d'exclusion la
laïcité c'est une loi de liberté
ça ne peut pas elle ne peut pas être
utilisée exploiter pour créer des
divisions dans la société
c'est profondément anti républicain
croire dans les instituts républicaine
c'est croire par exemple que même si une
liste est faite sur est constituée sur
la base de personnes qui le font parce
qu'ils sont français d'une même origine
la force de la république c'est qu'une
fois qu'ils se soient ils sont arrivés
dans dans un conseil municipal avec
cette identité de comprendre
qu'effectivement il faut participer à la
gestion du bien commun c'est ça la force
de la république
refuser ce type de choses c'est
finalement empêché la république de
jouer son rôle
donc pour vous il ya pas de problème
avec par exemple l'union des démocrates
français musulmans tant que les parts un
parti politique
tant qu'il n'incite pas à la haine tant
qu'il n'incite pas à utiliser la liberté
d'expression au delà de ce qui est
permis dans la loi il n'y a aucune
raison
de l'interdît et donc de d'empêcher des
candidatures au contraire toute
participation aux institutions
républicaines relève d'une intégration
que ce soit parce que on a une opinion
politique qui est très différente d
opinion globale on rentre dans le
système et on accepte finalement de
travailler de la même manière si on se
sent à côté de la société si on accepte
de rentrer dans le jeu politique et que
le jeu politique par sa force il arrive
à vous intégrer c'est une bonne chose on
n'a pas l'impression faut pas l'empêcher
ça ne ferait qu'aggraver les qu'aggraver
les divisions très bien très bien donc
favoriser l'intégration et pas
l'exclusion merci voilà jean yves
lecointe sans votre réaction
merci beaucoup alexandre pour cette
réaction
didier rambaud vous avez entendu à
l'instant jean yves le consulte il faut
pas interdire les listes communautariste
c'est un sujet froid qui inquiète jusque
dans vos rangs par exemple sébastien
lecornu qui dit elle un nouveau il faut
faire des fronts républicains locaux
face à de telles listes est ce que c'est
vraiment pour vous un vrai danger
actuellement il faut lutter contre le
communautarisme c'est évident c'est la
priorité
on peut faire autrement que et à travers
l'interdiction de sortie électorale je
pense qu'il faut le contrôle par exemple
d'école qui sont hors contrat la
question des enfants qui aujourd'hui
sont déscolarisés effectivement une
belle fois les voir il faut aller
chercher et il est ramené effectivement
dans la société
mais quand on veut commencer à légiférer
par des interdits je sais pas où ça peut
aller
interdire à des listes communautaire bon
on peut avoir le débat mais je pense
qu'il faut mener le débat autrement
effectivement moi je crois être
contre-productive d'abord une fois
d'abord je pense que ça peut entraîner
d'autres débats et pourquoi pas
interdire les listes front national
parce que certains certains pourraient
prôner de la haine du racisme etc
max brisson qu'est ce que vous en pensez
ça peut être contre-productif c'est
parce que pour l'instant ce phénomène
des listes communautariste on en parle
beaucoup mais c'est pas tant de monde
c'est peut-être mille personnes sur
toute la france
on voit ya des endroits où c'est un vrai
problème est avec nous sur le compte on
a d'abord eu tout à l'heure tous les
poncifs habituels des socialistes est
d'abord on nous a reproché de courir
après le front national depuis
mitterrand ça n'a pas toujours été le
cas
moi je suis très très clair jamais
d'alliance comme la plupart de mes amis
donc cette leçon elle suffit
2 deuxième mort on a une belle exemple
aussi de parti socialiste qui a
abandonné la laïcité
il est dans la laïcité accommodante à
géométrie variable ou coup par coup
c'est pas mon attitude c'est pas ma
position je suis pour une laïcité
intransigeante puisque la gauche ne le
peut pas la droite va l'apprendre amer
après par rapport à ce que dit mon
collègue rambo moi je réagirais on a un
discours que je peux totalement partagé
oui il faut combattre le communautarisme
qui est un danger pour la république et
pour la france et c'est un danger parce
qu'il ya 1 heure tu es ce que la
république a construit dans notre pays
en france cette spécificité française /
7 / ce vivre ensemble sur cette
universalité de la citoyenneté française
c'est de la construction depuis deux
siècles de notre pays hélas le
communautarisme bien le heurter
pleinement et s'étonner du et c'est un
héros bien sûr c'est un élu du pays
basque qui vous le dit et c'est pour ça
que quand on parle de communautarisme ce
que je sais de quoi pallier un modèle
français
un modèle républicain tout à fait
exceptionnelle et la droite sonore
aujourd'hui à l'eau portée après c'est
le problème de la majorité
présidentielle et du maquereau 10 mhz
sur le dans les discours on est toujours
en phase puis quand on veut passer aux
travaux pratiques
il ya toujours une raison pour ne pas
faire sur moi des listes communautariste
oui elle me choque parce que les heurter
les conceptions mes convictions
républicaines et pour faire plaisir à
notre ami de valeurs actuelles
aussi une conception de ce qu'est la
france viendra nous choque aussi mais
pas les moyens de combattre le faire
écouter un discours avec lequel vous
êtes certainement d'accord puisque hier
emmanuel macron depuis mayotte est
intervenu sur ces sujets régaliens au
sens plus large
il a notamment encore été une fois
questions d'immigration on l'écouté donc
il faut se battre contre l'immigration
clandestine est plus efficace et
reconduire au pays d'origine
ceux qui n'ont pas droit à l'asile ces
deux éléments sont les deux faces d'une
même politique
si on veut réussir une vraie politique
d'asile et d'intégration
on doit être rigoureux sur la lutte
contre le trafic l'immigration
clandestine et est beaucoup plus
rigoureux sur les reconduites au pays
d'origine
ça c'est indispensable
david bellamy qu'est ce que vous pensez
du positionnement de la république en
marche l'immigration est bien c'est un
sujet dont on parle petit à petit
emmanuel macron depuis déjà le mois de
janvier la république en marche et ça y
est elle aussi vraiment de se
positionner sur les sujets régaliens
alors que on l'avait entendu sur le pré
en partie du quinquennat plutôt sur les
sujets bien d'économies sur lequel on
sait que le président la république est
très à l'aise oui mais on voit bien que
c'est un sujet qui est un sujet
transcourants qui intéresse tous les
tous les courants politiques
et puis il y à la république en marche
on le sait bien des hommes et des femmes
qui viennent plutôt du centre droit et
d'autres qui viennent plutôt du centre
gauche ou de la gauche donc c'est assez
normal que cela irrigue l'ensemble du du
débat sur la question du communautarisme
c'est à nos élus de décider dans leurs
débats le meilleur moyen d'y faire face
mais ce qui est certain c'est que c'est
effectivement totalement contraire à la
culture politique dans laquelle la
france ou par laquelle la france
contemporaine s'est constitué depuis le
19e siècle c'est-à-dire une démocratie
républicaine libéral s'est même
anticonstitutionnelle on a déjà la
constitution qui en soi est à est une
norme qui luttent contre ce type
éventuelle de de dérive
simplement il faut éviter de mettre sous
le titre de liste communautariste des
choses qui n'en sont pas forcément des
partis politiques qui ont dans leur
dénomination une identité religieuse
cela a toujours existé cela existe
encore aujourd'hui je crois que monsieur
retailleau le sait bien et donc il ne
faut pas non plus mélanger les types de
2,2 d'identité et de il faut donner un
sens très particulier très précis à ses
listes communautariste bastien aux
jeunes sur les listes communautariste
communautarisme en fait je sur
l'immigration j'ai l'impression que ça
fait moi ça fait moi réagir c'est non
mais moi j'étais d'accord avec ce qu'il
a dit sur les migrations et qu'il le dit
mais qu'ensuite il fait exactement
inverse notamment dans la loi qui a été
voté qui a erré large et c'est le
regroupement familial par à mayotte main
sur les reconduites à la frontière et
sont quand même assez importante sur le
lagarde et les chiffres sur les lices
communautariste que j'ai ce que je en
fait je n'ai pas de problème avec le
fait de les interdire c'est pas ça ne
pose pas de problème mais je pense que
ça passe c'est passé totalement à côté
du vrai sujet encore une fois et je
pense que ça va pas servir à grand chose
le
la liste communautarisme elle est pas un
problème en soi elle est simplement un
symptôme d'un problème qui de ce qui se
passe dans la société française qui est
ce que jérôme fourquet a décrit dans son
dans son livre sur l'archipel français
ça veut dire qu'on a une société dans
laquelle il ya des groupes qui ne vivent
plus du tout ensemble et dans laquelle
il ya des parties entières de la
population qui font sécession et c est
en fait le fait de faire une liste
communautaire qui s'adresse seulement à
cette partie de la population là c'est
simplement une conséquence de sa donc
déjà cette info au sujet parce que y'a
presque pas dit ce que me taire ça
n'existe pas en plus ces gens là ne vote
pas un repas aux élections et surtout le
fait d'interdire ces temps là de se
présenter aux élections ou de faire des
listes ça va pas du tout faire
disparaître le problème qui en fait ils
sont là et que c'est ça le problème
il nous reste quelques secondes un mot
de conclusion tout de même max brisson
didier rambaud la question du voile
n'est pas le vrai sujet de la laïcité le
veut vivre ensemble c'est faire
république c'est pour ça que je pense
que la droite indiquent qu a porté sur
la république après question après
question il faut régler les problèmes ce
sont des questions pratiques sûrs que
l'on pose à travers ces propositions de
loi elles ont le mérite de poser un
problème plus global
mais ce n'est pas parce que le problème
est immense il faut pas le régler
question après question la neutralité de
l'école c'est une question composé et on
souhaite la traiter c'est pour le bien
de la conscience des enfants
construction et c'est peut-être très
important pour la suite pour faire
république en sa route mais en tout cas
le sujet sera en débat la semaine
prochaine dans l'hémicycle du sénat
mardi prochain le 29 octobre exactement
merci messieurs d'avoir participé à ce
débat
on va passer au deuxième thème de cette
émission les suites de l'incendié de
visites libres izal à rouen les
sénateurs ont entamé hier les premières
auditions de leur commission denquête
début en fanfare puisque is entière
passer sur le gril de leurs questions le
pdg de la multinationale l'américain
eric nre résumé par au travail états
avant toute explication le pdg de
lubrizol à commencer par demander pardon
je voudrais tout d'abord présenter nos
excuses les plus sincères à tous ceux
qui ont été impactés par l' incendie du
26 septembre
il a ensuite tenté sous serment je le
jure de répondre aux inquiétudes
nombreuses des sénateurs concernant les
risques sanitaires de l'incendié du mois
dernier
est ce qu'on connaît vraiment la
dangerosité du panache de fumée qui est
qui et qui
qui est sorti et qui a flotté sur la
ville deux roues art et ses environs
réponse maladroite des riches n'eurent
les produits qui ont brûlé ne présentent
pas de danger à la santé outre les
irritations
il n'y a aucune différence significative
entre ce qui a été brûlé dans le feu et
ce qui peut brûler dans l'incendié d'une
maison
face au scepticisme des sénateurs les
retombées ne sont pas nocives
permettez moi juste de vous faire part
de mon étonnement sans faire de
catastrophisme
je pense quand même qu'on est là devant
une catastrophe écologique le directeur
s'est engagé à leur fournir toutes les
analyses effectuées par des experts
indépendants
quant au déroulé de l'accident il
s'affine d'après nos informations
l'incendié a débuté hors de notre site
mais nous devons encore en déterminer
les causes
il est trop tôt pour en dire plus une
enquête judiciaire est en cours trop tôt
aussi pour évoquer précisément les
indemnisations qui répondront aux
préjudices subis par les agriculteurs et
les sociétés environnantes
mais le pdg promet que lubrizol sera au
rendez vous une nouvelle promesse face à
laquelle la commission reste prudente
soyez certain que nous serons très
vigilants quant au fait que ces bonnes
intentions se traduisent dans les faits
les sénateurs poursuivront leur enquête
jeudi sur le site de lubrizol et on
poursuit sur cette audition est sûr que
l'on a pu apprendre trois semaines après
l incendie de lubrizol avec mes invités
sur ce plateau christine bonfanti-dossat
bonjour sénatrice les républicains de
notes et garonne co rapporteur de la
commission d' enquête sur l' incendie de
lubrizol on vous a d'ailleurs entendu
dans ce reportage également sur ce
plateau didier marie bonjour vous êtes
sénateur socialiste de seine-maritime
première question pour vous christine
bonfanti-dossat on a entendu donc les
changes que vous avez eue hier avec eric
scherer qu'avez vous pensé de sa réponse
lorsqu'il vous dit les fumées dégagées
par l'incendié ne sont pas plus toxique
que celle d'une habitation
ça vous paraît un petit peu gros j'ai
été très surprise et très dubitative par
rapport à effectivement à cette réponse
parce que je disais hier qu'on n'avait
pas besoin d'avoir des diplômes de
chimie pour considérer que ces
substances toxiques qui brûlent ensemble
génère une combustion sauvage dont nous
ignorons tout pour vous
le fait de dieu il nous semble c'est du
bon sens et le fait de dire que cet
incendie s'apparente simplement à l'
incendie d'une maison n'est pas n'est
pas recevable
didier marais vous qui demande une
expertise indépendante sur le cac
lubrizol j'imagine que vous ne prenez
pas la parole du pdg de l'entreprise
pour argent comptant non plus non un
mois après l incendie
toute une série de questions restent
posées et l'audition du pdg
international de lubrizol non pas n'a
pas apporté les réponses attendues mais
des réponses trèfle oui il a fait preuve
d'empathie
il nous a expliqué que l'entreprise où
il est en bon voisin mais quand on lui a
posé des questions quand on lui a posé
des questions précises sur la nature des
produits sur leur toxicité et s'est
voulu rassurant quand tu as posé les
questions sur le montant des indemnités
que l'entreprise était prête à verser il
n'a pas citer de chiffres tout cela est
resté relativement fou de nous ce qu'on
veut c'est l'objet de la commission
denquête c'est la vérité et cette vérité
je pense de s'établir au fur et à mesure
des auditions et du temps que nous
allons consacrer à cette affaire quand
on reste sur la question de la toxicité
on a appris que les résultats et les
bilan hépatique des pompiers intervenus
sur place sont anormaux d'ailleurs
certains veulent porter plainte
et bien cela n'est bien sûr pas à même
de rassurer on imagine les roannais la
population sur place mais sûr que non
puisque l'ambiance dans cette région
l'heure est à l'angoissé permanente
si on a évité peut-être la panique et
peut-être que les services de l'état ont
suggéré le fait qu'il n'y ait pas de
panique l'angoissé toujours et toujours
là et lorsqu'on dit aux gens que tu es
circulez ya rien à voir tout finalement
et c'est bien passé si vous avez
quelques petites allergies des éruptions
cutanées
ça se bornera ça ce n'est pas très grave
pour qu'on ne prenait bien que la
population ne peut pas accepter cela
je pense que il y a eu aussi nous sommes
le tilt une mauvaise communication pour
rassurer les gens
il faut leur dire des choses et je crois
que la commission denquête va aussi
s'atteler à travailler sur le fait que
pourquoi n'y at il pas eu cette
communication
que tout le monde attendait
effectivement vous aviez pointé du doigt
d'ailleurs viage de communication avec
beaucoup de retard dans l'information
celle ci a été partiel les maires sont
restés seuls face à l' incendie et à ses
conséquences
donc nous ce que l'on veut aujourd'hui
c'est que toute la transparence soit
faite alors le gouvernement tardivement
a demandé au préfet de mettre en place
un comité pour la transparence et et le
dialogue qui se réunira d'ailleurs de
nouveau vendredi
mais les inquiétudes demeurent bons
nombres de nos concitoyens et des
habitants de la métropole de rouen et
d'au-delà s'inquiètent des retombées des
suies de ce qu'ils ont respiré et donc
les analyses doivent tout est fait les
unes après les autres
nous ce qu'on demande c'est qu'il y à la
fois un suivi médical immédiat et de
long terme et qu'on mette en place une
étude épidémiologique
là dessus on n'a pas encore les réponses
de l' agence régionale de la santé
j'espère que nous les aurons d'ici la
fin de la semaine parce que les gens
souhaitent effectivement savoir ce qui
s'est passé est effectivement ses
arrières un vrai sujet comment est ce
qu'on va pouvoir savoir combien ça va
coûter en termes de santé publique comme
on va faire le suivi sanitaire comme en
épi qui va payer enfin ce sont des
sujets sur lesquels avant qu'on ait une
réponse aucune réponse ni ni d'ailleurs
sur la volonté du pdg de commencer à
indemniser les agriculteurs et les
commerçants le ministre de l'equipement
fonds pour les agriculteurs le ministre
de l'agriculture a avancé le chiffre de
40 millions
le pdg a dit non pas du tout je ne suis
pas du tout d'accord avec ces chiffres
c'était à la presse les problèmes
allechi voilà les provinces étaient là
et pas le chiffre dont je moi aussi mon
souci est de dire
je lui ai d'ailleurs posé la question
hier de savoir quelles étaient ses
relations avec le gouvernement français
il a vu pour l'instant madame bornes il
a vu ni la ministre de la santé nih il
ya quelques semaines alors il a dit nous
a dit que non et amis la ministre de la
santé nil le ministre d'économie et des
finances ni le ministre de l'agriculture
c'était mon avis important qu'ils les
voient et à la question avez vous vu
avez vous eu un entretien avec le
président de la république il a répondu
évasivement non non non je pense que
c'est un événement majeur pour
l'industrie française mais également
pour la la sécurité de la population
moi je pense qu'on doit maintenant
rassurer la population
il ya des analyses qui ont été faites
qui sont fiables fait parlant de 16 par
l'ineris y en a d'autres qui sont faits
par des cabinets qui sont mandatées soit
par l'entreprise soit par les services
de l'état
tout ça doit être mis sur la table et on
doit communiquer dessus pour que les
gens sachent exactement de quoi il
retourne il y a encore effectivement les
zones d'ombré oui il ya encore les
inquiétudes donc il faut l'élever
progressivement je pense que la
commission denquête contribuera aussi à
aller lever moi mon inquiétude
maintenant c'est effectivement pour
celles et ceux qui ont été pénalisés il
faut les indemniser les agriculteurs on
sait à peu près comment ça va se passer
pour les commerçants pour les
entreprises c'est pas le cas
et puis globalement il ya un déficit
d'attractivité pour l'ensemble du
territoire qui devra aussi est évaluée
et indemniser un mot on va revenir sur
un instant de cette audition hier au
sénat un élément qui n'est pas fait pour
être rassurant c'est lorsque eric summer
a égrainé avec précision pour le coup
les accidents que le groupe a connu ces
dernières années on écoute ses passagers
on y revient dans un instant plateau
j'ai eu quand même en 2013 un accident
rouen dans votre établissement
une fuite de gaz importante qui a
conduit à ce que la justice condamne en
2014 l'entreprise lubrizol considérant
je cite qu'il y avait une série
d'insuffisances dans la maîtrise des
risques de la part de la société
2013 il y a eu du mercaptan qui a été
lâchée qui n'est pas un produit
dangereux en 2015
nous avons une seat à hambourg où il y
ait eu d'autres incidents qui avaient
été rapidement réglé en 2018 en belgique
nous avons eu neuf un tuyau qui a été
poussé nous avons également eu une
incendie en pennsylvanie sur un site en
christine bonfanti-dossat on est
quasiment un accident par an alors
certes le groupe comporte une
soixantaine de sites à travers le monde
mais vous vous dites quoi vous dites ça
fait quand même beaucoup je dis bien sûr
que ça fait beaucoup et c'est très
inquiétant alors il n'a pas parlé non
plus de l'amiante car je rappelle que
8000 m² de toiture amiantée ont été
brûlés et ça ramène quand même à uni
mail à un imaginaire douloureux pour
nous il n'a pas du tout été fait état
d'un ce reportage
alors je suis effectivement inquiète la
commission est inquiète alors même si
cette commission je le rappelle ne va
pas interférer en rien avec l'enquêté
judiciaire
nous ne sommes pas là pour faire la
chasse aux sorcières ni pour entretenir
un feuilleton médiatique on est là
simplement pour que pour faire la vérité
sur les conséquences que cela va vous
parler de feuilleton médiatique faudra
quand même vous faire réagir aussi à ce
qu a sorti le monde sur les problèmes
qu'il y a en masse ou trend en sous
traitance est vachement normandie hier
le pdg de lubrizol à nier qu'il y ait pu
avoir un problème de sous traitance
alors que le monde
on le voit a révélé qu'un rapport
manquerait de gros problèmes dans la
région avec des sous-traitants qui ne
connaissent pas les protocoles de
sécurité qui ne savent pas 92 % ne
savent pas utilisé un extincteur
ça c'est quand même très inquiète
notamment moi je enfin pour la normandie
je pense partout il ya des sites
industriels sensibles
non je crois qu'en fait depuis quelques
années après avoir tiré les
enseignements de la catastrophe d'azf
on n'a pas
surveiller la mise en oeuvre des
procédures qui en découlait il ya un
véritable relâchement aujourd'hui sur la
sécurité industrielle à la fois parce
qu'une diminution du nombre de
fonctionnaires chargés de contrôler il
faut dire les choses telles qu'elles
sont mais aussi parce qu'on a assoupli
la réglementation en ce qui concerne de
grisolles il ya une autorisation
d'extension des capacités de stockage
qui avait donné le pdg nous dit qu'elle
n'a pas été mise en oeuvre en tout cas
cette autorisation
cette autorisation a été donnée sans
aucune enquête environnementale c'est la
marque d'un affaissement progressif d'un
affaiblissement progressif et donc
effectivement ça concerne les
entreprises saison mais ça concerne bien
évidemment la sous-traitance et
malheureusement on n'a pas mis en oeuvre
les dispositifs nécessaires pour
qualifier toute la chaîne en matière de
sexe sera d'ailleurs l'objet d'auditions
sur ces entreprises de sous traitance
mais bien sûr vous savez les auditionner
valait alors le programme dans
l'immédiat demain nous allons sur le
site à rouen il est important que la
commission se déplace et puis nous
continuons les auditions la semaine
prochaine nous avons six mois pour
rendre notre rapport et les auditions
sont nombreuses et variées et elle en
donne pour but d'éviter aussi que cette
catastrophe ces catastrophes là ne
survienne à nouveau
moi je déplore que en france nous
n'ayons pas cette culture finalement du
risque on se dit le risque zéro n'existe
jamais mais après j'ai fait des
exercices on n'a pas cette culture de
faire des exercices
moi je suis de golfech et je vois en
tant que maire les exercices mois sur 40
en ont déduit en faire deux donc dans il
ya une culture de la prévention en amont
mais ya pas une culture de la gestion de
crise et donc quand une crise intervient
comme malheureusement ça a été le cas
sur sur rouen on est relativement
désemparés et donc je pense que la
commission enquête aura comme c'était le
cas pour azf en 2001 un certain nombre
de préconisations à faire pour améliorer
les choses
effectivement on attend donc les
préconisations de la commission denquête
il ya encore six mois de travaux
auparavant effectivement les travaux ont
commencé seulement hier avec cette
première audition même s'il a beaucoup
les deux en plateau pour venir discuter
et bien des leçons à tirer de cet
incendie de lubrizol parce que nous
sommes maintenant un quart d'heure des
questions d'actualité au gouvernement on
commence à voir du monde arrivé dans la
salle des conférences du sénat qui
jouxte l'hémicycle dans l'actualité du
sénat également et bien il ya la mission
d'information sur le sauvetage en mer
elles remettent aujourd'hui ses
conclusions cette mission sénatoriale a
été créée le 19 juin dernier à la suite
du drame survenu le 7 juin aux sables
d'olonne qui a entraîné je le rappelle
la mort de trois sauveteurs
les sénateurs ont multiplié les
déplacements sur les côtes françaises
ils demandent un meilleur encadrement
pour les baigneurs aient un statut de
citoyen sauveteurs écoutez le au micro
de béatrice 15 ans pour moi l'élément
essentiel c'est la question de la
gouvernance si les bénévoles adhérents
pouvait s'exprimer dans des instances
digne de ce nom avec une démocratie
interne vivante
je pense que nous en soyons sans doute
pas là et que je n'ai pas ce sentiment
d'éloignement à la fois du sciage et de
l'état reparler par les bénévoles
chacun a pu se sentir à la fois écouter
nous nous avons fait un travail de
terrain qui est avant tout un travail
d'écouté a passé des dizaines d'heures
aux côtés des des bénévoles et nous les
avons écoutés
c'était l'objectif et ils nous ont parlé
ils se sont livrés toutes leurs
interrogations toutes leurs demandes
nous les porterons au travers donc de
propositions comme ça est rédigé dans le
rapport 30 propositions extrêmement
concrètes qui sont pour beaucoup d'entre
elles
facile à mettre en oeuvre rapidement le
statut du bénévole la gouvernance de la
snsm le financement aussi les moyens en
fonctionnement comme un investissement
et justement alexandre vous êtes avec
dominique estrosi sassone dans la salle
des conférences du sénat la sénatrice a
elle aussi participé à cette mission
d'information oui dominique estrosi
sassone cette détresse des sauveteurs en
mer est ce que c'est d'abord un problème
de moyens
je pense que effectivement il y à une
question de moyens comment arriver à
assurer le financement dans la pérennité
de la flotte qui sert au sauvetage en
mer parce qu'on le voit que cette flotte
aller vieillissante elle est vétuste et
qu'aujourd'hui il ya un vaste plan
d'investissement à soutenir
et qu'il ne peut plus être prises en
charge comme c'est le cas actuellement
uniquement par les collectivités
territoriales qui font déjà beaucoup
parler station et par la snsm
au niveau national il faut que l'état
qui aujourd'hui s'est désintéressé du
sauvetage en mer alors que c'est une
mission régalienne
alors que c'est une mission de service
public puisse bien évidemment financer
ce plan d'investissement mais ce que
l'on a pu aussi noté à travers nos
déplacements de cette mission
d'information sur le terrain c'est que
véritablement d'abord on a affaire à
quelques 8000 500 sauveteurs en mer qui
sont d'un d'un bénévolat d'une
disponibilité d'un dévouement d'un
professionnalisme extraordinaire sauf
que aujourd'hui bien évidemment d'abord
dans leur majorité ce ne sont plus des
gens de mer ils ont besoin de se former
et aujourd'hui les formations sont de
plus en plus coûteuses pour les stations
locales
il faut leur donner un véritable statut
de bénévole et cela passe par ouvrir des
congés de formation
cela passe par prendre en compte des
heures de bénévolat dans le calcul de
leurs points de retraite par leur donner
des jours de délégations c'est comme ça
qu'on arrivera bien évidemment à
renforcer leur statut de bénévoles
auxquels ils sont fermement attachés et
c'est ce qui est fait aussi la réussite
notre modèle du sauvetage en mer mais
bien évidemment il faut qu'ils puissent
être encouragé il faut qu'ils puissent
être sécurisés dans leur mission
quotidienne alors votre mission
d'information propose également
d'encadrer les pratiques de baignade qui
évolue est ce qu'aujourd'hui les
baigneurs sont trop imprudent forcément
on le voit les usagers de la mer ne sont
plus ceux que l'on a connu il ya
quelques années en arrière qui étaient
des plaisanciers qui connaissait la mer
aujourd'hui tout un chacun peut
s'aventurer sur la mer à partir de
navires mais aussi à partir d'un simple
engins de plage sans même en avoir fait
une seule fois une expérience et donc
forcément face à ces changements de
comportement de la part des usagers de
la mer il faut les responsabiliser
il faut aussi qu'ils puissent prendre
leurs plats leur part dans le
financement du sauvetage en mer c'est la
raison pour laquelle la mission
d'information dans ses propositions
propose de d'étudier la généralisation
d'une assurance obligatoire pour tous
les navires mais aussi pour tous les
engins de plage alors c'est pas chose
facile à mettre en oeuvre mais je crois
qu'on sera obligé d'y arriver
si l'on veut que le modèle du sauvetage
en mer tel qu'il est dans notre pays
puisse perdurer
très bien merci beaucoup dominique
estrosi sassone d'avoir répondu à nos
questions
merci beaucoup à l'exemple pour cette
nouvelles réactions dans la salle des
conférences du sénat alors que les
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
comment commencer dans une dizaine de
minutes maintenant et j'ai le plaisir
d'accueillir pour commenter cette séance
alexis a géré mots bonjour un jour vous
êtes présidente du think tank france
audacieuse et du mouvement politique
nous citoyens france alors on a une
petite idée un des thèmes de ces
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
il va y avoir notamment des questions
sur le mouvement social à la sncf
ce mouvement qui fait suite à la
collision mercredi soir de la semaine
dernière entre un ter dans le conducteur
était le seul agent sncf présent et un
convoi routier coincé est ce que pour
vous c'est un problème de sécurité ou
est-ce qu'on a été plus dans une grève
sauvage dans un droit de retrait ou une
grève selon vous il ya débat
actuellement
d'ailleurs les daims et l'un et l'autre
ne sont pas exclusifs c'est à dire qu'on
peut très bien avoir un sujet de
sécurité dans mes mails oui je vais du
en même temps mais quand même avec eux
sur ce coup là je trouve un une
importance qui a été donnée à ce retrait
quasi légal on voit bien aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs que la direction générale du
travail s'apprête à des juges est quand
même
les deux inspecteurs du travail qui ont
donné un avis
hier je crois de mémoire je crois qu'on
voit surtout aussi monter en puissance
une cette grève illimitée du 5 décembre
bien sûr donc aujourd'hui on est dans
une logique de cartographie en faites
vous pour essayer de voir qui va réussir
à rentrer dans le mouvement et donc on
est bien au-delà des questions de
sécurité dont vous voyez je ne fais pas
que du en même temps je pense que les
questions de sécurité sont effectivement
très importante et que si vous pensez
que ce qui se joue c'est mais c'est
autre chose qui se joue c'est la réforme
des retraites c'est la grève illimitée
effectivement qui s'annonce pour le mois
de décembre et qui pourrait être un mois
meurtrier pour le bjp assurant qu' ici
pki le crack qui le craint bien sûr et
c'est pour ça que le premier ministre
edouard philippe est montée au créneau
de façon très forte
ce à quoi il ne nous a pas forcément
habitués monter en première ligne de
cette façon là donc oui oui évidemment
c'est important de marquer la frontière
pour éviter que ne dégénère finalement
un mouvement qui risque cette fois ci
d'agréger un certain nombre de
mécontentement en ligne de mire il ya
bien sûr bien la réforme des retraites
le climat social très compliqué a
beaucoup viser cette réforme alors même
qu'on ne la connais même pas et que même
on se dit qu'elle n'aura peut-être
jamais vraiment le temps les
consultations se poursuivent
oui alors au sein du mouvement nous
citoyens nous nous avions pas mal
travaillé ce sujet des retraites en
regardant d'ailleurs le le sujet de
façon plutôt bienveillante au début et
quand on a creusé sur la base du rapport
parce qu'effectivement ce n'est pas le
projet en tant que tel ce n'était que
sur la base du rapport delvoye donc
s'apercevait finalement que c'était
vraiment un changement de monde y
compris dans l'aveyron un didier
guillaume qui est actuellement dans la
salle des conférences du sénat le
ministre de l'agriculture qui va avoir
un certain nombre de questions qui lui
seront destinées à notamment par rapport
au mouvement d'aghrib machine qu'il ya
actuellement je vous laisse poursuivre à
l'extérieur m'en fous et on voyait que
les
le finalement les questions de
positionnement des partenaires sociaux
qui était amoindrie avec cette
valorisation du point qui devait être
automatique
donc en fait c'est une réforme qui est
très importante qu'il faut faire parce
que la mathématique
hélas au bout d'un moment mais peut-être
que la façon dont on s'y est pris n'est
pas la bonne
et notamment sur le fait de vouloir
finalement mettre dans le même sac
si vous pardonnez l'expression
l'ensemble des régimes spéciaux avec les
régimes autonome c'est pas la même chose
un régime spécial
le gouvernement semble reculer là-dessus
a dit que les régimes autonome
certainement on va pas forcément y
toucher ils ont leurs propres caisses
bien sûr tout en s'amusant la ville bien
sûr ils sont enfin prudents parce qu'ils
ont vu aussi la capacité de mobilisation
notamment des avocats que l'on voit
c'est peut battre le pavé et qui cette
fois ci ont réussi une très belle
mobilisation en mettant en avant ont
finalement le la capacité bénéficiaire
de leur régime qu'ils ont réussi c'est
leur propre réussite pour que ça ne soit
pas mutualiser dans un grand tour où
tout le monde ne ferait pas un certain
nombre d'efforts autres sujets sains que
l'on prévoit lors de cette séance de
questions d'actualité au gouvernement et
bien c'est la grogne des départements
qui se poursuit on est quelques jours
après la fin de la grande réunion de
l'assemblée des départements de france
et on sait là où ça coince encore et
toujours
c'est ce fameux big bang fiscal avec
dominique bussereau notamment qui dit eh
bien il ya un véritable hold up qu'on
est en train de faire sur nos finances
et sur notre autonomie financière
oui et ça c'est un mouvement que je
trouve assez inquiétant parce que là
pour le coup le gouvernement fait
beaucoup de en même temps parce que d'un
côté
ils appellent finalement à avoir plus de
décentralisation à un moment où lui-même
n'avait pas donné beaucoup de gages ou
ce afin que l'on puisse dire avec
l'exercice du grand débat national qui a
permis quand même de raccrocher à un
moment où le pays était quand même très
fracturée ça a été une main tendue vers
les territoires et ça a été quelque
chose qui a été appréciée d'un côté
comme de l'autre et le en même temps
l'autre branche finalement dû en même
temps c'est que là on voit bien une
détricote les prérogatives fiscales
aussi du département et c'est un sujet
un sujet de financement mais au delà de
ça c'est un sujet de rayonnement aussi
de capacité d'action finalement des
départements au sein du territoire
voilà donc on est vraiment sur un sujet
là que je trouve assez emblématique
finalement delà de cette fracture
territoriale que nous voyons qu'ils
arrivent à l'issue d'un mouvement qui
n'est peut-être pas fini même s'il
prendra d'autres formes
le mouvement des gilet jaune qui a quand
même laissé fracturée notre france de
façon assez profonde
un autre sujet qui travaillent les
territoires et les sénateurs il
sincèrement c'est la guerre commerciale
entre l'union européenne et les etats
unis va y avoir des questions sur ce
sujet qu'est ce qui se passe exactement
à quoi est due cette guerre commerciale
alors ça c'est très intéressant parce
qu'en fait ce sont des questions
géopolitiques qui rejaillissent vraiment
économiquement très rapidement oui la
géopolitique qu'est ce que c'est c'est
que au milieu finalement l'union
européenne aujourd'hui doit trouver sa
place dans un monde qui est absolument
fracture est là aussi entre trump la
chine qui continue son ascension
la russie qui continue d'être un acteur
extrêmement important sur le plan
diplomatique et les états unis refusent
finalement ce multilatéralisme sur
lequel nous avions construit tout notre
mode de fonctionnement diplomatique
jusqu'à présent et donc on voit bien que
ce sont des rapports de force bilatéraux
qui commence à se
à se mettre en place et notamment un
rapport de force extrêmement fort pas
que la chine avec les états unis mais
également les états unis par rapport à
l'union européenne dans sa globalité
avec toutes ces barrières douanières est
donc l'arrière douanière avec le jeu au
milieu de tout cela de l'om s'est donc
c'est cela qui est qui et encadre on va
dire hélas très précisément depuis le 18
octobre vous avait en fait deux pôles
vous avez le pôle sur les avions
avec une taxe complémentaire de 10 % et
puis vous avez le pôle plus agricole
avec un certain nombre de biens de 25%
notamment sur les 20 qui concerne de
plein fouet pour le coup les
exportateurs la france effectivement
cette question du vin justement elle va
être au coeur de l'intervention de
nathalie delattre
elle est à votre micro alexandre
poussard on vous retrouve donc salle des
conférences
on parlait à l'instant de cette guerre
commerciale donc entre les états unis et
l'union européenne
oui nathalie delattre le vin français
est victime de la guerre commerciale
entre les états unis et l'union
européenne
concrètement quelles vont être les
conséquences immédiates pour la filière
viticole
mais à côté la conséquence immédiate
nous l'avons vu dès le 19 octobre c'est
à dire qu'il ya des bateaux qui sont
arrivés à quai avec du vin qui ont été
déchargés et immédiatement nos
négociants américains ont dit stop vous
n'envoyez pas d'autres vins nous allons
voir comment se comporte le marché
américain
avec cette taxe de 25% sur les vins dits
tranquilles et nous verrons si nous
commandons à l'avenir
et des vins français ou non parce que le
marché américain sera plus disponible
pour ce vent l'a alors cette surtaxe
américaine elle va avoir aussi des
conséquences à long terme pour la finir
bien sûr sont des marchés que l'on
construit avec ténacité pendant des
années c'est un marché en progression
c'est 3 milliards d'euros pour la
filière le marché américain et en une
seconde
effectivement trump a fait basculer
cette cette situation alors cette
surtaxe américaine elle provient d'abord
d'un conflit sur les avions airbus qui
ont été subventionnés par l'union
européenne mais finalement pourquoi
taper sur le banc français mais parce
que effectivement trump est le choix
dans la compensation de délire telle ou
telle taxe il le fait sur le vin
français parce que d'abord il c'est que
pour nous c'est important au niveau de
la filière ses 550 mille emplois directs
ou indirects
donc ils pensent que nous allons
peut-être entrer en négociation et il le
fait parce que c'est notre deuxième
balance commerciale excédentaire en
france avec 11 milliards 7
donc oui il touche là où effectivement
ça peut être très perturbant sont des
emplois non délocalisables enfin il sait
que pour nous nous sommes très fragiles
sur ce secteur là d'accord il frappe où
ça fait mal
et qu'est ce que vous avez demandé au
gouvernement concrètement tout à l'heure
mais écoutez moi en tant que co
président de l'anef de l'association
nationale des élus de la vigne du vin
nous avons envoyé un courrier il ya
quelques semaines pour faire un grenelle
de la victime culture parce qu'au-delà
des taxes américaines
nous sommes victimes
beaucoup de dommages collatéraux et et
de demandes de pouce et sociétal sur
l'environnement ce qui est légitime
donc nous demandons un grenelle parce
que nous avons besoin de pouvoir
discuter de mettre à plat tous ces
dossiers
très bien merci beaucoup nathalie
delattre et on va tout de suite allé
dans l'hémicycle du sénat vous retrouver
alice bardot alors alice quel va être le
programme de ces questions d'actualité
au gouvernement
oui alex à l'heure en effet il sera
question donc de la guerre commerciale
qui fait rage entre les états unis et
l'union européenne mais aussi et surtout
de la grève surprise de la sncf ce
week-end et c'est bien ça qui va dominer
les questions au gouvernement
alors la présidente du groupe communiste
eliane assassi va ouvrir le bal en
interpellant le premier ministre sur la
sécurité dans les trains car il faut le
rappeler c'est après un accident de ter
sans contrôleur à son bord que de
nombreux agents de la sncf ont décidé
d'exercer leur droit de retrait emmanuel
capus donc le sénateur les indépendants
à a souhaité d'ailleurs interrogé donc
la ministre des transports à ce sujet
elisabeth bornes alors le les questions
au gouvernement vont bientôt commencer
je vous laisse donc à écouter cette
séance et je vous retrouve juste après
pour faire un point sur leur dérouler
[Musique]
sur notre site internet
chacun aura une attention particulière
pour le temps car nous avons en effet
quinze questions et donc le respect du
temps est important
la parole est à madame la présidente
eliane assassi pour le groupe communiste
républicain citoyen écologistes madame
la présidente vous avez la parole merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre mes chers collègues le
travailleur alerte immédiatement
l'employeur de toute situation de
travail dont il a un motif raisonnable
de penser qu'elle présente un danger
grave et imminent pour sa vie ou sa
santé ainsi que toute défectuosité qu'il
constate dans les systèmes de protection
il peut se retirer d'une telle situation
c'est la définition exacte du droit de
retrait droit reconnu par le code du
travail dans son article 41 31-1 et
c'est précisément ce qu'ont fait valoir
les cheminots suite à l'accident
ferroviaire du 16 octobre dernier
survenu l'avant veille des congés
scolaires pour rappel un autorail ter a
percuté un convoi routier faisant 11
blessés
cet accident grave qui aurait pu l'être
davantage sans l'esprit de
responsabilité exemplaire du conducteur
pourtant blessé a déclenché le droit de
retrait de 17 mille cheminots sur les 23
1000 conducteurs et contrôleurs soit +2
73%
ces agents ont considéré que les
conditions de sécurité n'étaient pas ou
plus assurée ni le gouvernement ni
l'entreprise n'ont répondu à cette
inquiétude légitime préférant par un
écran de fumée relancer un énième débat
sur le droit de grève
votre gouvernement n'a pas eu de mots
assez durs grève sauvage qui mérite des
poursuites judiciaires selon vous
mouvement social choquant selon la
ministre des transports
une grève injustifiée et illégale selon
le président de la sncf
la pédagogie de la répétition peut avoir
des vertus mais elle les perd
quand il s'agit d'asséner des
contrevérités au mépris de l'avis rendu
par l'inspection du travail qui a
considéré que le droit de retrait était
caractérisée justifier tout en rappelant
que l' entrave au droit de retrait
constituée elle même un délice qui
semble déplaire à madame l'anis du
travail j'ai une question simple ce
premier ministre en tant qu actionnaire
unique de la sncf
que répondez-vous aux inspecteurs du
travail qui recommande le retour des
contrôleurs dans les trains dans la
tente d'une évaluation complète des
risques pour vous répondre la parole et
à monsieur le premier ministre monsieur
le premier ministre monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs
madame la présidente vous m'interrogez
sur sept ce mouvement cette perturbation
très forte
cet accident qui sont intervenus à la
fin de la semaine dernière et pendant
tout le week-end et qui ont à la fois
suscité l'interrogation et l'inquiétude
d'un certain nombre d'agents de la sncf
sur les conditions de sécurité et qui
ont également suscité un très grand
mécontentement et une très grande
incompréhension de la part d'usagers de
la sncf qui à jour de grands départs se
sont trouvés sans aucune information
sans aucune prise en compte des
problèmes parfois compliqué qui leur
étaient posées par ce mouvement et par
ses décisions qui n'avait pas été
annoncée et je vous ne les avaient pas
évoquer madame la présidente mais je
sais qu'au fond de vous-même vous pensez
également à eux à tous ses usagers qui
ont subi des désagréments et
je vais vous dire
[Applaudissements]
je je veux vous dire madame la
présidente je vous dire madame la
présidente que la question de la
sécurité est prise au sérieux par les
agents de la sncf les cheminots en
général bien entendu par l'entreprise
dans son ensemble direction comprise par
tout le monde ici et que d'ailleurs dès
que la nouvelle de l'accident est
intervenu le gouvernement l'entreprise
et le gouvernement ont pris les
décisions qui doivent être prises c'est
à dire un audit interne la saisine du
bureau enquête accident transport
terrestre de façon à savoir exactement
ce qui s'était passé quelles procédures
ont été mises en oeuvre ou pas mises en
oeuvre
est ce qu'il faut en tirer comme
conclusion pour améliorer le niveau de
sécurité par la suite c'est ce qui se
passe à chaque fois vous le savez
parfaitement
c'est ce qui a été fait parce qu'on ne
transige pas avec la sécurité et parce
que chaque incident est une façon
d'apprendre et d'éviter soit qu'ils
puissent se reproduire soit d'autre type
de problème qui n'avait pas été pensé ça
a été fait comme ce sera
systématiquement fait à la suite de cet
accident
vous l'avez dit prêt de plus de 15000
conducteur les personnels de la sncf ont
fait valoir ce que le droit prévoit sous
le terme de droit de retrait ils se
trouvent
madame la présidente que nous n'avons
pas la même appréciation de la façon
dont s'applique le droit de retrait il
se trouve que je j'ai personnellement
mais je ne suis pas du tout un
spécialiste mais j'ai personnellement du
mal à comprendre comment alors que
l'accident intervient dans un contexte
particulier sur un type de train
particulier des conducteurs d'autres des
conducteurs d'autres matériels à
d'autres endroits pourraient considérer
que le même problème est susceptible de
se poser à eux j'ai beaucoup de mal à
comprendre pourquoi les conducteurs de
we go les conducteurs de tgv ont estimé
que sur leur ligne les mêmes sujets se
pose et or vous savez parfaitement
madame la présidente
et ça c'est du droit que certes c'est un
droit individuel que certes c'est un
droit individuel qui peut être exercée
de façon collective
monsieur le sénateur j'essaie de
répondre avec passion c'est vrai mais
dignement à madame la présidente
parler quand même donc pourquoi un
président pardon pourquoi un président
puisque vous me faites dire pourquoi
elle qu'un conducteur de tgv ou de we go
aurait dit qu'il y aurait pour lui ou
pour les passagers une menace grave et
immédiate
alors que la question qui était posée
concernés des lignes qui n'étaient pas
affectés aux grandes vitesses et qui
intéressait exclusivement les
conducteurs de ter
madame madame la présidente mon analyse
celle de la direction de la sncf
c'est que à ce moment là précis dans le
contexte de l'entreprise
quelque chose qui relève du détournement
du droit de retrait a été effectué et si
ce détournement du droit de retrait est
utilisé pour ne pas respecter les
obligations d'information en matière de
grève dans les services publics
alors en effet c'est inacceptable et
c'est les mots que j'ai employé parce
que cela fait peser sur les usagers sur
l'ensemble de notre pays sur les
familles des contraintes qui ne sont pas
acceptables
c'est ce que j'ai dit je le dis
calmement je le dis sans rien mais
connaître des obligations de sécurité et
des impératifs de sécurité
mais je le dis clairement aussi parce
que nous ne pouvons pas accepter que ce
droit individuel de retrait qui existe
et que je respecte
soit détournée de son objet pour
produire un désordre maximale lequel
vous le savez comme moi peut être
interprété de très différentes façons
dans le contexte de l'entreprise et même
dans le contexte de discussions dans
lesquelles les organisations syndicales
ont des positions à faire valoir
vous le savez comme moi c'est ça que je
voulais vous dire aujourd'hui en
redisant ici que les questions de
sécurité sont essentiels et que nous
partageons cet impératif
merci
quel premier ministre parlait à notre
collègue jean yves le conte pour le
groupe socialiste et républicain j'avais
la parole pour deux minutes
merci monsieur le président la question
s'adresse au ministre des affaires
étrangères je compte sur vous c'est
ainsi qu'emmanuel macron appelait en
septembre 2018 le peuple macédonien a
ratifié le difficile accord de prêt ce
pas le peuple macédonien l'a fait un an
après la france refuse d' ouverture des
négociations d'adhésion à l'union
européenne à ce pays
cette position française illustre un
manque de confiance dans la force du
projet européen
elle retire à l'union européenne une
part significative de la crédibilité du
processus d'élargissement et donc de son
efficacité
enfin elle ouvre à nos frontières la
porte à d'autres puissances qui
s'installe parce que nous sommes absents
l'europe reste un projet une promesse
d'être plus forts ensemble plus
efficacement solidairement en affirmant
des droits individuels et sociaux
il ya 30 ans nous avons vu de la
victoire de peuple européen qui
combattaient pour leur liberté et leur
indépendance
celle ci a permis d'engager la
réunification de l'europe cette victoire
était aussi celle de charles de gaulle
de willy brandt de françois mitterrand
qui n'avait jamais accepté cette
division cette mise sous tutelle de
l'europe
nous ne saurions aujourd'hui nous
inscrirons rupture de cette vision
monsieur le ministre
l'incertitude sur le break si tu es
certain confortable mais une sortie qui
gommerait des droits castrés des règles
essentielles à nos libertés à nos
économies à nos droits sociaux est venu
d'irlande à la paix n'est pas acceptable
l'union européenne peut-elle refuser à
westminster qui a tant inspiré la
tradition parlementaire
un report permettant d'éviter un saut
dans l'inconnu l'europe oublierait ainsi
son rôle essentiel de protection des
citoyens
pourtant la protection français la fois
la position française aujourd'hui semble
se limiter à l'impatience de tourner la
page du bric site
ce n'est pas convenable monsieur le
ministre l'action de la france en europe
vise elle a renforcé une europe des
nations au service exclusif des états
membres et de leur égoïsme ou une robe
souveraine au service de tous ses
citoyens et protéger leurs droits
pour vous répondre la parole et à madame
le secrétaire d'état
chargé des affaires européennes amélie
de montchalin la parole madame la
ministre
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur
sénateurs le compte la politique
européenne de la france et je crois que
le président le démontre dans chacune
des interventions et au conseil c'est
bien de rendre l'europe puissante c'est
qu'elle puisse peser qu'elle a une voix
dans le monde et qu'elle soit pour
reprendre vos mots souveraine
mais cette politique c'est également un
engagement devant les citoyens français
et européens qu'elle porte des résultats
que ces projets deviennent réalité est
que les tno concitoyens qui tous les
cinq ans vote pour l'europe puisse voter
non pas sur des promesses mais bien sûr
des résultats
c'est pour cela que la france à
travailler qu'elle a mis beaucoup
d'elle-même dans l'agenda stratégique
maintenant la commission est que nous
avons lors de ce conseil européen
essayez d'oeuvrer pour que nous
puissions mettre en oeuvre ce projet
alors oui nous assumons d'avoir un
discours et une stratégie claire sur le
brésil parce que nous voulons faire
cesser l'incertitude extrêmement
pénalisante pour des millions de
familles des millions citoyens et nous
voulons en vend bien les protéger contre
des incertitudes qui minent aujourd'hui
leur projet c'est aussi pour cela que
nous avons une position forte sur
l'élargissement parce que nous voulons
que toutes les étapes soient respectés
que les conditions posées il ya 18 mois
soit respectée nous voulons que le
processus de négociation soit plus utile
soit plus transparent que les
populations en bénéficient et stoppent
leur émigration massive
nous voulons une union qui fonctionne
mieux aujourd'hui à 27,28 nos décisions
sont lentes nous voulons donc nous
réformer avant de pouvoir nous élargir
c'est aussi pour cela que nous nous
assumons un engagement fort avec la
commission pour un budget européen qui
prennent à bras le corps l'enjeu
climatique
la transformation de l'agriculture pour
une europe qui fasse la différence et
qui crée de la souveraineté et de la
solidarité
alors oui pour tout cela la france
assume d'avoir une voix pour dire et
faire des choses fortes en europe
nous ne renoncerons pas cette ambition
parce que nous pensons que le plus petit
dénominateur commun autour d'un
consensus mou n'est pas une option
ce que nous voulons c'est créer le
consensus autour de l'ambition que nous
portons et c'est pour cela que le
président jean yves le drian et moi même
portant dans tous les états membres
sujet par sujet l'ambition de créer de
nouvelles majorités je vous remercie
monsieur le comte pour quelques secondes
madame la ministre
si l'action de la france était conforme
à ses paroles s'il était crédible
comprise nous n'aurons probablement pas
eu à subir le camouflet du refus de la
candidature de sylvie goulard à la
commission européenne
c'est aussi aujourd'hui la raison de nos
inquiétudes à la veille de la
finalisation du prochain cadre financier
pluriannuel qui devra en particulier
préparer à la transition écologique
merci la parole est notre collègue
emmanuel capus pour le gros plus
indépendant merci monsieur le président
madame la ministre avec les syndicats du
ferroviaire vous l'avez compris un abus
de droit peut en cacher un autre droit
de grève ou droit de retrait tous les
moyens sont bons
nous avions déjà connu en 2018 la grève
perlée la greffe capillotracté des
jusqu'au boutistes nouvel épisode même
saga nouvelle recette même tambouille
mercredi dernier un accident à un
passage à niveau a fait onze blessés
dans les ardennes dont le mécanicien
seul agent sncf à bord cet accident a
été particulièrement violent et on ne
peut remettre en question l'émotion
légitime qu'il a suscité l'accident a
fait l'objet de plusieurs enquêtes
il faudra notamment déterminer pourquoi
le système radio sol train n'a pas
fonctionné quoi qu'il en soit force est
de constater que le droit de retrait n'a
pas été limitée à certains matériels
identifié comme éventuellement porter de
failles de sécurité
certains systèmes étaient déjà utilisés
dans les années 70 il n'a pas non plus
madame assassi été limité aux lignes
sans contrôleur les tgv et les
intercités ou aussi été impacté ce droit
de retrait a été étendue à tout le
territoire national
la spontanéité de l'émotion a
manifestement été exploités et récupérer
les syndicats espéraient peut-être la
sympathie des usagers savants calculs
les centaines de milliers de voyageurs
bloqués lors d'un week-end de départs en
grands grande vague en vacances
sont évidemment excédé ou bien
s'agissait-il d'un test pour le 5
décembre
vous savez ce jour où ils vont protester
contre une réforme dont le contenu n'est
pas encore connue la confusion des
demandes mêlé à une disproportion totale
démontrent l'abus du droit de retrait le
danger grave et imminent a semble-t-il
d'ailleurs disparu car le travail a
repris sans qu'on puisse savoir ce qui a
changé depuis mercredi dernier c'est le
caractère inique de ce mouvement
madame la ministre la question est donc
très simple pouvez-vous nous assurer que
ces dérives inacceptables seront
sanctionnés afin que le droit de retrait
ne devienne pas la façon commode de
détourner la grève aux réformes d'un
boom qui a deux minutes parce que nous
pouvons tenir le ton monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur emmanuel
capus comme beaucoup de français j'ai
trouvé choquant la grève surprise qui a
mis en difficulté beaucoup de nos
concitoyens
les français ont besoin du train pour se
rendre au travail ou comme le week-end
dernier
comme le week-end dernier pour partir en
vacances
et quand on dit défendre le service
public on doit d'abord penser aux
usagers alors look
la grève est un droit que personne ne
remet en question mais il existe des
procédures qui permettent aux salariés
de faire valoir leurs revendications et
d'exercer leurs droits en minimisant la
gêne pour les usagers
clairement ces procédures n'ont pas été
respectées
le trafic est aujourd'hui revenue à la
normale à l'exception des ardennes et
des départements voisins et c'était
notre objectif principal
la sncf a annoncé des mesures
exceptionnelles pour indemniser les
voyageurs que ce soit le remboursement
exceptionnel des billets ou la mise en
place d'un fonds pour couvrir les frais
engagés par certains usagers mais je ne
confonds pas la méthode de cette grève
et les questions soulevées et je
voudrais redire que la sécurité
c'est la première des priorités pour
tout le monde et pas seulement pour les
syndicats c'est le sens des enquêtes qui
ont été lancés au sein de la sncf de
l'enquète qu'avec jean baptiste djebbari
nous avons demandé au bureau d'enquêté
accident dans les transports terrestres
c'est également le sens des engagements
qui ont été immédiatement pris par la
sncf
donc vous voyez monsieur le sénateur
nous sommes au travail avec la direction
pour apporter les bonnes réponses et
pour dire aussi avec fermeté que le
droit des usagers à se déplacer doit
être respectée merci la parole à notre
collègue pierre charon pour la simple et
rebecca pour deux minutes
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre de l'intérieur
mes chers collègues il y à 18 jours la
france était en état de choc à la suite
de la tuerie des quatre membres de la
préfecture de police de paris par un
fonctionnaire radicaliser il a fallu
plusieurs jours non sans cafouillages et
avec des pudeur sémantique plusieurs
jours de balbutiement politique malgré
la réactivité des enquêteurs pour
admettre que l'assassinât reposait sur
des motifs religieux
certes deux missions ont été annoncés à
juste titre par le premier ministre pour
détecter les agents a légalisé dans les
services antiterroristes
l'une de ses missions est relative à la
fameuse direction du renseignement de la
préfecture de police de paris qui dès
2015 aurait dû s'apercevoir du
changement d'apparence et de
comportement de ce fonctionnaire
la réorganisation ou le rattachement de
la drpp s'impose
près de trois semaines après cette
tuerie a rien n'a été fait les français
demandent des décisions immédiates au
moment où le gouvernement a reconnu
cette sécession insidieuse qui menace la
société les dérives communautaires de
certains employés de service public
exposées sont alarmantes par la bien
pensante des élites des signes évidents
de radicalisation dans ces services sont
tus c'est même le mot radicalisation qui
fait peur on n'ose pas désigner l'ennemi
alors que nous sommes en lutte contre
l'islamisme politique comme l'a dit
bruno retailleau le communautarisme
prépare le terreau des vocations
jihadistes de demain à chaque problème
l'exécutif tempête nous sommes devenus
cumulé de ces indécisions permanente là
comme dans bien des domaines
monsieur le ministre castaner à la suite
de la tuerie commise au coeur de
l'institution policière
je n'ose plus vous demander ce que vous
comptez faire pour que le drame de la
préfecture de police ne se renouvelle
pas puisque hélas nous ne vous croyons
plus pour vous répondre la parole et au
secrétaire d'état auprès du ministre de
l'intérieur
ce que le rendu neige sur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur pierre chante vous
m'interpeller donc sur le l'attaqué qui
a eu lieu le 3 octobre à la préfecture
de police de paris sur les conséquences
que nous en avons tiré d'abord vous dire
que 48 heures après les faits le parquet
national anti terroriste a été saisi et
c'était déjà une réponse puisque vous
dites qu'il a fallu plusieurs jours pour
48 heures après l'été saisit
immédiatement nous le premier ministre a
saisi l'inspection des services de
renseignements sur deux terrains le
premier essayer de comprendre comment ce
signalement le signalement consonnes
concernant monsieur harpon n'a pas n'est
pas remonté dans la hiérarchie n'a pas
été traité comme il se doit
première mission de l'inspection des
services de renseignements qui nous
rendra son rapport pour la fin de ce
mois et puis une deuxième mission des
services d'inspection de renseignement
qui va porter sur l'ensemble des
services de renseignement pour s'assurer
que partout le dispositif de signalement
est bien en place
quel est ce dispositif dans les services
de police il est très simple c'est au
chef de service de police de procéder au
signalement de les faire remonter à
l'inspection générale de la police
nationale qui en lien avec certains
services de renseignement dont la
direction générale de la sécurité
intérieure confirme nous pas la
radicalisation de l'individu puis prend
ensuite un certain nombre de mesures et
si nous prenons le cas de la préfecture
de police de paris mme savez ce sont
quatorze cas qui ont été traités et qui
se sont terminées dans neuf cas sur 14
par des éloignements définitif du
service en question
donc il y à bien une cellule qui en
place il ya bien des signalements qui
remonte à les gpl qui sont traités on
confirme d'une part la radicalisation
violente et ensuite des mesures sont
prises sur le champ disciplinaire vous
dire que pour vous rassurer
nous continuerons bien évidemment cette
action avec la mise en oeuvre de la loi
sylt qui permettra de révoquer des
agents de souveraineté
des fonctionnaires de police au seul
motif de la radicalisation
sans aller sur le terrain disciplinaire
comme nous le faisons actuellement et
vous dire également que d'ici très peu
de temps le champ d'action du service
national des enquêtes administratives du
fameux ce n'est as s'élargira de manière
être plus efficace et avoir un permis
qui est vraiment des miles et plus fine
possible
merci monsieur le sénateur charron
quelques secondes
je crois me souvenir que leur pilosité
directeur général de la sécurité
intérieure vous étiez à l'époque
d'accord avec moi mais cette question
s'adresse à monsieur castaner merci
beaucoup
la parole est à notre collègue pascal
martin pour le groupe de l'union
centriste
monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre madame la ministre
le 89e congrès de l'assemblée des
départements de france qui a lieu à
bourges la semaine dernière s'est soldée
par un échec
les discussions avec le gouvernement on
a chopé sur la question de l'avenir de
la fiscalité départementale réforme
après réforme
les élus départementaux ont le sentiment
que leur circonscription s'apparente non
plus à une collectivité décentralisée de
plein exercice
mais un échelon déconcentrés de l'état
le trentenaire aux communes de la taxe
foncière sur les propriétés bâties
départementale inscrits par le
gouvernement dans le projet de loi de
finances pour 2020 traduit ce lent
processus de recentralisation financière
amorcée et voici bientôt dix ans par la
suppression de la taxe professionnelle
est prolongé depuis par la suppression
d'une partie de la cvae
dans le cadre de la loi notre en leur
retirant la dernière imposition sur
laquelle il avait encore un pouvoir de
taux le gouvernement s'apprête à réduire
comme une peau de chagrin l'autonomie
fiscale des départements
cela est d'autant plus vrai que vous
semblez écarté tout déplafonnement des
droits de mutation à titre onéreux
l'attribution d'une fraction
compensatoire de la tva offrira certes
une ressource dynamique mais sera
nécessairement plus sensible aux
variations de la conjoncture économique
elle pourrait en outre être affectée par
des décisions qui est en prise au niveau
national échapperait à la responsabilité
des élus départementaux
alors que les départements engage chaque
année pour le compte de l'état 11
milliards d'euros de dépenses sociales
comment pouvez vous madame la ministre
garantir aux conseils départementaux une
évolution des transferts fiscaux qui
soit à la hauteur des charges qu'ils
assument pour le compte de la nation je
vous remercie on vous répond de la
parole et à madame jacqueline gourault
les listes de la cohésion des
territoires des relations avec les
collectivités territoriales
madame la ministre monsieur le sénateur
pascal martin je le cherche du regard
ah voilà merci je voudrais d'abord
rappeler que la suppression de la taxe
d'habitation est avant tout une baisse
d'impôt qui n'a jamais été vu depuis
très longtemps puisque c'est 18
milliards que nous rendons aux français
avec cette suppression de d'impôts de
taxes d'habitation et je voudrais vous
préciser que dans votre département de
la seine maritime
cela représente un gain de 559 euros en
moyenne bien sûr par foyer fiscal
c'était un engagement de campagne du
président de la république il est tenu
la lisibilité de l'impôt par ailleurs
monsieur le sénateur est nettement
améliorée puisque pour le contribuable
local
désormais la taxe foncière ne sera perçu
que par le bloc communal
en ce qui concerne les départements
puisque vous m'interrogez sur les
départements cette compensation qui ai
dû effectivement au fait que le foncier
bâti descendra vers les communes et bien
sera compensée par une fraction de tva
et je dis bien une fraction de tva passe
à mon temps mais vous l'avez dit
vous-même fraction vous l'avait dit et
dynamique
cela garantit bien sur l'autonomie
financière
car c'est tout l'inversé d'une dotation
le système et d'autre part plus
équitable
je crois qu'il faut insister sur ce
point riche ou pauvre
quelle que soit la dynamique foncière
chaque département vers a progressé de
la même manière ses ressources
chaque année cette réforme n'a donc pas
susciter ou agréé ou aggraver la
question du niveau de ressources des
départements
le constat celui qui conduit à plus de
solidarité entre départements par des
mécanismes renforcés de péréquation nous
le partageons monsieur le sénateur et
c'est pour cela que le gouvernement a
proposé un amendement qui a été adoptée
vendredi attribuant au département une
fraction de tva supplémentaire de 250
millions qui sera répartie de manière
péricaud et dès l'origine
je vous remercie monsieur martin
madame la ministre de remarques la
première en ce qui concerne la fraction
de tva
elle ne prendra malheureusement pas en
compte l'évolution démographique et
l'effort de construction de chaque
département
deuxième remarque il serait pour le
moins légitime qu'en cas de baisse du
produit de la tva à l'échelle nationale
les recettes attendues pour les
départements soit à minya à minima
pardon garantie je vous remercie
la parole est à notre collègue richard
yung pour le groupe de la république en
marche n'avait la parole mon cher
collègue c'est le président madame la
ministre monsieur tron vendredi dernier
à imposer de nouvelles sanctions
douanières contre des produits
d'exportation venant d'europe
il y en a pour 7 milliards et demi dont
1 milliard pour la france
ceci fait suite à une décision de l'om
c'est relatives au financement des
développements d'airbus permettez-moi
trois remarques
la première c'est que les états unis
n'accorde aucune estime à l'om c'est ils
ont même cherché à l'art démolir ils ont
refusé de nommer les juges et les
curieux de voir que soudain pris par la
vertu ils accordent la plus le plus
grand enthousiasme et la plus grande
célérité à l'application des décisions
de l'om sait
les etats unis imposent leur législation
économique et financière à travers le
monde à tous les pays
l'exemple de l'iran est dans tous les
esprits et il faut dire que en tant
qu'europe nous répondons relativement
mollement enfin à ma connaissance le
gouvernement fédéral américain déversent
des centaines de milliards de dollars
dans l'industrie aéronautique américaine
sous prétexte de contrat d'études et de
recherches pour la france sont concernés
par ces sanctions les avions les avions
fini il ya des avions non finie mais là
il ya des avions fini + 10 % les vins
tranquilles
donc le champagne n'est pas concerné
ainsi que le vouvray donc je m'en
réjouis et les fromages
nous ne pouvons que refuser que
regretter le refus de négocier des états
unis et dans ce cet affrontement
bilatérales c'est bien sûr le jeu de la
chine que je me joue monsieur 30 sans
doute aurons-nous à prendre des mesures
de sauvegarde ou de compensation pour
les exportateurs français peut-être
pouvez-vous nous en dire un mot
l'om c'est devrait donner la possibilité
à l'europe d'imposer des sanctions aux
rock you going en 2020 mais je crains
que cela soit trop tard j'espère et vous
pouvez peut-être leur assurer là dessus
allez l'europe prendra des mesures bien
avant 2020
madame la ministre on cherche des
affaires européennes
merci monsieur le président monsieur
sénateurs young effectivement comme vous
l'avez décrit les droits de douane
additionnels qui ont été décidées par
les états unis font suite à une décision
rendue par l'om c'est dans le cadre d'un
contentieux engagé en 2004 c'est-à-dire
il ya plus de 15 ans et donc ses droits
que vous l'avez rappelé ce sont 7 5
milliards de dollars d'importations
européenne parents qui concerne vous
l'avez dit l'aéronautique l'agriculture
la viticulture
le gouvernement est pleinement mobilisé
que ce soit jean baptiste maunier
guillaume bruit de la mer est également
la présence plus que symbolique de la
chancelière merkel et du président la
république
chez airbus mercredi dernier pour un
conseil des ministres franco allemand
qui visaient notamment rappelé
l'importance européenne que nous
apportons ensemble
le soutien que nous apportons notamment
à airbus l'uni aurait peine vous l'avez
dit ce serait fondée à imposer des
droits de douane contre les états unis
dans le contentieux parallèle contre
boeing
mais le calendrier vous l'avez dit n'est
pas très favorable puisque nous
attendons des confirmations de l'om
c'est des montants que nous pourrions à
poser et que nous ne connaîtrons
qu'avant quelques mois et pas avant
probablement en 2020
notre préférence va à une résolution à
l'amiable de ces contentieux car nous
pensons que l'escaladé des tensions nées
avec un allié et un partenaire n'est pas
souhaitable puisque ça aurait un impact
encore plus négatif sur nos économistes
notre commerce et sur notre industrie
aéronautique
nous continuons donc à proposer aux
états unis de dialoguer nous avons été
l'union européenne et des états unis
tous deux condamnés dans cette affaire
vieille de plus de 15 ans et nous
pensons qu'il est d'imposer des droits
de douane nous devrions travailler
ensemble à un compromis équilibré pour
mieux encadrer les futures subventions
aéronautique
puisque nous savons que en chine l'état
lui ne se prive pas de subventionner
massivement ses propres constructeur est
donc de renforcer ses positions et c'est
à eux au fond que cette affaire
bénéficient et c'est bien là tout le
paradoxe
nous regrettons que jusqu'ici les états
unis aient refusé d'engager les
discussions vers un compromis
j'appelle ici devant vous très
solennellement l'administration
américaine a entamé des négociations le
plus vite possible sans quoi nous
prendrons des mesures de rétorsion et
d'ici là et didier guillaume a pu
mobiliser lors du dernier conseil des
ministres à bruxelles la commission
européenne pour que nous puissions
protéger les viticulteurs les
agriculteurs les plus impactés par des
mesures de savon très ciblée je vous
remercie
la parole elle dans notre collègue
nathalie de là pour le groupe du
rassemblement démocratique et social
européen
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre l'organe de règlement
des différends de l'om sait a confirmé
la semaine dernière autorisé les états
unis à augmenter les taxes sur les biens
et les services européens dans le cadre
du dossier des subventions airbus le
président trump a choisi de réserver un
traitement de faveur au deuxième poste
excédentaire de 11,7 milliards d'euros
de notre balance commerciale française
le vin les droits de douane sont
désormais en hausse de 25% pour les vins
dits tranquilles 25 bourses
sur un marché qui dépasse les trois
milliards par an conquis par des années
de ténacité
tandis que les américains ont stoppé eux
en quasi une seconde
nos exportations la viticulture
française est aujourd'hui la victime
collatérale d'un conflit industriel qui
ne la concerne pas une nouvelle épreuve
pour une filière entrer dans une forte
zone de turbulences à l'étranger nos
marchés sont moroses instabilité
politique à hong kong obligeant
l'annulation du wine festival
l'interminable break site écroulement du
marché chinois où il ya cinq ans
la viticulture faisait déjà les frais
d'un conflit avec l'union européenne sur
les panneaux photovoltaïques un contexte
national en berne également attaqué de
toutes parts sur ses propres terres par
l'urbanisation rampante par la pression
sociétale sur l'environnement et la
traçabilité des produits mais aussi par
la raréfaction de la main d'oeuvre et
les problématiques de transmission le
modèle viticole français est
sérieusement ébranlé le vitib aching
fait son oeuvre et sapent le moral des
vignerons une filière qui fait tant
d'efforts
malgré les déchaînements climatiques et
concours largement à ce que la france
soit pour la troisième année consécutive
considéré comme ayant l'alimentation la
plus durable du monde
que faire monsieur le premier ministre
pour le vin qui occupe une place si
particulière dans la culture française
ainsi que dans notre économie puisque ce
sont plus de 500 mille emplois directs
et indirects
les élus du vin et des terroirs
regroupés en associations dont je suis
la coprésidente vous en proposer il y a
quelques semaines l'organisation en
urgence d'un grenelle de la victime
culture allez-vous y répondre par
l'affirmative
je vous remercie merci pour vos réponses
la parole est qu'à madame la secrétaire
d'état auprès de la milice des armes et
madame darrieussecq
ah pardon
non j'ai confondu avec le pinard
militaire la réponse est à didier
guillot ministre de l'agriculture et de
l'alimentation voilà je suis pas trop
mal sorti comme un moyen président il ne
s'agit que du vin tranquille
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
madame la sénatrice amélie de montchanin
a répondu avant sur la situation globale
concernant l'ensemble des filières suite
à la question du sénateur young qui ont
été moi donc de répondre
particulièrement sur votre question
concernant le vin français et vous dire
que comme l'a fait la sucre et des états
le gouvernement est tout entier mobilisé
bruno le maire est et à washington il ya
encore quelques heures pour essayer de
faire bouger ce qui va être difficile au
sahb le mans la position des américains
ce que nous ne souhaitons pas c'est
attendre les six mois de délai pour que
dans six mois la france met à son tour
d'autres sanctions parce que ce serait
la course à l'échalote et ce ne serait
pas bon donc nous privilégions
évidemment les solutions de compromis
mais on n'est pas totalement sûr
qu'elles arrivent immédiatement
aussi nous avons vraiment essayé de
mobiliser à la fois la commission
européenne et des positions françaises
lors du conseil des ministres de la
culture le 14 octobre dernier au nom de
l'italie de l'espagne et de la france je
suis intervenu pour demander la
solidarité des états membres est
intervenu pour demander à phil hogan le
commissaire à l'agriculture qui est
encore là pour quelques jours que
l'europe prenne des décisions
il faut absolument point de prendre des
décisions fortes un premièrement d une
décision de solidarité européenne
deuxièmement des décisions dead au
maintien économique et troisièmement des
décisions dead pour aller chercher de
nouveaux marchés
parce que si ce n'est pas le cas il y
aura de grosses difficultés dans la
filière viticole
c'est aujourd'hui toutes les régions qui
sont touchés c'est sur les vins d'entrée
de gamme et de et de volume et ses plus
de 300 millions d'euros dont il s'agit
s'il n'y avait pas quelque chose pour
compenser je pense que la filière
viticole comme vous le disait justement
quelques difficultés auraient du mal à
ça à s'en relever aussi aujourd'hui j'ai
envoyé un nouveau courrier au
commissaire européen pour lui demandé
trois choses que la commission finance
la mise en oeuvre rapide des programmes
de promotion
c'est absolument indispensable que des
garanties soient apportées aux
opérateurs
mettant en oeuvre ces mêmes mesures
parce qu'aujourd'hui les opérateurs sont
sûres sont sur la brèche et enfin que la
solidarité européenne viennent par
rapport à l'om c'est j'ai reçu il ya
l'ensemble de la filière viticole ils
ont des propositions à faire
nous sommes en train de l'est de les
regarder pour savoir comment nous
pourrions avancer je vous remercie
merci monsieur le ministre la parole est
à notre collègue andré richard pour le
groupe l'est républicain qu'avait la
parole mon cher collègue
merci monsieur le président ce premier
ministre je voudrais vous parler du
burkina faso
ce pays est miné par le développement du
terrorisme islamique et est au bord de
l'effondrement dès à présent un tiers de
son territoire est aux mains des
jihadistes alors que selon l'onu on
comptait fin août 2 190 mille déplacés
ils seront probablement cinq cent mille
à la fin de l'année 3000 écoles sont
déjà fermés de même que tous les
hôpitaux et dispensaires des zones
concernées
le pire est que l' influence des
terroristes ne cesse de grandir et
désormais ce sont des attaques quasi
quotidiennes qui frappe le pays avec
leurs cortèges de pertes humaines
militaire et civil l'armée nationale et
malheureusement impuissantes à endiguer
cette progression le risque est de voir
le scénario malien se rejouer dans ce
pays et ceci est d'autant plus grave que
le burkina faso n'est pas n'importe quel
pays il est assurément un verrou
stratégique pour bloquer l'expansion du
terrorisme vers les pays du golfe de
guinée
tel que le togo le bénin la côte
d'ivoire et le ghana qui s'inquiètent à
juste titre les pays de la cedeao ont
d'ailleurs solennellement tiré la
sonnette d'alarmé lors d'un sommet
extraordinaire mi septembre à
ouagadougou sur le premier ministre mais
question à cet égard sont simples
premièrement cinq ans après le succès de
l'opération serval qui avait permis
d'empêcher le renversement de l'état au
mali vu la gravité de la situation
burkina faso que compte entreprendre la
france le président de la république a
annoncé à la fin l'été je cite un
nouveau partenariat pour la sécurité et
la stabilité dans le sahel
ce partenariat peut assurément concerner
des pays européens mais également la
cedeao qui s'est notamment engagé à
financer une nouvelle force régionale à
côté et du g5 sahel pouvez vous nous
éclairer à ce sujet et enfin dans la
mesure où plus que
fondamentalisme religieux on le sait
c'est la pauvreté qui fait basculer la
population le terrorisme n'at-il pas
lieu de développer plus fortement et
spécifiquement l'aide au développement
dans ce pays en lien avec tous les
acteurs possibles sur le plan national
mais aussi international je vous
remercie pour vous répondre la parole
merci monsieur le président mesdames les
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur vous poser une
question importante et décrivez une
situation qui est effectivement la
situation très difficile du burkina faso
actuellement où les attaques terroristes
se multiplient où les victimes civiles
et militaires se multiplient également
puisque le week-end dernier encore
quatre militaires et un policier ont été
tués
vous décrivez aussi une détérioration de
la situation humanitaire c'est une
réalité
deux cent cinquante mille déplacés et
peut-être un million de deux personnes
qui sont soumises à l'aide qu'ils
auraient besoin des d'humanitaires dans
ce pays dont nous soutenons bien entendu
le burkina faso de différentes façons la
première vous le savez c'est de façon
militaire puisque nous avons une
coopération bilatérale avec le burkina
faso qui a été renforcé fin 2018 et nous
sommes à leurs côtés sur le plan du
renseignement de l'appui au feu mais
également de l'appui au commandement
afin qu'il lutte plus efficacement
contre le terrorisme
nous sommes à leurs côtés aussi vous le
savez dans l'opération du g5 sahel qui
permet à l'europe d'être en soutien de
ces cinq pays de leur armée afin de les
former et nous sommes dans soutient
également comme l'a dit le président de
la république lors du sommet de biarritz
nous sommes attentifs à ce partenariat
stratégique pour la sécurité et la
stabilité du sahel
l'ambition étant de soutenir la
communauté internet que la communauté
internationale pardon soutiennent et
augmente les capacités de chaque pays à
pouvoir se défendre et se protéger dans
cette zone
et nous sommes aussi au soutien du
burkina faso sur le plan du
développement puisque notre aide à
augmenter en 2010 960 millions d'euros
de la fcd dont 100 millions d'euros de
dons contre l'an dernier en 2010 800
millions d'euros
donc avec un soutien à l'entrepreneuriat
et à l'éducation
et il ya également l'alliance sahel qui
est une initiative franco allemande et
qui vise à améliorer l'aide au
développement
tout ceci se mette en ordre si je veux
dire d'action le plus efficacement
possible mais je suis d'accord avec vous
pour dire que le travail est immense que
nous devons rester humbles devant tout
cela mais surtout particulièrement actif
et je sais que vous êtes attentif à la
situation de ces pays merci la parole
est maintenant madame marie françoise
pérol dumont pour le groupe socialiste
avec le luth la malle chers collègues
merci président la quasi-totalité des
présidentes et présidents de
départements de france quittant la salle
lors de leur congrès annuel alors que la
ministre représentant le gouvernement
s'exprime est pour le moins inhabituel
mais lourd de sens
ces élus dans leur diversité politique
ont ainsi voulu dénoncer la mise sous
tutelle des budgets départementaux
engagé avec le pacte de cahors fin 2017
et confirmé par le plf 2020 ils
s'inquiètent à bon droit de la fin de
leur autonomie fiscale avec le transfert
de la taxe foncière aux communes pour
compenser la suppression de la taxe
d'habitation
ils ne se satisfont pas de l'octroi
d'une part de tva en compensation de
cette perte et ce pour trois raisons
vendu comme dynamique par le
gouvernement par le gouvernement cet
impôt est de fait très aléatoire et son
rendement s'inverse mécaniquement en
période de crise alors même que toute
crise engendre mécaniquement plus de
précarité et donc plus de dépenses et de
solidarité versées par les départements
par ailleurs la tva et en paix est payée
de même façon que l'on soit très riche
que l'on soit très pauvres via la
consommation il estime choquant et on
les comprend de voir les plus fragiles
payer pour des politiques sociales dont
ils sont censés être les bénéficiaires
enfin il dénonce la remise en cause
inacceptable de l'histoire et des
principes de la décentralisation via la
mise à mal de leur autonomie financière
et fiscale qu'elle suit le gouvernement
entend qu'il réservé à leurs légitimes
inquiétudes vont répondre la parole m
labellisé qu ayant des territoires et
des relations avec les collectivités
territoriales à l'âme jacqueline
gourault sénatrice pérol dumont
peut-être vous sera-t-il intéressant de
connaître que la baisse d'impôts en
moyenne pour les habitants de votre
département sera de madame vous avez pas
madame
je disais peut-être madame pérol dumont
cela vous intéresserait de savoir que la
baisse en moyenne pour les foyers de
votre département puisque vous avez
parlé des gens en difficulté ce que je
partage ces 744 euros par foyer fiscal
par ailleurs par ailleurs par ailleurs
il a été effectivement décidé de
compenser la perte du foncier bâti par
une fraction de tva qui s'élève à 15
milliards d'euros + 250 millions de
bonus je voudrais préciser ce que je
n'ai pas eu le temps de faire tout à
l'heure que la dynamique des 250
millions puisque les 250 millions sont
dynamiques comme le reste et bien
donneront lieu à une clause de
sauvegarde pour prévenir tout accident
qui pourrait arriver dans un département
c'est une solidarité supplémentaire
par ailleurs je voudrais préciser que
nous sommes véritablement dans une
fraction dynamique et non pas une
dotation puisque souvent on entend le
mot dotation et je voudrais comparer
puisque tout à l'heure monsieur martin a
parlé de la taxe professionnelle en 99
quand la part salaires de la taxe
professionnelle a été supprimée par quoi
at-elle été remplacée par une dotation
une vraie et sans dynamique de
croissance dont nous envoyons encore les
a fait aujourd'hui et je voulais vous le
rappeler tout simplement par ailleurs il
y a une clause de sauvegarde qui
garantit que la fraction de teillet a
versé ne sera jamais inférieure à celle
versée en 2021 et enfin je termine la
dynamique de la tva est en moyenne de 3%
depuis dix ans y compris les difficultés
de la crise de 2010 c'est à dire c'est
plus que le foncier bâti à la période du
vent
décidément la dame le ministre a écouté
votre réponse je crois que malgré les
mouvements journées de l'automne dernier
malgré les dernières estimations de
l'insee sur l'augmentation inquiétante
des inégalités et de la pauvreté dans ce
pays
cette dernière année le gouvernement n'a
décidément pas pris la mesure de la
fracture sociale et territoriale qui
s'installe dangereusement
vous pouvez toujours supprimées
l'observatoire national de la pauvreté
mais casser le thermomètre n'a jamais
fait baisser la température et gilles me
semble que vous seriez bien avisée
plutôt que de maltraiter les
départements de travailler avec eux à
leurs côtés chacun à sa place chacun
dans son rôle pour plus de cohésion
sociale et territoriale
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la parole est à notre collègue daniel
grémillet pour le groupe l'est
républicain
monsieur le président nos ministres le
président de la république le 11 octobre
2010 est déclaré les états généraux de
l'alimentation aux deux objectifs le
premier permettre aux agriculteurs de
vivre du ce de prix payé de permettre à
tous dans la chaîne de valeur de vivre
dignement et le second de permettre à
chacune et à chacun d'avoir accès à une
alimentation saine durable et sûre il
déclarait aussi il est plus possible
qu'aujourd'hui en france un tiers des
agriculteurs gagnent moins de 350 euros
par an et aujourd'hui où en sommes-nous
vous nous en est faite par mois par dont
vous nous avez fait naître beaucoup
d'espoirs vous nous avez parlé la montée
en gamme
la seule montée en gamme qu'ont vu les
agriculteurs ce sont des contraintes
supplémentaires
ce sont des charges supplémentaires ce
sont 80 intrusion dans des élevages
démontrant la maltraitance des animaux
et jamais on a vu une vidéo montrant un
agriculteur pleurer devant un animal qui
vient de périr ce qu'on leur fait croire
dans cette montée en gamme
c'est aussi les accords dumas corse où
les attaques hors du ceta voyez ce
ministre il y avait beaucoup d'attentes
et beaucoup d'espoirs vous l'avez vous
même déclaré cette semaine parce que
cette montée en gamme
rien n'est arrivé chez agriculteurs vous
avez dit les éditeurs n'ont pas eu le
fruit de cette loi et galim qu
allez-vous répondre aux agriculteurs à
qui vous avez fait naître autant
d'espoir pour nous répondre
[Musique]
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur des négriers
je partage votre inquiétude et vous dire
que le gouvernement et moi-même sont
tout entier derrière les agriculteurs
lorsque ceux ci sont montrés du doigt
lorsque ceux ci sont insultés lorsque
ceux ci sont violentés lorsque les
délais des élevages sont des bâtiments
d'élevage sont brûlés c'est inacceptable
la garde des sceaux est intervenue avait
écrit une instruction à tous les atouts
les procureurs et c'est inacceptable et
ça doit s'arrêter sur la deuxième partie
de votre question sur les états généraux
je crois que les états généraux ont
soulevé un espoir immense un espoir
immense qui c'est qui s'est conclue
conclue par une décision unanime de
l'ensemble du monde agricole des
industries agroalimentaires des
entreprises de transformation des
coopératives et de dessins des
responsables politiques pour dire qu'il
fallait changer la façon de faire est la
première chose qu'il fallait changer
c'était le prix payé aux agriculteurs il
est absolument inacceptable qu'un
agriculteur vent sont les ventes sa
viande en dessous du prix de revient
en dessous de ce que ça lui laisse que
ça lui repas et vous savez c'est pas
c'est pas en criant que vous ferez
augmenter le prix du lait ou le prix de
la viande mais c'est comme je le fais
depuis le début lundi en rencontrant
toutes les filières et encore jusqu'à ce
matin et toutes les filières saut dans
les mêmes conditions
ils veulent tous que les coûts de
production qu'ils ont eux mêmes fixé
soit respecté mais c'est pas le
gouvernement qu'il fait respecter c'est
le marché c'est je suis désolé ce sens
ce sont les coopératives qui achètent de
le lait c'est pas le gouvernement
ce sont les la grande distribution qui
achètent des produits ce n'est pas le
gouvernement
et c'est la raison pour laquelle nous en
sommes nous en sommes nous en sommes à
plus de 3000 contrôles de la dgccrf
il arrête de me la faire nous prendre
encore plus de sanctions s'il le faut il
faut que la grande distribution et les
entreprises respectent les agriculteurs
et achète le prix là où le prix que ça
corresponde aux et merci monsieur
grémillet
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le ministre je reprends la
conclusion du président de la république
qui disait ce que j'attends de vous pour
finir c'est de recréer la confiance
savez monsieur le ministre en
agriculture il pousse toujours quelque
chose
et lorsqu'on sème le vent récolte la
tempête
et aujourd'hui s'était exprimée par les
adducteurs hier hélas il y en a 300
compas pu manifester et monsieur
ministre faut pas mentir aux
agriculteurs il faut pas tromper la
société parce que aujourd'hui
d'aujourd'hui va dépendre ce qu'il y
aura dans la 07 de nos enfants demain
merci
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à notre collègue yves
detraigne pour le groupe de l'union
centriste mais le président madame ma
question s'adresse à madame la mise la
cohésion des territoires et des
relations avec les collectivités
territoriales
je souhaite appeler madame la ministre
votre attention sur la décision de
supprimer à compter du 31 décembre de
cette année le prêt à taux zéro
logements neufs pour les habitants des
zones b2 et c c'est-à-dire dans les
villes moyennes et les secteurs bureau
selon le gouvernement cette non
reconduction répondrait un double
objectif d'une part revitaliser les
centre bourgs anciens et d'autre part
lutter contre l'artificialisation des
sols et l'étalement urbain
en effet le prêt à taux zéro serait
maintenu dans ces deux zones pour
l'achat dans l'ancien jusqu'en 2021
pourtant la fin de ce dispositif risque
de mettre un coup d'arrêt à l'accession
à la propriété pour les jeunes familles
et par conséquent de pénaliser le
secteur du bâtiment
en outre cette disparition irait à
l'encontre des objectifs du président de
la république qui a fait de la réduction
des inégalités territoriales et du
développement harmonieux et équilibré
des territoires
l'une des priorités de son action la
mise en place de l'agenda rural que vous
portez madame la ministre devant je
rappelle de concrétiser et ancré dans la
durée les actions du gouvernement en
faveur des ruralités réservé ce ptz dans
le neuf aux grandes métropoles à une
partie de la côte d'azur mon corps à la
partie agglomérée de l'ile-de-france
soit les autres a et b1 serait un très
mauvais signal pour débuter l'agenda
rural je vous demande donc de bien
vouloir examiner ce dossier et maintenir
le dispositif du prêt à taux zéro dans
les zones b2 et c pour vous répondre la
parole de cabrel jacqueline gourault
plus de la cohésion du territoire
monsieur le sénateur il detraigne le
gouvernement a déjà fait connaître son
souhait de recentrer progressivement le
ptz 9 sur les zones les plus tendues là
où le besoin en logements neufs et le
plus
or pour les concitoyens afin de donner
de la visibilité aux professionnels nous
avons toutefois c'est le choix de
reconduire le livre le dispositif
pendant deux ans dans les zones b2 et c
avec une quotité de 20% pour ce qui
concerne le ptz dans l'ancien nous
l'avons recentrer sur les zones les
moins tendues car c'est dans ces
territoires que les besoins de
rénovation sont les plus forts dans ces
territoires l'enjeu à relever est aussi
celui de la diminution de la vacance des
logements résorber la vacance est
essentiel parce que comme vous l'avez
dit tout à l'heure c'est d'abord aux
frais rapidement des logements
supplémentaires
cela évite de consommer de l'espace et
de l'actif issia lise et enfin parce que
cela permet de faire revenir des
habitants dans les centralités des
villes moyennes et petites
ceci va dans le sens de programme action
coeur de ville est petite ville de
demain que nous allons lancer notamment
dans le cas de la une c'est et avant une
nouvelle décision sur le ptz dans le
neuf
le gouvernement a donc souhaité prendre
le temps de la réflexion et disposer d'
analyses précises c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous avons demandé un rapport
d'évaluation qui sera remis
prochainement et qui permettra
d'éclairer le débat parlementaire sur la
base de ce travail et des orientations
fixées notamment dans l'agenda rural
comme vous l'avez rappelé monsieur le
sénateur de nouvelles pistes pourront
être explorées et mises en oeuvre
je pense en particulier à la
prolongation du ptz pour de gros travaux
et de gros travaux pardon assimilé à du
neuf
je vous remercie sur le trail merci par
l'état notre collègue madame patricia
mohr erichot pour le groupe l'est
républicain
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues
monsieur le premier ministre en montagne
avant l'arrivée de la neige la saison du
des montagnes âge est synonyme
d'activités économiques sociales et
culturelles instance intense dans nos
vallées à l'automne sont organisées dans
les territoires alpins et pyrénéens les
grandes foires agricoles celles où
éleveurs maquignons et bergers se
retrouvent le temps d'une journée pour
partager les dernières anecdotes de la
saison des steve et vendre leurs bêtes
des agneaux dévots qui n'ont pas encore
connu les étables nom des bêtes élevées
en plein air avec soin et j'ose le dire
avec amour
cette année pourtant à la traditionnelle
foire tarder en duo champsaur il était
impossible d'acheter les brebis
malgré la qualité des produits locaux
malgré le soleil et les couleurs
d'automne le temps n'était pas à la fête
d'ailleurs de nombreux maires venus des
hautes-alpes et des
alpes-de-haute-provence du vaucluse des
alpes maritimes s'étaient rendus jusqu à
champoléon pour exprimer leur soutien
aux éleveurs pour interpeller les
pouvoirs publics sur une réalité qui
n'est plus tenable
en effet dans certains alpages comme
ceux situés au coeur du parc national
des écrins
il est impossible d'appliquer les
mesures de protection du plan national
d'action sur le loup et les activités
d'élevage
malgré les dispositifs date berger de
filet et de chaînes de protection
le loup au fil des années gagne des
territoires et aujourd'hui se pose la
question du devenir de l'agro
pastoralisme en montagne la question
n'est pas qui du ministre de la
transition écologique et solidaire ou du
ministre de l'agriculture et de
l'alimentation aura le dernier mot
non monsieur le premier ministre la
question et la france veut-elle ou
normes et tenir la tradition du
pastoralisme et la vie qui va avec
pour vous répondre le parent le
communiqué culture
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice
je connais votre engagement sur l'agro
pastoralisme la défense des éleveurs et
je vais vous dire que le gouvernement a
un objectif que notre tradition
agropastoral continue que les bergers
reste dans nos montagnes et que l'on
continue à voir sans de troupeau c'est
la raison pour laquelle c'est la raison
pour laquelle et moi je ne rigole pas là
dessus et je ne rigole pas je fais pas
de polémiques là dessus pour une bonne
et simple raison que quand un éleveur
voix 150 brebis des rochers quant aux
éleveurs voir ses brebis égorgées
quand on est 9 heures et stressé passe
la nuit sans dormir pour surveiller son
troupeau
il ne fait pas son travail ce n'est pas
son boulot à lui et c'est la raison pour
laquelle le gouvernement a mis en place
un plan loup cette année comme jamais
nous avons doublé le nombre de
prélèvements vont donner des moyens
comme jamais pour faire en sorte que les
le pastoralisme puisse se maintenir
et vous connaissez la position du
gouvernement entre l'éleveur et le
prédateur nous choisirons toujours
l'éleveur et c'est la raison pour
laquelle le nombre de prélèvements
étaient doublés cette année madame vous
le savez vous le savez vous le savez
très bien et c'est la raison pour
laquelle le nouveau plan loup coordonné
par le préfet mailhos a mis un certain
nombre de responsabilités de
possibilités de tir de prélèvement de
tirs d'effarouchement nous en sommes
quasiment à 100 tirs de prélèvement et
si ce centième loup devait être prélevés
et bien le préfet l'a dit nous
augmenterions le plafond et
parallèlement on sait très bien que ce
sujet est un sujet européen
c'est la raison pour laquelle pour la
première fois on peut beaucoup parlé
mais pour la première fois ce n'est
jamais arrivé
la france a posé ce dossier au niveau de
l'union européenne
au niveau du conseil des ministres de
l'europe en disant oui à la biodiversité
mais oui à léquilibre agro pastoral et
c'est la raison pour laquelle un certain
nombre de pays est en train de mettre en
place un texte pour faire en sorte que
le guide interprétatif sur les espèces
en voie de disparition plus bouger
puisque aujourd'hui le gouvernement a
annoncé qu'il avait plus de 500 loup et
le loup n'est plus une espèce en voie de
disparition de notre pays je vous
remercie
madame aurait ri cho
ce n'est pas suffisant il est temps que
le gouvernement prenne ses
responsabilités et assume ses choix
il est temps que les paroles soit en
adéquation avec les actes et que le
gouvernement explique aux consommateurs
qui n'est pas favorable à l'élevage
extensif car ils préfèrent abandonner la
montagne au loup et à l'ours
merci
la parole est à notre collègue josiane
cause pour le groupe du rassemblement
démocratique et social européen
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à madame la ministre de la
transition écologique et solidaire
madame la ministre comme vous l'avait
annoncé en juillet dernier et
conformément aux prix aux préconisations
de la mission d'information sur le
désenclavement des territoires par le
transport aérienne dont j'ai été la
rapporteure les vols vers les
territoires ultramarins la corse ainsi
que les lignes d'aménagement du
territoire son obligation de service
public seront exemptés de la hausse de
la taxe de solidarité prévu dans le plf
2020 mais un amendement déposé par le
gouvernement a adopté à l'assemblée
nationale prévoit que cette exonération
sera subordonnée à la réponse de la
commission européenne permettant de
considérer ce dispositif législatif
comme conforme au droit de l'union
européenne
à ce stade il n'est pas du tout certain
que la commission autorise l'exonération
dans le meilleur des cas le risque est
que l'exonération ne soit pas appliquée
dès le 1er janvier 2020
dans le pire des cas que l'exonération
ne soit pas autorisée du tout ses vols
vous le savez madame la ministre sont
indispensables à l'aménagement du
territoire et une hausse de la taxation
mettraient en danger leur équilibre
économique extrêmement fragile madame la
ministre pouvait vous garantir que le
gouvernement s'assurera que la
commission se prononce avant janvier
si ces vols devaient au final être
imposées temporairement ou de manière
permanente
pouvez-vous nous assurer que l'état
prendra en charge la pleine compensation
de la hausse de la taxation pour vous
répondre la parole et tables de la ville
disposition écologique solidaire mais
d'abord nous avez la parole merci
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice josiane cost alors comme vous
le rappelez c'était qu'aux contributions
c'est un fou c'est un choix à la fois
écologique et de justice c'est une
réponse à beaucoup de nos concitoyens
qui nous ont dit ne pas comprendre
pourquoi ils paient une fiscalité
carbone sur leur carburant tandis que
d'autres français
n'en payent pas sur le transport aérien
cet éco contribution elle ira à 100% au
financement de transports propres et
notamment au désenclavement des
territoires puisqu'elle sera
intégralement affectée à la fit est
concrètement elle s'appliquera à toutes
les compagnies qu'elles soient quelle
que soit leur nationalité si bien que
les deux tiers de cette de cet éco
contribution seront payés par des
compagnies étrangères
je rappelle qu'une telle
éco-contribution existe déjà dans de
nombreux pays et que nous sommes le seul
à moduler cette contribution en fonction
des classes éco ou à faire les classes
affaires payant 6 fois plus que les
classes économiques
elle s'appliquera à tous les vols au
départ de la france mais comme vous
l'avez rappelé nous avons souhaité poser
un certain nombre d'exonérations pour
les liaisons avec les outre-mer la corse
et pour les liaisons d'aménagement du
territoire
parce que je sais le rôle vital que
jouent ces liaisons pour les
désenclavement de ces territoires pour
leur développement économique
et c'est d'ailleurs pour ça que nous
avons renforcé le soutien en faveur de
ses liaisons et c'est pour ça que nous
ne souhaitons donc pas leur appliquer
cet éco contribution alors nous avons
souhaité faire preuve de la plus grande
prudence en notifiant cette aide au
niveau de cet éco contribution à la
commission européenne
les premiers échos que nous avons nous
rendre très confiant sur l'acceptation
par la commission européenne de ces
exonérations et donc l'objectif est bien
d'avoir un accord de la commission avant
la fin de cette année je vous le
confirme en cause je vous remercie
madame la ministre pour ses propos
rassurant parce que vous savez comme
combien ces lignes d'aménagement du
territoire sont importantes pour nos
territoires isolés les outre-mer où les
territoires très enclavée que nous avons
encore dans notre pays
les billets d'avion sont chères et donc
évidemment les passagers ne saurait
supporter les hausses de taxes et les
collectivités territoriales de ces
territoires également sont en général
très fragile au niveau des budgets
donc on espère que l'exonération sera
totale merci beaucoup merci la parole
est maintenant ne peut que
nicole bonnefoy pour le groupe
socialiste et républicain
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à madame la ministre de la
transition écologique et solidaire en
mars dernier lors de la clôture des
assises du transport aérien vos affaires
vous affirmiez madame la ministre et je
vous cite que nous pouvions
collectivement faire mieux pour la
compétitivité économique notre pavillon
français
quelques mois plus tard alors que deux
compagnie aérienne française aigle azur
et xl airways annoncent leur faillite
laissant sur le carreau plus de 1700
salariés
le gouvernement propose une hausse de la
taxe de solidarité d'environ 200
millions d'euros sur les billets d'avion
dispositions fiscales qui n'est en
réalité qu'une variable d'ajustement
budgétaire peut-être madame la ministre
y at-il entre nous un malentendu sur la
définition que vous donnez à la notion
de compétitivité ou peut-être la
politique du gouvernement manque t'elle
de cohérence voire de vision stratégique
en effet si une éco taxe sur les
transports aériens peut être mise en
place
elle ne doit l'être qu'à l'échelle
européenne internationale afin d'éviter
de rajouter des difficultés à une
filière de transport ou la concurrence
avec les compagnies étrangères est déjà
particulièrement féroce et vous le savez
mes questions sont donc simples madame
la ministre
avez vous abandonné l'ambition de
redresser la situation du transport
aérien français
avez vous également abandonner vos
enfants de vos ambitions
environnementales en préférant utiliser
la taxation de l'aérien comme variable
d'ajustement budgétaire plutôt que comme
véritable levier d'accompagnement du
secteur aérien dans la recherche et
développement ou couple est plus
particulièrement pour la structuration
d'une filière de biocarburants qui est
appelé de leurs voeux par nos compagnies
aériennes pour vous répondre la parole
est à mon avis la transition écologique
d'abord merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
madame la sénatrice nicole bonnefoy
alors je voudrais vous redire que cette
contribution elle répond à une attente
très forte des français je pense partout
en france et également en charente qui
ne comprennent pas pourquoi ils paient
une fiscalité carbone sur le carburant
de leur voiture et que le kérosène comme
ça chacun le sait n'est pas exonéré je
pourrais ajouter qu'il ne paye pas non
plus de tva sur les vols intérieurs
contrairement aux trains internet
queneau et donc c'est dans ce contexte
et en effet pour financer une politique
de transport du quotidien de transport
propre que nous avons décidé de mettre à
contribution le secteur aérien mais je
voudrais vous redire que cette
contribution elles s'appliquent à toutes
les compagnies et redire que ce sera
donc payé à deux tiers par les
compagnies étrangères
je vous invite comme j'invite les
compagnies aériennes françaises à
regarder la fiscalité qui s'applique
chez nos voisins et c'est tout à fait
édifiant puisqu'on peut alors constater
que contrairement à ce que certaines
compagnies françaises soutiennent la
fiscalité est plus élevée sur les
billets en allemagne ou au royaume-uni
qu'elle ne l'est en france
je voudrais rappeler au passage que
l'allemagne vient de décider d'augmenter
la taxe sur ses propres billets de 74%
donc effectivement il faut mener cette
réflexion au niveau européen c'est un
premier signal que nous avons souhaité
donner en mettant en place cette éco
contribution mais je pense qu'il ne faut
pas imputer à la fiscalité les
difficultés que les deux compagnies dont
je regrette comme pour toute entreprise
qu'elle ait dû déposer leur bilan
c'est toujours un drame pour les
salariés mais je pense que c'est aussi
des choix des entreprises de se lancer
sur le long courrier pour une compagnie
historiquement sur le moyen-courrier de
vouloir se lancer sur le marché du low
cost long courrier qui est un marché
extrêmement compétitif mais en tout cas
ça ne remet pas en cause notre ambition
de mettre en place une fiscalité
écologique juste et respectueuse de
l'aménagement de nos territoires
maintenant votre foi oui madame la
ministre la situation est alarmante et
les enjeux majeurs je le rappelle
environ 2000 emplois qui ont déjà été
supprimés comme je l'aï dit tout à
l'heure et ce n'est pas par hasard
nous devons nous donner l'ambition avec
le secteur aérien de continuer à faire
de ce mode de transport un levier de
puissance vous préparer notre industrie
à l'avion de demain
l'état se doit d'accompagner la mutation
technologique et environnementale du
secteur aérien en soutenant massivement
la recherche de développement
la structuration d'une filière de
biocarburants c'est cela une vraie
politique éco-responsable
n'oublions jamais que les compagnies
aériennes sont la marque d'une grande
nation vecteurs
majeur du désenclavement du territoire
de notre lien avec le monde
elles sont essentielles à notre
rayonnement international
merci la parole est à notre collègue
marc laménie pour le groupe l'est
républicain
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre madame et messieurs les
ministres chers collègues ma question
s'adresse à madame la ministre de la
transition écologique et solidaire et
merci par ailleurs mme collègue laure
darcos de me céder sa place sur un sujet
sensible pression' beaucoup la défense
du rail des usagers et des cheminots se
l'était rappeler l'accident du ter
compétences régionales qui dans les
ardennes la semaine dernière il y a une
semaine reliant charleville mézières à
reims a heurté un convoi exceptionnel
qui est resté coincé sur un passage à
niveau
onze blessés malgré son état de choc et
ses blessures le conducteur et aider les
passagers blessés plusieurs ont été
hospitalisés grâce à son sang froid
le conducteur seul a évité de justesse
un sur accident qui aurait pu s'avérer
dramatiques pour les 80 passagers
il a en effet longer les voix sur plus
d'un kilomètre pour avertir le train
suivant drame évité grâce à sa
conscience professionnelle à ce
conducteur attaché à son métier qui a
d'ailleurs tenu à rester discret cet
accident met en lumière malheureusement
des dysfonctionnements des difficultés
récurrentes d'organisation de la sncf
retards réguliers mécontentement des
usagers mais aussi des agents qui va
croissant par ailleurs la prise en
otages des passagers n'est pas forcément
la meilleure solution
la sncf fonctionne mal les raisons sont
multiples et la réforme
malheureusement il n'y a rien changé
madame la ministre l'administration de
votre collègue madame pénicaud menis du
travail recommande à la sncf de
suspendre le dispositif agents seule la
disparition des contrôleurs et des
moyens humains n'est pas la bonne
solution nous aimerions connaître
l'opposition adam la mise quels moyens
sont mis en place pour lutter contre la
fraude dans les trains dépourvus de
contrôleurs c'est cet accident rappelle
également la dangerosité des passages à
niveau où en sommes-nous madame la
ministre dans l'exécution programme
national de sécurisation des passages à
niveau qui avait fait l'objet d'une
opération de communication de votre part
il y a quelques mois merci d'écouter
d'entendre les élus de proximité les
usagers les cheminots sur le terrain
merci
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur laménie je vous remercie de me
donner l'occasion de redire que l'après
la sécurité c'est la première des
priorités et je sais qu'elle est dans
l'adn des cheminots je sais leur
attachement à cette priorité et je
voudrais rendre hommage au conducteur du
ter accidenté pour son très grand
professionnalisme
il a eu les bons réflexes qui ont permis
d'assurer la sécurité des voyageurs
donc la sécurité c'est aussi notre
priorité absolue c'est bien le sens des
enquêtes qui ont été lancées aussi bien
au sein de l'entreprise que l' enquête
du bureau enquête accident de mon
ministère
et comme chaque fois toutes les leçons
seront tirées alors pour revenir aux
conduites aux équipements agent seul je
voudrais rappeler que c'est un
dispositif qui existe depuis 40 ans en
ile de france depuis près d'une dizaine
d'années en région et qui a notamment
pour objectif de permettre aux
contrôleurs d'intervenir non pas seul
dans un train mais plutôt en équipe
ce qui est aussi bénéfique à leur propre
sécurité
je note au passage qu effectivement une
inspectrice du travail a envoyé une
lettre de recommandation à la direction
de la sncf la direction générale du
travail a eu l'occasion de dire qu'elle
ne partageait pas cette analyse
mais au delà au delà moi j'ai constaté
que des circulation avait été
interrompue sur des tgv sur des trains
de nuit qui à ma connaissance ne sont
pas équipés agents semaine à la
présidente assassi sur des corail
intercités ce qui relie paris a
clairement paris à l'image donc je pense
que dans ces conditions on peut se dire
qu'on était bien loin du droit de
retrait donc nous sommes tous attachés
ici à la sécurité ferroviaire au respect
du droit de grève
comme nous sommes tous attachés au
service public cela veut dire aussi
penser aux usagers mais
si nous avons terminé merci monsieur le
premier ministre
dams et messieurs les ministres avec les
questions au gouvernement les prochaines
auront lieu mercredi 30 octobre devait
suspendre la séance qui sera reprise à
16h30 pour l'examen de la proposition de
loi visant à adapter la fiscalité de la
succession de la donation aux enjeux
démographiques sociétaux économiques du
21e siècle
la séance est suspendue alors comme vous
venez de l'entendre il a notamment été
question de la grève surprise à la sncf
lors de ces questions d'actualité alors
la présidente du groupe communiste a
interpellé le premier ministre en début
de séance sur la sécurité des trains
edouard philippe a été applaudi à droite
de l'hémicycle puisqu'il a une nouvelle
fois condamné le jeu site détournement
du droit de retrait alors si à gauche on
ne doute pas de la légitimité pour les
agents de la sncf a exercé leur droit de
retrait à droite et au centre on réclame
des sanctions c'est le cas d' emmanuel
capus sénateurs les indépendants écoutez
le
la confusion des demandes mêlé à une
disproportion totale démontrent l'abus
du droit de retrait le danger grave et
imminent a semble-t-il d'ailleurs
disparu car le travail a repris sans
qu'on puisse savoir ce qui a changé
depuis mercredi dernier c'est le
caractère inique de ce mouvement
madame la ministre la question est donc
très simple pouvez-vous nous assurer que
ces dérives inacceptables sont
sanctionnés afin que le droit de retrait
ne devienne pas la façon commode de
détourner la grève alors la ministre des
transports et les apps est borgne s'est
contenté de répéter qu'elle avait été
choquée par cette grève surprise mais
elle n'a pas dit un mot sur
d'éventuelles sanctions comme le lui
avait demandé le sénateur
enfin lors de ces questions d'actualité
au gouvernement il a été question de la
guerre commerciale qui fait rage entre
les états unis et l'union européenne
mais également de la grille bashing
quelques sénateurs ont interpellé didier
guillaume le ministre de l'agriculture
voilà tout de suite
le débriefing de ces questions
d'actualité avec vous
tam et je vous retrouve donc la semaine
prochaine pour les prochaines questions
d'actualité au gouvernement
merci beaucoup à l'iss pour toutes ces
explications effectivement vous l'avez
dit on va maintenant débriefer les temps
forts de cette séance avec mes invités
sur ce plateau à l'extérieur - restez
avec nous merci beaucoup
vous êtes je le rappelle présidente du
think tank france audacieuse et du
mouvement politique nous citoyens en
france nous a rejoint également henri
cabanel bonjour vous êtes sénateur rds
de l'hérault je rappelle que vous êtes à
l'origine d'une proposition de loi qui
vise à prévenir le suicide des
agriculteurs les agriculteurs y en a
beaucoup été question lors de cette
séance de questions d'actualité au
gouvernement on va en reparler également
avec nous sur ce plateau andré reichardt
bonjour sénateurs les républicains du
bas-rhin merci beaucoup d'être ici et en
plateau et enfin jean claude tissot
bonjour sénateurs socialistes de la
loire
je vais revenir avec vous notamment bien
sûr cette question de la sncf qui a
largement occupé cette séance de
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
notamment et bien avec l'intervention
d'eliane assassi eliane assassi
d'ailleurs qui est au micro d'alexandre
poussard alexandre la présidente du
groupe communiste au sénat a tout à
l'heure interpeller le premier ministre
sur la sncf et le mouvement de grève
qu'il y a eu les jours derniers
oui le premier ce qui avait le week-end
dernier pas parler de grève sauvage des
cheminots est-ce qu'il y en ait six vous
avez trouvé que cet après midi le
premier ministre à apaiser la situation
non je ne crois pas qu'il l'ait apaisé
pour preuve les nombreux messages que
j'ai reçus après mon intervention est la
réponse du premier ministre qui persiste
à dire qu'il s'agissait d'un mouvement
de grève alors que c'est simplement les
cheminots qui ont fait valoir leur droit
de retrait je pense qu'il ya une
sémantique est utilisé par le
gouvernement qui est dangereuse qui
triste en fait les relations avec les
cheminots mais aussi avec les usagers
moi ma question portait simplement sur
les questions de sécurité
il ya quelle mesure le gouvernement
comptait prendre pour assurer la
sécurité à la fois des cheminots et des
usagers et je n'ai pas eu de réponse
d'abord une question sur le droit de
retrait edouard philippe a demandé
pourquoi il y avait des conducteurs de
we go de tgv qui avait qui s'était
retirée alors que cet accident concerné
l'été les ter pourquoi mais c'est le
droit de retrait je les reprises et dans
ma question il est bien précis dans sa
définition qu'on retrouve dans le code
du travail vous savez
dix sept mille cheminots sur les 23000
conducteurs qui ont fait valoir leur
droit de retrait et ça a du sens quand
même ce n'est pas une dizaine ce n'est
pas une centaine 17000 sur 23 me donc
les cheminots pense et je partage leur
sentiment qu'ils peuvent être en danger
et que effectivement des usagers à
l'instar de ce qui s'est passé sur le
ter en ardenne peuvent être en danger et
que la direction comme le gouvernement
qui est actionnaire quand même le seul
actionnaire de la sncf ne répondent pas
à leurs à leurs questionnements et je
pense qu on appelle ce pas là le
dialogue social n'existe pas ou peu aux
à la sncf entre la sncf la direction et
le gouvernement et je pense qu'il serait
temps quand même de se décrisper et de
mettre en oeuvre effectivement ce
dialogue social pour répondre aux
besoins à la fois des cheminots et des
usagers très bien faire un pas vers le
dialogue social merci
question merci merci beaucoup alexandre
pour cette réaction va parler de cela en
plateau mais tout de même je voudrais
qu'on revienne à la séance de questions
d'actualité au gouvernement pour
entendre les changes qui a eu eliane
assassi avec le premier ministre et pour
que l'on puisse bien comprendre quelle a
été la réponse de l'exécutif
on va tout de suite retrouvé et bien ce
moment de la séance en un autorail ter a
percuté un convoi routier faisant 11
blessés
cet accident grave a déclenché le droit
de retrait de 17 mille cheminots sur les
23 1000 conducteurs et contrôleurs soit
+2 73%
ces agents ont considéré que les
conditions de sécurité n'étaient pas ou
plus assurée ni le gouvernement ni
l'entreprise n'ont répondu à ses
inquiétudes légitimes préférant par un
écran de fumée relancer un énième débat
sur le droit de grève
madame la présidente mon analyse celle
de la direction de la sncf
c'est que à ce moment là précis dans le
contexte de l'entreprise
quelque chose qui relève du détournement
du droit de retrait a été effectué et si
ce détournement du droit de retrait est
utilisé pour ne pas respecter les
obligations d'information en matière de
grève dans les services publics alors en
effet c'est inacceptable henri cabanel
détournement du droit de retrait dis
donc le premier ministre à ce que vous
êtes d'accord avec son analyse alors de
la question qui était posée
il faut quand même souligner la
problématique de l'accident qui est
intervenu sur c'est d'abord la sécurité
qui s'épousent est au niveau des usagers
et haut niveau donc du conducteur de ce
train puisque il s'est pris il s'est
trouvé dans une situation totalement
seul devant donc la responsabilité
qu'ils avaient de pouvoir porter secours
à aux usagers qui était blessé dans la
réponse du premier ministre
effectivement on sent qu'il y a deux
interprétations différentes dans le
cadre du droit de retrait parce que
l'ordre ont repris a donc une définition
précise sur des dangers et par rapport à
la sécurité
effectivement le premier ministre a
évoqué les conducteurs de tgv qui peut
être ai je partage assez aussi n'avait
pas à s'engager dans le droit de retrait
puisque un même accessible dans leur
travail n'était pas un danger
particulier charte y at il eu un
détournement des droits de retrait selon
vous pour reprendre les mots du premier
ministre avec et bien cette pagaille
effectivement qu'il y a eu vendredi
premier jour des vacances pour de
nombreux usagers assurément
assurément moi je le dis en âme et
conscience je suis pas du tout marcheur
je suis du groupe plr donc je peux pas
être soupçonné de des collisions avec
l'excellent ecolutions moi je pense
qu'effectivement il ya eu un
détournement du droit de retrait
on l'a dit clairement autant on peut
comprendre qu' il puisse se poser des
questions de sécurité liées à la
présence d'un seul une seule personne
seul agent donc le conducteur dans un
ter autant on aura du mal à nous faire
comprendre comment à un conducteur de
tgv peut être utilisé son droit de
retrait pour ne plus marcher clairement
il ya certainement dans cette affaire à
la fois un droit de retrait mais aussi
le monte à travers une grève surprise
d'en découdre avec le gouvernement c'est
clair ou avec la sncf
et ça franchement aller à un moment on
sait que les familles ont besoin de
voyager etc
c'est pas normal jean claude tissot
alors est ce que pour vous effectivement
c'est un c'est plutôt un conflit social
qu'un véritable droit de retrait ce que
tout cela aussi annoncé à la grève
illimitée pour le mois de décembre j'ai
pas si c'est un conflit social mais moi
je partage pas l'avis de mon collègue
mais qu'est ce que vous faites de la
solidarité
si aujourd'hui les conducteurs de tgv
n'avait pas utilisé leur droit de
retrait croyez-vous qu'on aurait parlé
comme aujourd'hui on en parle de
l'incident qui est à l'accident qui est
arrivé sur la voie d'un ter
bien sûr quand il ya une grève de train
du conducteur
ces impacts une population les usagers
mais on devrait plutôt être avec eux
dans leurs revendications
parce que c'est
notre intérêt c'est pour notre sécurité
que ces gens-là manifeste s'ils
manifestent comme les infirmières en
partant en grève sur leur boulot sur
leurs blousons ça va pas être efficace
où les conducteurs de trains ou cas
aussi marqué en grève sur le pare brise
du train et je suis pas sûr que ça
marche donc si hélas hélas je pense que
la responsabilité elle revient au
gouvernement
on a reçu tous dans nos permanences des
gens de la sncf qui nous disent
aujourd'hui alors je sais plus le nom de
l'agent de la fonction mais ils sont sur
les quais il accompagne les départs des
trains et ces gens là ils vont être
supprimés le conducteur sera seul pour
démarrer le train donc on va plus
personne ne va s'assurer si les portes
sont fermées si quelqu'un est coincé ici
un gamin qui court au long de la voie
jusqu'à là il y avait quelqu'un qui
disait aux conducteurs de train ne part
pas s'il ya un danger aujourd'hui on
voulait supprimer les alerter sur le
fait mais bien sûr il ya de moins en
moins de personnel
le projet videmment karité une veille de
vacances un week-end c'est embêtant on
est tous impact et si on utilise le
train mais s'il faut faire grève s'ils
ici font grève entre deux heures du
matin et 5 heures du matin certes ça va
moins gêné le monde mais je suis pas sûr
qu'on en parle et rit elle exerçait une
grève c'est pas un droit de retrait ce
cas là on respecte les obligations de
service public etc
sinon à quoi ça sert qu'on légifère pour
précisément permettre aux usagers de se
retourner à travers un droit de préavis
et c'est une obligation précise mme
alexa j'ai renoncé
c'est une grève pour vous une grève
sauvage et bien un droit d'un droit de
retrait bien sûr c'est un bras de fer
politique et on le voit du point de vue
de l'utilisation d'une grève sauvage et
trouvé que de ce point de vue là la la
répartie qu'avait eue
elisabeth borne était intéressante parce
qu'elle remettait bien
en exergue les différentes priorités
quand vous parlez de service public
normalement vous devez penser en
priorité à l'usagé dans la sécurité par
la sécurité et aussi bien sûr ça on est
tous d'accord mais aussi par une
application stricte du droit de grève
c'est en plus un week-end de vacances de
départs en vacances
donc c'est vraiment un détournement en
fait des moyens juridiques qui sont
mises à disposition et je note juste le
regard de l'ancien avocat
mais je note juste que les deux avis qui
ont été données par les inspecteurs du
travail sont en voie d'être certainement
noté en tout cas par la direction
générale du travail qui qui n'a pas
l'air de partager tout à fait le même
point de vue donc c'est instructif de ce
point de vue là aussi andré reichardt
vous avez entendu ce qu'a dit jean
claude tissot une grève si c'est ça ne
gêne personne
ben ça ne marche pas ça ne sert à rien
on peut aussi comprendre qu'ils
utilisent ce jour-là par rapport est
bien a effectivement tout le conflit
social qui est en train de s'annoncer et
toutes les revendications du personnel
de la sncf
mais je n'en disconviens pas une grève
par définition doit être utile
bon sinon bon par contre il ya des il ya
des contraintes au droit de grève qui
ont été instaurées dans ton dont 11 par
le législateur il faut respecter cela
enfin encore une fois si on doit
prévenir pour permettre effectivement au
service public de 2 de mettre en oeuvre
quelques dispositifs
demandes d'informations des usagers mais
deuxièmement aussi pourquoi pas de
faciliter le fluidité de la circulation
à ce moment là écoutez il faut respecter
le droit et je comprends bien ce que tu
dis mais quand une fois entre droit de
retrait et les grèves se sont bien deux
choses totalement différentes mais on ne
disconvient pas personne ne disconvient
à l'obligation de sécurité des usagers
on est bien que si on va un petit peu
plus loin et qu'on part du strict cas de
cette histoire de droit de retrait est
ce que c'est aussi une répétition et
bien du conflit social qui est en train
de s'animer à la sncf est ailleurs henri
cabanel à l'égard du gouvernement voilà
je passe ce que le le vrai problème
il est donc dans le dialecte de lier le
dialogue social par d'eau en amont
il n'y a qu'à regarder nos voisins
pourquoi nos voisines
ça se passe aussi bien enfin quand je
dis aussi bien il ya moins de grèves
quand même que 1 phrase pourquoi culture
française à la graine non mais pourquoi
parce que à namur il ya une discussion
avec les syndicats et on essaie de
trouver des solutions aux problèmes
aujourd'hui force est de constater que
certains syndicats ont tiré la sonnette
d'alarmé sur le problème de sécurité et
qu'il a fallu attendre un accident
supplémentaire pour effectivement trouvé
la problématique et essayer de résoudre
après donc tout notre problème vienne à
notre système français où anna mans on
n'est pas suffisamment cohérent et les
uns et les autres pour pouvoir trouver
une entente qui permettrait donc de
résoudre les problèmes bien à maman
avant que l'accident soit la clôture
vous êtes d'accord un manque de dialogue
social dans l'entreprise et peut-être
aussi entre eux d'un si on prend ça
comme une image entre l'exécutif et
aujourd'hui
bien les manifestants dans la rue quand
on voit le nombre de conflits sociaux
qu'il y avait depuis le début de
l'automne
ben oui surtout que je mettrais une fin
toute la problématique gilet jaune si on
peut appeler ce mouvement-là de cette
manière là et ce qui se passe a laissé
faire parce que c est il ya des gens qui
sont identifiés comme tels il ya des
syndicats qui sont là qui le
gouvernement ne peut pas dire on sait
pas qui c'est vrai c'est aujourd'hui on
n'a pas un grand débat pour pour savoir
quelles sont les mesures à prendre très
rapidement pour que justement la
sécurité soit absolument respecter et je
suis désolé le gouvernement j'ai entendu
les réponses de madame bordés et du
premier ministre
le droit de retrait les arrange bien
quoi du coup parce que c'est évident de
parler vraiment du fond du problème
et moi je le regrette et bien sûr bien
sûr quand dia d'un préavis de grève ça
c'est mieux on va s'organiser quand on
arrive sur le quai de la gare et que le
train est annulé et ça m'est arrivé
plusieurs fois c'est très désagréable
mais ma foi mais je pense que oui c'est
vrai on est ce que c est ce que c'est
les prémices d'un mouvement de fin
d'année la lettre mais alors justement
dit que le gouvernement l'entende
et qu'on se retrouve pas dans cette
situation là la semaine des fêtes de
noël quoi effectivement c'est ce qui est
prévu un andré reichardt un mois de
décembre très compliquée pour les
usagers
et tout cela c'est notamment dû à la
réforme des retraites pourtant bien
c'était un sujet sur lesquelles
l'exécutif fait beaucoup de
consultations et c'est un sujet qu'il ne
cesse de reporter et pourtant et bien on
le voit la fronde le difficultés
sociales sont là je ne sais pas moi
qu'il faut poser cette question je crois
que c'est au gouvernement qu'il faut la
poser moi je suis de ceux qui
effectivement s'interroge sur la
procédure mise en oeuvre pour procéder à
cette réforme des retraites à au
commissaire aux retraites qui a
travaillé semble-t-il dans la
concertation c'est du moins ce que j'ai
entendu lire plusieurs mois voire plus
d'une année et la concertation se
poursuit et puis et puis voilà on
annonce des choses et puis
la concertation se poursuit moi je suis
très étonné quand même un de cette façon
de procéder parce que là on agite un
chiffon rouge mais on dit c'est pas sûr
qu'on va véritablement le faire comme ça
et puis la retraite par points oui oui
c'était mais on est quand même pas sûr
que généralement on n'est pas pressé
faut pas s'étonner si derrière ça les
gens s'interrogent quoi et et on
pourrait peut-être s'économiser tous ces
mouvements si on avait un discours je
pense claire construit sur lequel on
discute on négocie enfin voila moi je
suis très étonné sur la procédure bien
ceci dit sur le fond la question des
retraites est naturellement complexe
vraiment très complexe je souhaite bonne
chance à tout gouvernement qui veut et
qui veut s'y atteler franchement si
c'était facile ce serait déjà réglé
maintenant ah oui d'ailleurs françois
fillon rappelle a fait une petite
plaisanterie en disant que dans la rue
avec sa réforme des retraites que ce que
fait le gouvernement
aujourd'hui c'était je peux me permettre
une juste pour l'anecdote pas le 5
décembre s'il vous plaît parce que c'est
le jour de mon anniversaire
voilà comment on s'est dit que ça c'est
dit bosso alex légèrement vous qu'un
analyse faites-vous eh bien peut-être de
ce décalage entre ces consultations qui
se poursuivent et en même temps on le
voit ces mouvements sociaux qui
s'amplifie dans la rue et dans les
trains alors deux choses d'une part sur
le dialogue social globalement on sait
très bien que depuis le démarrage de ce
quinquennat c'est un sujet dont emmanuel
macron n'était pas friand et la crise
des gilet jaune l'a bien contraint
finalement art tendre la main aux
partenaires sociaux donc également pour
pouvoir avoir un dialogue social de
qualité il faut surtout que des deux
côtés de la table il y ait cette envie
de discuter et on voit bien
qu'aujourd'hui on est dans un pays qui
est dans notre pays qui était assez
fracturée et assez cliver et de ce point
de vue là je pense pas que les deux
premières années
de ce gouvernement de ce quinquennat
soit forcément une réussite du point de
vue du dialogue social bon ça c'est le
premier point
deuxième point du point de vue de
finalement de l'implication de la
société civile aussi partout c'est de ça
dont on parle à l'intérieur des
consultations qui sont effectués par ce
que dans les consultations il a les
partenaires sociaux classiques et puis
il ya au sens large aussi la société
civile
on l'a vu sur la cca ne avec les lois
bioéthiques
on le voit là sur le sujet des retraites
où normalement ça devrait être ouvert à
tous et je là où je vous rejoins
totalement c'est que on avait finalement
une feuille de route qui paraissait
assez clair avec un très gros travail
qui a été fait quand même par le rapport
delvoye oui mais qui n'était qu'une
piste tout le monde va penser que
c'était le projet de loi tel qu'il
serait et on voit très bien que vers
l'avant il va y avoir différents centres
là sur des réglages sur des sujets qui
sont pourtant notre pays mérite
aujourd'hui d'avoir une réforme des
retraites qu'ils soient correctement
fait pour les générations qui vont
suivre donc et on voit que c'est rétro
pédalage finalement sont masqués par une
association soit des partenaires sociaux
soit le besoin de rediscuter je pense
aux avocats par exemple évidemment qui
sont descendus dans la rue et on a assez
peu l'habitude de cela
donc on voit bien qu'il le gouvernement
aujourd'hui est en défense plutôt qu'à
l'offensive sur ce sujet des retraites
un autre sujet sur lequel le
gouvernement est en défense et celui de
l'agriculture en a été largement
question lors de cette séance de
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
les agriculteurs sont dans la rue ils
ont manifesté ils ont fait des blocages
hier d'ailleurs et bien daniel grémillet
à interpeller tout à l'heure où le
gouvernement il est à votre micro
alexandre pissas en direct de la salle
des conférences
et oui daniel mais daniel grémillet
pardon vous avez eu des mots très forts
envers le ministre de la gueule de
l'agriculture concernant cette loi
agriculture et alimentation
vous avez dit que seul le gouvernement
avait menti tromper les français et les
paysans il ya eu tromperie selon vous
effectivement vous avez fait tellement
naître d'espoir d'espoir au niveau des
agriculteurs
serriculteurs quelle que soit l'équipe
de production qui était en souffrance
qui rencontrent des difficultés
financières énormes qui ont des charges
qui ne cesse de croître
et effectivement la conséquence un an
après de l'application qu'est ce qu'on
voit on voit des contraintes
supplémentaires qui ont un qui pèsent
sur les agriculteurs des charges
supplémentaires et donc essais on a
vraiment monteith et de doula je dirais
ce qui est en train de se produire
il ya longtemps qu'on n'a pas vu autant
d'agriculteurs dans dans les rues le
manifester comme hier dans cette
mobilisation est l'autre point aussi
quand je dis on a trompé consommateurs
parce qu'aujourd'hui on veut une
agriculture plus proche qui est tracé
comme on la porte aujourd'hui au niveau
de tous les territoires quels que soient
les productions agricoles
agroalimentaires dans notre pays et en
même temps on dit les éditeurs français
les consommateurs vont retrouver les
produits qui correspondent pas aux
exigences de l'agriculture française qui
corresponde pas l'exemple du c'est à
l'exemple du méco ressources c'est
effectivement une tromperie et demain
nous n'avons aucune certitude que nos
enfants alors vont manger ce qu'ils
viennent de campagne alors il ya un
autre sujet qui a marqué cette séance de
questions d'actualité
c'est la guerre commerciale entre les
états unis et l'union européenne qui
frappe le vin français mais également
les fromages français daniel grenier
vous produisez du fromage dans les
vosges 1 du munster et du mark herr est
ce que vous attendez que le gouvernement
vienne au chevet de ses filières qui
vont être frappés par les américains
alors effectivement la france va être
frappé par les positions des américains
sur des fromages tous les fromages ne
sont pas concernés mais il n'est pas
pensable là encore que ça soit des
agriculteurs des salariés des
entreprises qui payent les pots cassés
de la politique et il est nécessaire que
la l'europe plus joue pleinement son
rôle
aujourd'hui on attend plus d'europe une
europe plus forte qui est capable de
résister et de faire en sorte qu'elle
celles et ceux qui sont exposés par des
telles mesures de rétorsion ne soient
pas victimes
mais effectivement bénéficie la
solidarité européenne bénéficie de cette
identité quelque part européenne les
américains n'ont pas de leçons à nous
donner à une seule condition c'est que
les européens soient au coude à coude
qu'il faut aller au bras de fer avec les
américains je pense qu'on peut pas
laisser faire les américains comme ils
sont en train de
nous traiter c'est pas possible et dans
tous les cas toutes les entreprises qui
seront victimes de ces rétorsion il est
absolument nécessaire que la solidarité
européenne joue complètement son rôle
son jeu c'est essentiel très bien merci
beaucoup daniel grémillet pour votre
réaction
merci beaucoup alexandre pour cette
nouvelle réaction et on va continuer à
parler agriculture sur ce plateau
il ya tromperie sur la marchandise nous
dit daniel gremillet est ce que vous le
pensez aussi henri cabanel
lorsque vous voyez ce premier bilan qui
est fait bien après l'application de
cette loi agriculture et alimentation
cette loi également la méthode je les ai
toujours dit était la bonne méthode de
réunir donc toutes les parties prenantes
dans le cadre des jeux géants dont les
états généraux de l'agriculture pour
amener à une loi sauf que on a oublié de
dire que dans cette économie libérale
c'est le marché qui a raison donc on a
beau mettre des règles
il arrive un moment donné où la volonté
politique n'est pas à la hauteur de la
réalité économique
c'était prévisible pour vous b oui il ya
eu quand même des lanceurs d'alert chez
les jeunes et chez les autres pour
expliquer aux ministres travers à
l'époque que on aurait des difficultés à
appliquer cette loi parce que le prix du
marché il est tel qu'il est tel qu'il
est et d'un aujourd'hui la guerre des
prix que se font les quelques
distributeurs qui restent mais c'est
toujours l'agriculteur qui est un bâti
et aujourd'hui l'agriculture est dans
une situation depuis quelques années
voilà dans quel métier on ne pourrait
accepter que chaque deux jours il ya
trois agriculteurs qui se suicident
parce que c'est les chiffres de 2015 605
agriculteurs se suicider donc ça prouve
bien qu'elle aime que l'agriculture est
dans une situation très inquiétante et
que cette loi est galim même si elle
avait de bonnes intentions et le crt à
la réalité économique du marché et de la
guerre des prix que se font la guerre à
distribuer jean claude tissot
effectivement le compte n'y est pas
c'est ce que disent tous les
agriculteurs dans la rue en au delà de
toutes les questions d'agri bashing etc
dont on entend beaucoup parler le
problème c'est d'abord et bien comment
vivre aujourd'hui de l'agriculture oui
c'est ça mais ça rejoint un petit peu le
sujet de tout à l'heure c'est à dire que
le gouvernement veut consulter mais il
écoute les gens mais il ne les entend
pas donc les objets à la loi et galim on
savait presque dès le début que ça
serait très compliqué avec les arguments
que bien développé henri cabanel
comment peut-on forcer la main en fait
il ya cinq interlocuteurs la grande
distribution
donc à 5 peut s'entendre les millions de
gens en face et c'est compliqué donc
aujourd'hui c'est un chèque d'un
milliard et demi qui a été fait à la
grande distribution avec le le
réhaussement du frp le seuil de revente
à perte
ça n'a bénéficié surtout pas aux paysans
et ça a compté au consommateur parce que
à travers différentes manières de
production etc etc
ce sont les grossistes ce sont les
distributeurs qui ont engrangé le
bénéfice de cette fois galim et on voit
bien le ministre tout à l'heure il a
beau faire des moulinets
je suis désolé il est grand il peut rien
faire il prive il a fait un constat des
civils il l'a dit lui même ce qu'il a
fait en début de semaine il a fait il a
fait un constat d'échec est aujourd'hui
oui on est tous d'accord pour dire que
la guerre ça fait des morts mais quels
sont les éléments qu'on peut reprendre
pour justement essayer de reprendre la
main quoi andré reichardt effectivement
il faut que la grande distribution que
l'industrie agroalimentaire jouent le
jeu
cette loi est galim elle était censée
permettre aux agriculteurs d'être
rémunéré le juste prix le prix que leur
coûte aussi et bien la fabrication de
tous ses produits
nous partageons tous le même constat
daniel gremillet l'a bien dit
manifestement cette loi n'a pas produit
les effets souhaités loin s'en faut et
on va lui dire très clairement et grands
perdants sont à la fois les
consommateurs qui ont pris plus que les
grains de riz
et puis les agriculteurs qui
malheureusement ne voit rien venir et
chars comme dit je sais pas comme dit il
fait les moulinettes le ministre un peu
importe ce qui fait mais il doit
constater la situation et vous avez bien
compris que toutes ces manifestations
d'agriculteurs et sont pas juste là par
hasard donc clairement il y à là à
l'heure actuelle un ras-le-bol qui est
d'autant plus ressentie difficilement
par les agriculteurs qu'on leur a fait
miroiter
des lendemains qui chantent et ses
lendemains qui chantent ne sont pas là
ça c'est clair dès lors que vous dites à
la population que ça va aller mieux et
que ça va moins bien il faut pas
s'étonner si effectivement elle est
d'autant plus déçu voilà et ça ça me
paraît ça ça me paraîtrait garde on a
fait trop espérer aux agriculteurs on
était quelques uns jugeant les t bonds à
dire que on allait on peut faire un acte
de foi nous aussi mais on voit pas bien
comment on va s'en sortir le seuil de
revente à perte
par définition n'était pas la solution
unique bien même si elle pouvait un
moment laissé pensé que ça irait et bien
voilà ça s'est passé il faut que le
gouvernement se disent que la situation
actuelle ne convient pas et qu'on en
tire les conclusions et qu'on se dise
pas oui mais on va essayer de mettre
quelques rustines etc
ça marche pas alex a germé par rapport
au désespoir des agriculteurs moi je
crois qu'il faut souligner aussi que
healy a très peu de professions en fait
qu'ils doivent gérer un tel
chamboulement de leur écosystème
parce qu'on voit bien qu'avec la
transition écologique aujourd'hui aussi
on demande à nos adversaires de
s'adapter en changeant quand même leur
pratique qui est aussi demandée par le
consommateur qui devient selon le terme
consacré un consom acteur donc ça déjà
en dehors de toutes les préoccupations
et elles sont très présentes bien
évidemment mais de revenus déjà quand
vous avez dans une province en mutation
une intro une transformation à assumer
c'est déjà très déstabilisant et ça ne
peut pas se faire non plus sur une
période courte donc ça c'est le premier
point avec on voit bien des agriculteurs
qui avaient l'habitude de 2,2 de
travailler leurs terres différemment
aujourd'hui on leur dit faut faire des
techniques culturales simplifiées très
bien donc on change tous les points de
repère premier point deuxième point je
crois aussi que quand on voit la grille
bashing aujourd'hui qu'avait été
orchestrée quand même hier par la fnsea
on voit bien que c'était une journée
d'action poussé par la fnsea
je suis pas certaine que l'ensemble des
agriculteurs se retrouvent derrière cela
parce que leur principale préoccupation
déjà
c'est le charge la simplification
administrative quand quand vous discutez
avec des agriculteurs c'est quand même
ça le point aussi très très pivot de
leur quotidien pour en douze courses
avoir des revenus qu'ils soient des 100
jours que tissot vous êtes d'accord il
ya un décalage entre les attentes de la
majorité des agriculteurs qui portent
plutôt sur les revenus et le mouvement
auquel on a assisté hier et déjà
auparavant pour protester contre le
dénigrement dont fait partie l
agriculture et qui est plutôt orchestré
par des syndicats agricoles
vous dites qui a les deux voilà la
grille bashing on le met à toutes les
sauces mais je sais même pas ce que ça
veut dire
aujourd'hui c'est pas c'est plus
conjoncturelle la crise à l'école c'est
une crise structurelle
aujourd'hui on essaye de résoudre un
problème avec des règles du jeu d'il ya
50 ans il ya tout de suite après guerre
on a mis aux agriculteurs produisent et
il faut nourrir la population
on va vous aider chimiquement et que
techniquement etc aujourd'hui on est
plus dans cette dynamique là aujourd'hui
la population et vous l'avez dit les
gens sont des consom'acteurs donc il
faut accompagner la mutation agricole
pour arriver au résultat que la
population souhaite et c'est pas avec
des vieilles règles qu'on va trouver des
solutions je suis désolé il faut
vraiment changer de modèle agricole
il faut changer on pourrait parler du
glyphosate on en a parlé longuement le
glyphosate il suffit pas de supprimer de
l'ifo that parce que si demain on
supprime le before that bayer et
monsanto ils n'ont pas attendu qu'on le
supprime
ils ont une molécule qui est prête sur
les rayons elle sera en vente pour les
agriculteurs nous avons plus cher ça
s'impose à rentrer j'apprends beaucoup
de choses
ce qu'il faut faire c'est accompagner
les agriculteurs pour ne plus avoir
besoin du glyphosate et des autres
matières il faut accompagner des
agriculteurs pour ne plus avoir besoin
des firmes en amont et en aval de leur
production quelle que soit la production
alors sabeton une mutation vous l'avez
dit ça va pas se faire en un an ou deux
mais je suis désolé
aujourd'hui le syndicat majoritaire qui
a mis les paysans dans la rue enfin
d'ailleurs assez calmement parce que
jouer q de classe particulière je pense
que cette question là qu'il faut qu'ils
se posent
parce que il faut accompagner un nouveau
modèle agricole
vous êtes d'accord avec ça avec chabanel
plutôt que de protester contre le
dénigrement dont ils font l'objet et
cette agréable matinée il faut chercher
à évoluer pour les agriculteurs pour
réellement pouvoir améliorer leur image
auprès des français d'abord je voudrais
revenir ce qu'a dit madame est allé dans
son sens il n'y aura pas de transition
écologique que ça les agriculteurs il
faut que les insectes et ils le savent
très bien et pour une grande majorité
d'entre eux ils ont un cliché donc une
volonté de faire une agriculture durable
malgré effectivement les critiques que
l'on peut avoir ici ou là mais la grille
machine existe quand même et on peut pas
reprocher aujourd'hui au ministre de
l'agriculture de ne pas se battre sur la
vie la chine parce que il a toujours été
en avance
sauf que bon derrière il ya tout un tas
d'associations minoritaires qui nous
font un mal fou et qui se disent donc
animalistes qui sont en fait souvent des
associations vegan etc et qui travaille
enfin qui communiquent dans l'illégalité
et met à mal donc les agriculteurs et
dette et les agriculteurs aujourd'hui
entre la ghriba chine entre la
complexité administrative entre les
aléas climatiques entre les aléas
sanitaires entre donc les aléas
politiques ou par une simple décision
d'un président des états unis eau ils se
voient donc leurs produits sur taxi de
26 1% va en parler mais voilà donc la
fraîche main
ils sont dans une situation un petit peu
délicate mais je tiens quand même à
souligner qu' une bonne partie d'entre
eux ont compris l'intérêt qu'il y avait
à changer de pratique pour aller vers
une agriculture durable
le petit se voulait réagir oui juste la
grée bashing sais c'est pas il ya des
époques des exploitations agricoles qui
sont pas du tout montré du doigt qui
sont visités tous les week-ends il les
marchés sont à la ferme est au contraire
la population soutient à travers leurs
achats et même les visites auprès de ses
exploitations là en disant voilà c'est
ce système là qu'on veut donc la grille
machine
je suis désolé il n'est pas pour toutes
les exploitations mais on les montre pas
on montre toujours les plus mauvaises
oui c'est vrai c'est dommage surtout
organiser certaines associations
notamment sur l'élevage où là il ya un
but politique qui est qui et dé renom à
vous et à vous aimer qui leur est
présent un fort doute mais de toute
façon la transition agricole se fera au
rythme du sol au rythme du vivant c'est
bien ça la difficulté c'est que l'on
peut l'accompagner mais bien sûr qu'on
peut l'accompagner à 56 milliards de la
pac
oui 9 milliards pour la france mais cela
dit en effet que si on a quelques sols
manette quoi nos sols reviennent à comme
terreau finalement d'une nouvelle
pratique culturale un mot juste sur la
cerise sur le gâteau c'est aussi et bien
actuellement à la guerre commerciale que
se livrent les états unis et l'union
européenne on a eu la question du vin
aujourd'hui andré reichardt
j'enlève pour venir - dans cet
accompagnement nécessaire de nouvelles
entre guillemets pratiques culturales
les les compagnies consulaires les
chambres d'agriculture notamment aussi
les organisations syndicales peuvent
jouer un rôle très important sur essayé
je voudrais à cet égard j'en parle pas
comme ça
je voudrais à cet égard qu on se
félicite tous ensemble de ce que le
gouvernement hier soir a changé de
position en ce qui concerne notamment le
prélèvement qu'il voulait faire sur les
recettes des chambres d'agriculture et
de ses membres et notamment sur cette
régionalisation au niveau de la grande
région vous avez vu ce qu'il voulait
faire prélever
au niveau de prélever dans les
départements où donner une grande région
et ensuite n'ont versé que 70%
ça c'était un vrai scandale comment
voulez vous que les chambres
d'agriculture puisse faire un boulot
efficace lorsqu'on les lorsqu'on les
bayonne moi je t'aime félicité de cela
encore une fois ces agriculteurs doivent
être accompagnés pas seulement
financièrement doivent aussi être
accompagné précisément pour mettre en
oeuvre ces nouvelles façons culturales
dont vous venez de parler et qui sont
essentiels pour l'agriculture française
alexa j'ai rarement un mot sur la cerise
sur le gâteau je le disais tout de même
cette guerre commerciale que se livrent
en plus les états unis et l'union
européenne et ça met en difficulté
d'agriculteurs oui les agriculteurs se
retrouvent là finalement au milieu d'un
bras de fer encore entre deux
européennes pris en otage tout à fait
puisque d'un côté on a cette surtaxe de
25% on va vraiment à la course à
l'échalote est maintenant sur la façon
dont les barrières tarifaires sont sont
précisés donc on a cette surtaxe qui
provient finalement des aides qui avait
été donné à airbus
et puis de l'autre côté dans quelques
temps avec omc oui c'est sans rapport
mais pourtant on arrive là aujourd'hui
on va voir la version inverse
parce que fait le fond du problème c'est
quoi ces des représailles de monsieur
trump pour avoir mis une taxe sur les
gars femmes au niveau français c'est ça
la vraie réalité est là où je rejoins
daniel grémillet c'est qu'on n'est pas
suffisamment solidaires au niveau
européen et que la taxe sur les gars fin
on aurait dû comme le souhaitait bruno
le maire un moment donné la voir au
niveau européen je ne passe pas comme
monsieur tron aurait réagi de la même
façon insu merci beaucoup et saint
germain merci à vous y allez on va
passer au troisième thème de cette
émission
le troisième thème et bien c'est la
question des départements jacqueline
gourault qui tout à l'heure a eu une
nouvelle fois à justifier bien les
réformes fiscales locales du
gouvernement ont les coûteuses il a été
effectivement décidé de compenser la
perte du foncier bâti par une fraction
de tva qui s'élève à 15 milliards
d'euros + 250 millions de bonus je
voudrais préciser
ce que je n'ai pas eu le temps de faire
tout à l'heure que la dynamique des 250
millions puisque les 250 millions sont
dynamiques comme le reste et bien
donneront lieu à une clause de
sauvegarde pour prévenir tout accident
qui pourrait arriver dans un département
c'est une solidarité supplémentaire
andré reichardt à ce que vous avez été
convaincu par les mots de la ministre
cela fait déjà quelques jours quelques
semaines quelques mois qu'elle doit et
bien se justifier sur sept ce grand big
bang fiscal local prévues par le
gouvernement belge avait déjà tenu ce
discours au congrès de l'adf
effectivement l'assemblée des
départements de france on est des
départements de france sans spécialement
convaincre bon y compris quel magasin
qu'ils ont plus un c'est clair alors
soudain on voir en vo on voit apparaître
une clause de sauvegarde le vient de
tomber
bon je sais pas si pour autant ils
seront plus satisfait que ça moi je
voudrais juste dire que les départements
sont en train de vivre une situation
particulièrement difficile avec des
recettes qui étaient contraintes et des
obligations qui elle leur échappe
voilà avec notamment le social qui plus
est on a voté mais chers collègues aussi
là dans le projet de loi sur
l'engagement et la proximité cette
semaine enfin ouais ça a été voté hier
et on a travaillé pendant 15 jours les
deux semaines passées on a voté la
possibilité pour les départements de se
voir confier de nouveau un certain
nombre de deux compétences notamment sur
ce qu'il est mais je vais aller
directement l'aide à la solidarité
emploi alors ça va exiger des moyens et
ils moi je voudrais redire ici que je
suis et moi je sais que c'est pas bien
vu mais que beaucoup plus que les
grandes régions c'est c'est ce sont les
départements les communes qui peut
véritablement chacun de chacune
naturellement dont on fait chacun dans
son domaine de compétences peuvent être
au plus proche du terrain savent ce
qu'il faut faire
la solidarité dodo a joué dans la
proximité
moi je dis qu'il faut aider les
départements c'est tout à fait clair et
s'ils se plaignent à mon sens c'est à
juste titre on est en train de faire
avec ces grandes régions je vous parle
la mienne grand thèse des monstres avec
avec une gabegie j'ose le dire une
gabegie financière qui n'a plus lieu
d'être on n'a plus les moyens de se
payer ça alors que ceux celles et ceux
qui peuvent être efficaces se situe dans
la proximité les départements sont c'est
un sujet sur laquelle vous avez d'accord
avec vos collègues de gauche j'ai
l'impression un jean claude tissot moi
quand j'entends la ministre dans le
groupe je pense que quand même permis le
mot va être fort mais je pense que c'est
la malhonnêteté intellectuelle je vais
vous dire pourquoi la taxe d'habitation
les gens modestes ne paient pas oui
aujourd'hui la taxe d'habitation pour
les communes la compensation va être
prise sur la tva mais comment va la
payer et tout le monde va la payer et on
arrive à un paradoxe c'est à dire que
quelqu'un qui touchent le rsa
la paix c'est avec tout les des
allocations de solidarité et ben en fait
c'est lui qui va se payer sa propre
indemnité de solidarité même vous rendez
compte
et ça on le dit pas et je trouve c'est
scandaleux c'est malhonnête oui elle a
fait valoir les 18 milliards qu'elle
rendait aux français avec la taxe
d'habitation jacqueline gourault mais
vous dites c'est un leurre mais mais oui
parce que les gens me la payer à fin
août et j'étais maire d'une commune je
sais très bien là pourcentage de gens
m'ont pas dit qu'ils ne paient pas la
taxe d'habitation
donc aujourd'hui c'est un faux cadeaux
on leur dit vous allez passer la taxe
d'habitation
ils la paient déjà pas c'est un cadeau
empoisonné alors henri cabanel c'est un
faux cadeaux dijon claude tissot oui je
suis assez d'accord avec ce qu'il dit
mais je voudrais revenir sur la
nécessité de garder nos départements
telle qu'elle est aujourd'hui dans la
difficulté où il se trouve il y a donc
le pacte de cahors qui limite les
dépenses à 1,2 pour cent est
automatiquement par rapport à la masse
salariale dans mon département
ce chiffre est il dépassé dépasser sans
rien faire ça n'a absolument sur les
indices
donc il est évident que ce département
notamment solide celui de l'hérault va
payer une amende parce qu'il dépasse on
continue à lui donnait donc des
compétences sur le social
qui effectivement est lié directement à
notre économie c'est d'économies va
m'enlever le social forcément augmenter
alors que la compagnie sensation de la
tva c'est pareil si l'économie va mal
mais il ramène étudiants et pour ça et
pourtant la ministre dit que c'est par
la tva combat compenser dos je sais pas
quel calcul et le fais mais je voudrais
insister sur le fait de département les
départements sont vraiment la
collectivité au plus proche donc effet
des citoyens et surtout avec une volonté
de solidarité dans les territoires
l'aménagement des territoires et la
solidarité des territoires
c'est le département qui la porte et
aujourd'hui si on y enlève cette
capacité là et qu'on lui met juste avant
que ses compétences sociales
ben il servira plus à rien et qu'ils en
paieront les conséquences sont nos
communes rurales qui perd sommes
directement la nôtre donc effectivement
c'est un vrai souci que les départements
ont mis à davanne sur leur autonomie
financière entre la charte alors que
fallait il faire
la taxe d'habitation quand même beaucoup
disaient que c'était un mauvais impôt
comment est-ce qu'on pouvait bien
réformer et comment est-ce qu'on pouvait
comme moi ce qu'on pouvait faire
écoutez moi je fait assez mal placé de
dire ça dans la mesure où le président
qui était de mon bord a fait quasiment
la même chose avec une autre taxe voilà
mais on dont on a dit fil des
difficultés mais on n'annonce pas comme
ça du jour au lendemain je sais pas la
suppression d'une taxe on réfléchira à
la totalité du voisin préparation du
gouvernement tout le moins l'absence de
réflexion aller comment je veux dire ça
cohérente au même moment avec une étude
d'impact véritable avec je pense une
concertation je crois avec les
différentes parties concernées
ce premier plan naturellement celles et
ceux qui bénéficiaient de la taxe
d'habitation
tout ça ne s'est pas fait et pour faire
leur leur budget à l'heure actuelle vous
rendez compte à l'époque on est quoi à
l'époque on est là la de l'année
les gens qui travaillent à élaborer des
budgets pour l'année prochaine sont en
train de se demander comment ils vont
faire avec des annonces qui viennent
progressivement comme ça à 11h55
c'est ça qui m'étonne enfin quand même
je sais pas moi j'étais maire mais aussi
pendant 17 ans j'ai même été président
de région un moment jamais je ne sais
pas je comprends pas je comprends pas
comprenez le procédé aux 15 50 40 ans
terminera jan on est dans une année
électorale donc
#cannes jalton maire c'est à dire que
bombe à écouter tout ce qui pourra faire
plaisir au maire ils seront cette
réforme ça fait pas plaisir pour
l'instant non mais le la manière dont
dans le gouvernement
ces mois ci que se discute avec chacun
les évident qu'on l'a donc c'est plutôt
qu'à je crois plutôt aisée du coin bon
moi je pense que voilà je pense que la
méthode aujourd'hui employé par ce
gouvernement mais par les gouvernements
successifs 1 c'est que on ne travaille
pas à suffisamment de nabua maman on ne
définit pas suffisamment les un jeu on
n'étudie pas suffisamment les impacts
donc on est pressé dans la mesure et moi
je suis moi ma bi homo ma toujours
expliqué que qui va vite va mal donc je
pense qu'il faut justement bien étudié
tous les impacts de toutes les décisions
qui vont être prises
parce que sinon on reviendra là rien qui
va vite va mal ça sera le mot de la fin
merci beaucoup à tous les trois d'avoir
débriefer cette séance de questions
d'actualité du mercredi au sénat
l'actualité parlementaire elle continue
sur public sénat tout de suite on vous a
sélectionné les temps forts de
l'audition du pdg de lubrizol trois
semaines après l'incendié de rouen il
était auditionné hier par les sénateurs
qui débute une commission d' enquête
pour comprendre ce qui s'est passé et
comment ne plus jamais reproduire ces
erreurs
les temps forts ont été sélectionnés par
louis mourier nous procédons aujourd'hui
à la première audition de notre
commission d' enquête sur la gestion des
conséquences de l'incendié de lusine
lubrizol à rouen c'est une réunion qui
est vous l'avez vu
ouverte à la presse un compte-rendu sera
d'ailleurs publiée et nous accueillons
pour cette première audition
monsieur chenu requis et le président
directeur général du groupe
lubrizol je rappelle que nous avons créé
cette commission d' enquête à la demande
de l'ensemble des présidents de groupes
politiques du sénat et de l'ensemble des
présidents de commission du sénat c'est
donc une procédure assez solennel qui
nous conduit à être aujourd'hui réunis
en commission denquête avons installé
notre commission le 17 octobre
nous avons désigné deux rapporteurs
issue et c'est important de groupes
politiques différents
madame bonfanti dossat et madame nicole
bonnefoy
l'objectif de cette commission denquête
et d'examiner l'intervention des
services de l'état dans la gestion des
conséquences environnementales
sanitaires et économiques de l'incendié
de lusine du briol d'évaluer la
politique de prévention et de gestion
des accidents liés aux installations
classées et d'en tirer les enseignements
pour améliorer la maîtrise des risques
technologiques
nous recevons donc cet après midi comme
je vous l'indiquais monsieur senneurs
qui est actuellement à paris donc nous
avons profité de son passage à paris
pour commencer nos auditions par par lui
et nous souhaitons au cours de cette
audition avoir un certain nombre de
réponse de sa part sur les conditions
dans lesquelles s'est produit l'incendié
du 26 septembre qui est à l'origine
d'une crise qui perdure aujourd'hui sur
le territoire de rouen et du département
de seine maritime
je rappelle que parmi les principes
structurants de la prévention des
risques que technologiques figurent
celui selon lequel c'est l'exploitant
qui est le premier responsable de la
sécurité des installations et qu'il
incombe donc à l'exploitant de réduire à
la source les risques liés à ces
activités industrielles est donc
essentiel que nous puissions sur le
président vous vous interrogez étant
entendu que nous aurons d'ailleurs
peut-être à leur faire ultérieurement
alors dans le principe de la séparation
des pouvoirs il ne nous appartient
évidemment pas de rechercher ou
d'établir des responsabilités
judiciaires par rapport à la
responsabilité éventuelle de votre
entreprise nous appartient pas de savoir
s'il l'incendié accidentel ou criminel
mais nous appartient de comprendre les
faits ainsi que leur contexte et d'en
tirer des enseignements pour la
politique de prévention et de gestion
des accidents industriels
nous souhaitons bien sûr disposer de
réponses claires et précises de votre
part pour que nous puissions disposer
des éléments dont nous avons besoin pour
nos travaux et à ce titre nous aimerions
que vous puissiez nous rappeler les
principales caractéristiques de lusine
du grisolles ainsi que les mesures de
prévention et de gestion de crise qui
ont été mises en place sur ce site que
vous nous rappeler lier la chronologie
des événements les principales actions
et décisions qui ont été prises par
votre entreprise
depuis le début de l'accident votre
appréciation également des dommages
causés par l'accident et l'étendue de
votre responsabilité en termes
d'indemnisation étant entendu que vous
avez envisagé la semaine dernière une
indemnisation à l'amiable et que nous
aimerions bien sûr savoir ce que vous
envisagez en la matière et puis nous
aimerions également vous entendre sur la
manière dont vous avez coopérer avec les
différents services publics depuis cet
événement et vos choix en matière de
communication puisque dans cette maison
même la semaine dernière la ministre de
la transition écologique a émis quelques
réserves pour ne pas dire quelques
critiques sur la communication de votre
entreprise
je vais à présent vous demander
conformément à la procédure qui est
applicable aux commission denquête de
prêter serment
je vous rappelle que tout témoignage
mensonger devant une commission denquête
parlement
terre est puni de cinq ans
d'emprisonnement et de 75000 euros
d'amendé
monsieur futur je vous demande donc de
prêter serment de dire toute la vérité
rien que la vérité de lever la main
droite et de l'audi et de dire je le
jure ailleurs son toute attente je vous
laisse la parole pour une présentation
liminaire d'une dizaine de minutes
ensuite les rapporteurs et l'ensemble
des membres de la commission pourront
naturellement vous interrogez je signale
à mes collègues qu'il n'aurait pas
remarqué qu'ils ont à leur disposition
des petits appareils pour pouvoir
entendre la traduction de l'intervention
de monsieur chenu le canal numéro un qui
doit être branché pour que vous puissiez
avoir la traduction en français des
propos de monsieur chenu raki je laisse
tout de suite la parole
monsieur le président mesdames les
rapporteurs je suis fière exner
président et directeur général de
lubrizol merci beaucoup de me donner
cette occasion de parler avec vous
aujourd'hui au nom de nos 8700 employés
dans le monde
je voudrais tout d'abord et bien
présenté nos excuses les plus sincères à
tous ceux qui ont été affectés par
lincendie du 26 septembre qui a donc
détruit ce site de stockage à rouen je
suis conscient et désolé de tous les
dommages que cela a entraîné dans les
jours qui ont suivi cela fait 60 ans que
nous faisons partie de cette communauté
locale et des centaines d'employés et
leurs familles et bien font partie de la
vie de notre entreprise et nous notre
désir est de les aider ainsi que leurs
amis
nous avons 60 sites dans le monde et
notre but est toujours de le faire en
toute sécurité et d'éviter tout accident
ma plus grande responsabilité c'est la
sécurité des gens qui travaillent pour
nous d'après nos informations l'incendié
aurait débuté hors de notre site mais
nous devons encore en déterminer les
causes ni nous soutenons totalement les
enquêtes en cours nous avons eu beaucoup
de chance et nous sommes très conscients
de cette chance qu'il n'y ait eu aucune
victime
car rien n'aurait été plus importants et
pour moi il ne s'agit pas d'un enjeu
juridique il s'agit de la sécurité de la
famille la famille lubrizol donc je suis
responsable à rouen et dans les 66 pts
de lubrizol dans le monde
beaucoup de ces sites ont des entrepôts
de stockage
j'ai passé beaucoup de temps avec des
gens en france à la fois en personne et
à travers tout le travail que nous
faisons quotidiennement pour essayer de
répondre à leurs besoins
cela inclut tous les employés leur
entourage leur voisin nous connaissons
les gens qui travaillent à rouen depuis
très longtemps et l'entreprise pour eux
est comme une seconde maison et pour eux
donc c'est comme s'ils avaient perdu
leur logement et bien sûr notre volonté
notre résolution de les aider d'aider
leur famille et leur entourage
et bien ne fléchira depuis plus de 90
ans est bien notre objectif est de
faciliter donc l'opération de véhicules
de transport et ce en limitant les
émissions donc ce par le biais de
matériaux de substances chimiques mais
également de d'équipements de sécurité
et donc nous prenons cette
responsabilité donc responsabilité qui
concerne des 1 millions et des millions
de consommateurs qui sont au bout de la
chaîne nous prenons cette responsabilité
très au sérieux et nous voulons
travailler ensemble pour relever ce défi
et continuer à générer de la valeur pour
nos employés et tous ceux qui dépendent
d'eux et dès les premières heures de
l'incendié les jours et les semaines qui
ont suivi nous avons voulu avoir une
communication ouverte
nous avons essayé du mieux que nous
pouvions de répondre à toutes les
questions et ce le plus rapidement
possible ainsi qu'à toutes les requêtes
qui nous ont été faites par des
officiels le 26 septembre à 2h39 du
matin il ya les premières réponses sur
place l'incendié qui s'était déclaré
nous voulons remercier ici les pompiers
la brigade des pompiers pour leur
intervention leur réponse rapide
réaction rapide a permis et bien
d'éteindre cet incendie le brasier le
même jour
nous avons en commun en coopération avec
les autorités locales établi un centre
de contrôle et de gestion afin d'assurer
la sécurité sur le site
et pour les communautés et les quartiers
environnants nous avons mis sur place
une équipe de gestion de crise et avec
une équipe mondiale pour pouvoir mettre
à disposition du site toutes les
expertises nécessaires à 5h30 nounou sa
mise en relation avec le préfet de
manière à pouvoir et bien gérer le plus
efficacement possible et elle a passé
toute la journée
et la dréal également à était présente
et notre équipe leur idole assisté non
seulement l'équipe de la préfecture mais
aussi l'équipe de la dréal nous avons
des huiles pour moteurs et des fluides
hydrauliques entre autres dans les
heures qui ont suivi l'incendié
nous avons répondu à toutes les requêtes
concernant les substances et des
produits le brise hall sur site
nous avons fourni une liste 380 produits
lubrizol stocker a donc sur le site
livre isole et également des fiches
produits détaillées pour les dix
substances lesdits produits qui étaient
en plus grande quantité est également un
grand nombre d'informations de contexte
concernant ces 3 380 produit est
également tout ce qui pouvait aider à
des tests environnementaux
pour ce qui concerne les matériaux
lubrizol qui était celle où normandie
logistique lubrizol travail avec
l'amendé logistique depuis des années et
le fait que soient stockés à proximité
donc chez un chai hin stockistes des
produits lubrizol est une pratique qui
est commune
dans notre secteur nous avons fourni
toutes les informations nécessaires aux
officiels et aux représentants des
autorités publiques nous avons donc très
rapidement fourni une liste détaillée
des produits lubrizol
qui nous a été demandé le 4 octobre donc
nous l'avons fourni pour le 4 octobre
là notre engagement reste très fort afin
de remplir toutes nos obligations
notamment en termes d'information
c'était très important pour est bien
géré la crise mais également pour aider
à tout ce qui pouvait dissiper les
inquiétudes quant aux conséquences
environnementales sanitaires et autres
d'après nos informations les produits
sur site qui ont brûlé ne présentent pas
de danger à la santé outre les
irritations dues aux dégagements de
fumée c'est nos produits concernent
essentiellement des composés organiques
notamment des produits de type cargo
nous approuvons et sommes reconnaissants
à la préfecture d'avoir donné des
consignes aux riverains pour rester chez
eux
considérant les effets donc postérieure
au dégagement des fumées
nous avons mené une évaluation très
détaillée de nos centres peau de manière
à déterminer quels étaient toutes les
substances présentent même à l'état de
traces nous pouvons
nous pensons pouvoir affirmer que et
bien tous les produits qui étaient
présents sur le cycle grisolles ainsi
que sur le site normandie logistique ne
présentent pas de danger à la santé cela
a été validé par des tests
environnementaux
mais nous comprenons qu'il y ait encore
des inquiétudes à dissiper nous sommes
en faveur pleinement faveur de tests
supplémentaires afin de soulager ses
inquiétudes et nous nous sommes mis en
relation et nous travaillons avec des
organisations locales à rouen de manière
à mener ces tests environnementales tout
cela a été rendu public sur des sites
internet j'aimerais maintenant passer à
la question des réglementations de
sécurité rien n'est plus important pour
lubrizol que de promouvoir et de
défendre la sécurité d'assurer la
sécurité de nos employés et des
riverains nous nous sommes engagés à une
amélioration continue de cette sécurité
notre site est pleinement en respect des
réglementations de sécurité
nous avons une culture de sécurité qui
est très ancrée et nous nous travaillons
avec les autorités afin de mener tous
les contrôles et toutes les
améliorations qui permettent de garantir
la sécurité de nos employés mais
également de nos voisins sur les sites
industriels et des communautés locales
nous mesurons l'impact environnemental
et ces tests ont pu mettre en évidence
qu'il n'y avait pas eu d'environnement
de d'impact environnemental immédiat et
il ya eu une mise à jour en fait
avec un contrôle le 18 septembre dernier
bien sûr au nous nous sommes aussi
également la question des impacts
sanitaires a plus moyen terme et alors
qu'elle nos informations nous permettent
de dire qu'au-delà des irritations
immédiat dus à la fumée il n'y a pas de
d'inquiétude à avoir sur les impacts
sanitaires à un moyen terme il nous à nu
après année nous avons toujours défendu
les causes qui nous semblait juste et
nous avons toujours voulu être de bons
voisins et ainsi agir pour assurer la
sécurité des deux de nos voisins sur les
sites industriels et des riverains
nous nous engageons à continuer à
fournir cette assistance à long terme
nous sommes aussi engagés à soutenir les
agriculteurs qui dont le travail a été
impactée également les entreprises dans
les livres dans les secteurs qui ont été
également affectées je pense à
l'hôtellerie et à la restauration et
nous allons financer également la
promotion de cette belle ville de rouen
et comme je les dis il y a encore des
tests environnementaux en jour et qui
continueront de manière à et bien
dissiper les inquiétudes qui demeurent
nous avons également assuré je le
réaffirme ici que tous les employés leur
idole continueront à être rémunéré leur
famille continueront à devoir compter
sur notre sur notre soutien
leur salaire et
là le cycle boys elle représente plus de
200 millions d'euros pour la le pays
nous en sommes conscients
nous voulons continuer à faire partie de
cette communauté locale à 1 rouen et
nous voulons continuer à travailler en
bonne intelligence avec les collègues
la collectivité territoriale et toutes
les autorités publiques à la partie
production du site n'ayant pas été
affecté par le lincendie nous allons
étudier la possibilité de remettre ce
site en activité
le 26 septembre restera dans notre dans
nos mémoires j'aurais aimé que bien sûr
cela ne se produise pas et nous voulons
continuer à agir pour la sécurité et le
bien-être de toutes les communautés de
autour de rouen et du cycle grisolles
merci beaucoup de votre attention
messieurs président doit répondre à
votre question vos questions d'abord où
attendent ou non d'autres questions
écoutez je pense que ce serait bien que
vous répondu aux questions que j'ai
posées et ensuite que l'on puisse donner
la parole aux rapporteurs
merci
alors la première question concernant
les événements et le calendrier des
événements je pense que j'ai répondu ces
questions nord la chronologie des
événements je pense qu'à ce jour nous
connaissons pas l'évaluation des dégâts
à la communauté mais ce que nous avons
dit ce que nous voulons aider la
communauté
nous avons travaillé avec ses pour
identifier les fermiers les agriculteurs
qui ont besoin de plus d'un soutien nous
avons la volonté de soutenir les
personnes qui ont besoin
nous avons une grande responsabilité
la question juridique n'est pas un
problème en ce qui me concerne nous
avons une responsabilité en tant que
voisin à tous nos amis et voisins avant
et nous allons donc répondre cela et
nous voulons bien entendu à prendre si
vous avez des renseignements nous
fournir dès le départ dans mes
commentaires
notre directeur général travailler avec
le préfet et communiqué fait que les
autorités et nous avons travaillé jour
après jour pour fournir autant
d'informations possibles afin de d'aider
les autorités nous avons communiqué avec
la presse locale et je suis venu à
passer une semaine après l'incendié au
travail avec la presse nationale et j'ai
eu une réunion très utile ministre
amadou gon amon second tour
et également au point comment nous
pourrions aider les agriculteurs
nous allons continuer discussions ce
sujet je suis à paris afin de s'assurer
que l'on puisse commencer à un dock à
modéliser les personnes qui ont besoin
d'être indemnisé je suis prêt répond
toute autre question que vous auriez
monsieur le président concrètement sur
la question d'indemnisation où en êtes
vous est-ce qu'il ya déjà une approche
qui a été qui a été fait
quand vous parliez éventuellement
d'indemnisation forfaitaire à quoi à
quoi pensiez-vous où on en est
aujourd'hui issus de votre point de vue
sur l'évaluation et les modalités de
cette indemnisation
sachant qu' une indemnisation par
rapport à des dommages qui sont déjà
évalué qu'il y a aussi des dommages qui
au jour d'aujourd'hui ne peuvent pas
encore être évalué
alors y'a certainement donné nous avons
travaillé avec eux pour savoir quelle
source
les agriculteurs impacté et de répondre
aux priorités nous allons gérer les faux
avec les messieurs vous identifier les
agriculteurs qui doivent recevoir le
soutien reçus rapidement possible nous
allons travailler avec la préfecture
pour gérer info afin de répondre aux
besoins des entreprises dans nos
sociétés nous avons et gazons financer
des opérations de nettoyage et nous
sommes en train de payer pour les
évaluations environnementales donc à ce
stade y a pas encore d'évaluation
globale du préjudice de votre part il ya
simplement des dispositifs on va dire de
pour faire face aux besoins les plus les
plus immédiats
c'est tout à fait injuste c'est bien
cela monsieur le président sûrement
amené à revenir sur la question de
l'indemnisation global je veux pas me
focaliser davantage la parole je vais
tout de suite donné la parole à madame
bonfanti dossat à porter pour poser la
première question puis ensuite dans une
fois monsieur je vous remercie d'avoir
profité de votre séjour à paris pour
venir devant cette commission
vous imaginez que des questions sont
nombreuses on a essayé d'être consiste
pour pouvoir permettre à nos collègues
de poser leurs questions
moi ma première question est de savoir
si vous avez répertorier le nombre
d'incidents et d'accidents industriels
du groupe
lubrizol depuis ces dernières années au
niveau français bien sûr mais également
au niveau européen et mondial et à ce
titre je voudrais savoir en quoi le
régime de protection américaine
différente il d'une autre et quelles
sont ses particularités dont nous
pourrions nous inspirer
ensuite j'ai bien écouté votre message
rassurant et vous avez dit vous même que
la quantité de produits chimiques brûlée
par l'incendié est désormais connue on
connaît d'hommes la nature la quantité
toutefois oui puisque la préfecture de
seine maritime a produit la liste
franchement j'avoue que je ne suis pas
diplômé en chimie donc j'ai eu beaucoup
de mal à à à lire tout ça c'est la
raison pour laquelle je me demande si
les produits chimiques qui ont brûlé
ensemble n'ont pas entraîné une
combustion sauvage et dans cette mesure
là est ce qu'on connaît vraiment la
dangerosité du panache de fumée qui est
qui et qui est sorti et qui a flotté sur
la ville de rouen et ses environs merci
mr à porter monsieur je me permettrait
peut-être de compléter le premier point
soulevé par même la rapporteur qui vous
a interrogé sur les accidents qui ont pu
se produire dans votre entreprise en
rappelant quand même je n'ai pas fait
cela pour pas être trop long qu'il ya eu
quand même en 2013 un accident à rouen
dans votre établissement
une fuite de gaz importante
qui a conduit à ce que la justice
condamne en 2014 l'entreprise lubrizol
considérant je cite qu'il y avait une
série d'insuffisances dans la maîtrise
des risques de la part de la société
donc si j'ose dire ce n'est pas une
première quine des problèmes dans votre
entreprise et sur ce site et j'aimerais
en question complémentaire à celle de la
rapporteure que vous puissiez nous dire
quelles conséquences sur ce site vous
avez tirées des événements de 2013 et de
la condamnation 2014
mais c'est certain que je commencerai
avec la question tu vas au sujet des
1,6 en 2013 il y a eu du
mercaptan qui a été lynché qui n'est pas
un produit dangereux mais qui a un autre
des acteurs nous excusons pour cela nous
savons ce qui s'est passé nous avons
investi 20 millions de dollars 2 euros
par don pour améliorer la sécurité et
prévenir une répétition d'un risque
ça n'a aucun lien avec le feu qui a eu
lieu en ce qui concerne le nombre
d'incidents pour d'accident si je suis
la lys nous avons eu quelques blessures
mineures et nous faisons tout ce que
nous pouvons pour éviter toute blessure
les personnels 1 en 2013 nous en avons
parlé avec le maire cadence 2015 nous
avons une seat un buruli eu donc
l'incident qui a été rapidement
régler en 2015 nous avions eu des
problèmes avec des lâchers de l'huile
qui sont allés dans ce système
d'évacuation de zone 2018 en belgique
nous avons eu un tuyau qui a été pensé
et il y a eu des poudres qui ont été
versés sur une route
cela a été nettoyée très rapidement et
mais seul a eu un impact que sur le
voisinage nous avons également eu une
incendie en pennsylvanie sur un site en
2017 et il s'est avéré que les produits
stockés dans cet endroit ont été
identifiés rappeler et nous avons changé
l'approvisionnement les matières éviter
que cet incident se reproduise nous
avons pris les mesures pour s'assurer
que ces incidents ne se reproduisent des
procédures de sécurité comme vous le
savez la procédure française donc
réglementer ce lot ces vaisseaux c'est
une réglementation qui exige que l'on
simule qu'on identifie quand 6000 des
situations potentiellement dangereuses
des scénarios potentiellement dangereuse
qui pourrait advenir dans nos sites et
nous le faisons régulièrement également
dans le site qui a été impacté par
incident temps 26 septembre dans tout le
new sites de production nous cherchons
constamment simuler et anticiper les
risques potentiels que ce soit en
amérique en asie où où que ce soit dans
le monde
les réglementations peuvent varier dans
les différentes parties du monde mais
notre intention est toujours la même
c'est d'éviter les risques d'éviter tout
incident ou blessure
en ce qui concerne la fumée et j'avais
complété la réponse concernant les
impacts sur la santé nous savons nous
avons des détails au niveau moléculaire
nous connaissons très bien toutes les
matières pierrot était dans l' incendie
nous pouvons simuler que 2,7 panache de
fumée nous pouvons stimuler et calculer
l'impact sur la santé de cette fumée
90% des matières sont de carbone
hydrogène qu'il n'y a aucune différence
significative entre ce qui a été brûlé
dans le feu et ce que l'on peut trouver
à brûler dans une incendie
par exemple dans une des zones et même
dans les maisons en des logements les
fumées peuvent être encore plus tôt que
c'est donc nous pouvons anticiper ce
quel serait le contenu de la fumée nous
pouvons déterminer prédire quels sont
les impacts à court terme ou à long
terme sur la santé de toute façon la
fumée irritante et nous sommes vraiment
désolés et en vous excusant l'impact
n'ayant aucune autre impact sur la santé
autre que l'irritation causés par les
fumées
merci bonjour monsieur le président
j'avais moi de questions avant de
laisser la parole à nos collègues
une question qui concerne plus
particulièrement vos liens avec
normandie logistique
vous avez dit tout à l'heure que depuis
des années vous travaillez avec
normandie logistique que c'était des
pratiques communes dans votre secteur et
que vous aviez par ailleurs les noter
fournit la liste détaillée des produits
stockés
quand les autorités voulons demander
après l'incendié moi ma question est est
ce que les substances stockées chez
normandie logistiques étaient les mêmes
que celles stockées chez lubrizol est
est ce que vous avez signalé
régulièrement et pas uniquement après un
incendie mais régulièrement au service
de l'état le déplacement sur le site de
normandie logistique de fûts de
substances dangereuses qui donc se
trouver chez lubrizol et qui chez
lubrizol justifie le classement seveso
seuil haut
alors que vous le savez pour normandie
logistique le l'établissement n'est pas
classée seveso donc ça c'est ma première
question
la deuxième question vous avez là aussi
évoqué en préambule votre souci
important la grande responsabilité qui
était la vôtre en matière de sécurité
et je voudrais là vous questionnez
puisque en 2010 il y avait une étude qui
avait émis en évidence une
méconnaissance importante des enjeux de
sécurité pour les sous traitants des
industries rouennaise et sur la base de
ce constat est ce que vous avez revu vos
exigences notamment en matière de
formation a imposé par donc votre
entreprise lubrizol ses prestataires
donc est-ce que vous avez recours à la
sous traitance pour quel type d'activité
depuis combien de temps et est ce que
dans quelques on dit
ont été formés ses sous traitants pour
répondre en particulier à cette étude de
2010 qui avait mis à d'évidence des
carences importantes en matière de
formation à la sécurité pour les sous
traitants
voilà c'est mes deux premières questions
merci même la rapporteure monsieur futur
merci aux fastes
tout d'abord je répondre à la question
concernant le normandy logistique du
préfet seul stock uniquement des
matières non le toxiques ou dangereuses
notant que les autorités étaient au
courant
de fait que nous stockons et matières
chez nombre des logistics vie n'étaient
pas informés régulièrement de ce que
nous stockons che non même dit juste
parce que nous ne mettions pas des
matières dangereuses qui d'été sous la
réglementation seveso et en ce qui
concerne les sous traitants votre
question concernant sous traitants je ne
connais pas tous les détails concernant
l'étude
mais en ce qui concerne nous prise au
tout sous traitants suis toujours la
même formation en matière de sécurité
que nous employer et doivent avoir la
même formation être à même de
d'être en conformité avec les règles de
sécurité nous avons grands noms de
personnes qui s'occupent de la sécurité
nous avons deux sous traitants qui
travaillent dans nos sites et donc exit
de stockage toute personne qui se trouve
sur ce site reçoit la même formation que
nos employés et nous devons être assurés
qu'ils peuvent donc être en pleine
conformité avec toutes les règles de
sécurité
j'ai écouté avec attention votre propos
introductif et permettez moi juste de
vous dire que je suis quand même un peu
étonné devant votre optimisme presque
on vous entend dire que les fumées ne
sont pas nocives
les retombées ne sont pas nocives
permettez moi juste de vous faire part
de mon étonnement sans faire de
catastrophisme
je pense quand même qu'on est là devant
une catastrophe écologique économique
certes pour pijuan et mais en tout cas
écologique aussi pour notre pays et tous
les sur tous les secteurs attenant à
rouen vous parlez de toxicité aiguë que
vous maîtrisez que vous allez indemniser
tout ce qui a attrait la toxicité aiguë
moi je voudrais que vous prononciez
clairement aussi pour une éventuelle
toxicité chronique
aujourd'hui je pense pas je pense pas
mais moi aussi je ne suis pas féministe
mais j'ai lu pour préparer votre votre
audition tout ce qu'ils avaient pu être
écrit ou presque sur sur cet accident et
aujourd'hui personne n'est capable de
dire si il y aura des retombées graves
sur sur les l'être humain bien sûr mais
aussi
moi je voudrais que vous ne répondiez 6
quels sont les engagements que vous
prenez qu'elles sont peut-être même déjà
des mesures que vous avez déjà envisagé
pour ce qui est des nappes phréatiques
quels sont les études que vous allez
mener sur la faune sauvage sur les
insectes
parce que ce sont des animaux migrateurs
peut-être qu'ils vont se déplacer et
peut-être se déplacer avec des produits
nocifs et qui peuvent aussi contaminer
bien au delà la région de rouen
donc l'eau utilisée par les pompiers
milton je crois que vous avez annoncé
tout à l'heure c'est très bien passé
quelque part est-ce qu'elle était
envisagé d'être traité est ce qu on la
suit est ce que voilà la scène passe pas
loin
voilà donc peut-être qu'on va retrouver
ça un peu plus loin vous démontrez aussi
d'une bonne volonté ce que je ne nie pas
mais je pense que il a fallu du temps
comme l'a dit ma collec tout à l'heure
pour avoir des éléments probants je
pense que si vous aviez voulu démontrer
d'une bonne volonté pour rassurer la
population il y avait des éléments très
facile à mettre en oeuvre par exemple
récupérer les filtres des ventilations
de bâtiments qui sont qui sont fermées
donc des filtres de vmc ventilation
mécanique contrôlée puis tout de suite
voir s'il y avait des différences avec
des les périodes normales donc ça est ce
que est ce que vous avez fait cesser ces
investigations rapide on va dire presque
hors procédure
voilà et puis après j'ai une question un
peu plus précis sur l'agriculture certes
vous à les indemniser
bien sûr les agriculteurs entre autres
qui ont dû jeter le lait pendant
plusieurs traite et là je n'en doute pas
mais aujourd'hui cela il a été jetés
dans des fosses à lisier cvo saint
lizier vont être pleines
mon devoir est répandu donc vont être
répandus sur des terrains imaginons que
les analyses démontrent que le lait est
aussi contaminé
donc voilà c'est une question un peu
vaste certes mais j'aimerais connaître
votre votre avis et comment vous
imaginez alors sans faire de
catastrophisme mais très très lucidement
comment vous imaginez accompagné toute
la problématique futur merci merci
monsieur tissot monsieur chenu
qui ne s'est pas fait d'un création
merci aussi qu'on nous parle d'effets
sanitaires nous parlons est
effectivement des effets de toxicité à
la fois aiguë et chronique je crois
qu'il est important de garder à l'esprit
que jusqu'à présent deux mille
échantillons emile résultats de ces
échantillons ont confirmé qu'il n'y a
pas de d'impact sanitaire nous allons
continuer bien sûr cette surveillance et
nous allons continuer à être pleinement
transparent il y a un plan de
surveillance sanitaire et
environnementale qui est bien c'est
engagé et qui se regarde les effets à
moyen terme et long terme
l'eau et a été confiné et et va être
traitée et cela concerne la scène
je ne sais pas et je m'en excuse ce qui
a été concrètement faire concernant les
films de ventilation mais l'information
dont nous disposons pour ce qui est de
la toxicité de la composition de tous
les produits qui ont été affectés par le
feu
tout cela a été fourni aux autorités
locales et nous sommes disposés à
fournir d'autres informations si on nous
les demandes en terme d' analyse et
d'informations complémentaires tout ce
qui peut être utile pour ceux qui y est
de 2 du soutien long terme pour les
agriculteurs et pour les autres oui nous
nous sommes engagés à un soutien à court
terme et à long terme nous allons
continuer bien sûr à faire partie de la
communauté locale à être des voisins et
donc nous ne savons pas encore quels
seront les besoins à long terme et nous
serons là pour continuer à soutenir
localement
merci monsieur dantec merci monsieur le
président vous avez expliqué donc alors
évidemment l'enquète éclaircir à ce
point que l'incendié peut-être partie de
l'extérieur et que vos dispositifs
anti-incendie
ne prévoyez finalement que de répondre
un incendie intérieur des entrepôts donc
ma question est de savoir quelles études
de risques vous aviez mené sur les
risques extérieurs 1 par rapport à votre
activité industrielle et dans ce cadre
là quels travaux avaient été menées avec
la dréal avec les pompiers et les autres
services de l'état pour mesurer les
risques liés à l'environnement de
l'entreprise n'ont pas les risques
internes à l'entreprise
mais les risques liés à l'environnement
immédiat ou plus lointain de
l'entreprise merci monsieur chenu
remercie et bien cela fait partie de la
réglementation seveso faisons des
analyses de risques très très nombreuses
il nous avons fait une évaluation de
risques pour
hélas pour le site est la partie qui a
brûlé et ce quelques jours seulement
avant l'incident nous ne pouvons faire
une analyse de risque pour un événement
qui se déclarerait en dehors du
périmètre de notre site parce que nous
ne serons pas savoir véritablement dans
tous les détails ce qui se passe en
dehors de notre site et donc ce que nous
savons c'est quels sont les matériaux et
substances qui sont présents sur notre
site ça nous le savons dans les plus
infimes détails
pour ce qui est hors de notre site nous
n'avons pas cette connaissance de tout
ce qui est présent en termes de produits
mais il y à une simulation qui était
mené autour de la zone qui a brûlé et
toutes les questions concernant les
filets la toxicité et bien c'est notre
évaluation c'est se penche là-dessus
et et cette information bien sûr nous la
transmettrons à la dréal et à tous les
services de l'état j'espère que la
réponse à votre question je pense que ça
n'est pas le cas je sais dantec que je
connais bien froncer le sourcil comme
cela c'est laid je peux le comprendre
qu'il n'est pas convaincu par la réponse
je me fous que vous lisez dans mes
pensées monsieur le président ce qui
veut dire que sur ces risques extérieurs
alors que sur beaucoup d'activités à
risque évidemment analyse de différents
risques prenons des risques connus chute
d'un aéroplane intrusion au terrorisme
donc l'analyse du risque extérieur fait
vraiment partie normalement de l'analyse
sur un site seveso donc pour ré
repréciser la question s'il veut dire
vous n'avez jamais eu ce travail sur les
risques extérieurs de l'environnement
immédiat de l'entreprise avec soin la
dréal soit les pompiers soit d'autres
services de l'état dont vous avez parlé
avion d'une mère d'un terroriste quoi
quelle que soit cette source
lui nous essayons de mesurer l'impact
sur ce qui est présent sur nos listes
quelle que soit la source de l'incendié
et nous le comprenons pleinement les
risques associés et les conséquences de
cet événement qu'elle que ce quelle
qu'en soit la source
ce que nous ne pouvons pas en revanche
estimé eh bien les composantes deux
sites extérieurs dans monte logistique
n'est pas un site seveso est donc
considérée comme un site à faible risque
donc ne peut pas entrer en ligne de
compte dans une analyse de risques c'est
les eaux mais nous sommes pleinement en
mesure de mener des analyses de risque
pour notre site
quelle que soit la source de l'incendié
nous faisons cette analyse de risque
j'espère que cela répondait mieux
malheureusement toujours pas la question
est juste et assez précises et il n'y a
pas de piège dans la question avez vous
travaillé avec des services de l'état la
dréal les pompiers sur cette analyse du
risque extérieur la question est
extrêmement simple et je pense que c'est
des documents d'ailleurs que nous aurons
monsieur le président a étudié par
ailleurs pour essayer d'être plus clair
que monsieur dantec qui pourtant est
très claire on a du mal à imaginer que
vous n'ayez pas intégrer dans votre
réflexion et dans votre analyse de
prévention des risques
le fait que à la porte de chez vous il y
avait une entreprise qui apparemment
avaient en son sein des produits qui
présentait quelques dangers à tel point
que vous considérez même que l'un s'en
disent qu'ils restent à trouver est venu
de chez votre voisin
donc on a du mal à penser que vous avez
travaillé comme si votre entreprise
était milieu d'un no man's land sans
intégrer dans votre réflexion sur la
prévention des risques le voisinage
immédiat
ça paraît quand même assez étonnant
non je crois que je n'ai jamais dit que
je pensais que le feu venait de notre
voisin ce que j'ai dit c'est que la
source est extérieur à notre site
c'est une erreur de traduction
non mais c'est vrai
c'est ce que nous avons compris en tout
cas
nous avons compris que c'est ce que vous
aviez dit que l'incident c'est que l'
incendie pardon s'était déclenché dans
l'entreprise voisine
c'est ce que nous avons compris mais la
question reste valable
néanmoins nous ne savons pas l'humour
feu s'est déclaré nous ce que j'ai dit
c'est que le feu s'était déclaré en
dehors de notre sage mais nous notre
analyse de risque bien sûr est basée sur
le niveau de risque pour évaluer les
risques associés à un site qui n'est pas
seveso et donc avec des matériaux qui ne
sommes pas seveso et bien cela donne à
notre une analyse de risque qui n'est
pas de risque ce qu'il s'agissait d'une
usine de traitement de produits
chimiques
c'est à haut risque nous en aurions tenu
ce compte mais bien sûr dans notre
analyse de risques nous avons tenu
compte de cet entrepôt je voudrais pas
être trop haut trop lourd mais jean
claude et le monde de parole absolument
mais la question est assez simple est-ce
que vous avez travaillé avec l'état avec
les dréal sur ses analyses de risques
extérieurs je ne vous demande pas si
vous vous l'avez pris en compte
est ce qu'il ya eu un travail
collaboratif avec l'état la dréal sur ce
risque là
yes we quelle que soit la source d'un
incendie dans le cas présent nous menons
une analyse d'impact de cet événement
avec la dréal avec la préfecture
tout ce que nous faisons là pour bien
essayé de terminaux de résoudre ces
risques et continue dans une
amélioration continue avec des
investissements est basée sur notre
évaluation de la probabilité de
survenance de survenue de cet événement
et et bien généralement cette
probabilité est faible quand il s'agit
d'un espace de stockage
donc de ce qui a brûlé ne dépend pas de
la source mais de la propagation de ce2
se donne que l'évaluation
l'astuce du résultat des conséquences
mais pour ce faire nous avons mené les
analyses de risques nous avons voulu
décider des investissements pas
véritablement à rouen eux nous a nous
n'allons pas investir uniquement à avoir
parce que nous n'allons mais j'ai besoin
de savoir pas seulement pour moi mais
pour tous nos sites dans le monde pour
assurer la sécurité de toutes nos
opérations
merci monsieur martin merci monsieur le
président
tout d'abord dire à monsieur le
président que j'étais présent le jour
même de cet incendie à 11h30 le matin
sur ce site lubrizol puisqu'à l'époque
je m'occupais des fonctions de président
du conseil départemental de la
seine-maritime et que j'ai été amené à
me rendre sur le site où j'ai pu mesurer
l'ampleur de ceux de cet incendie hors
norme tout à fait exceptionnelle avec
très rapidement ce panache de fumée sur
plus de 22 km de long sur 6 km de large
moi je voudrais monsieur le président
vous avez tout à l'heure évoqué à une
question posée par l'un de nos collègues
sur les moyens techniques que
l'entreprise dispose vous avez parlé de
vidéosurveillance ou de vidéo protection
de détecteurs moi je voudrais connaître
les moyens humains dédiés à la lutte
contre un incendie que lubrizol
pouvaient bénéficier vous pouvez engager
à l'instant t c'est à dire en pleine
nuit
combien il y avait d'agents lubrizol
formés à la lutte contre un incendie qui
ont pu répondre présent
ça c'est la première question la
deuxième question nous le savons la
doctrine de la directive seveso et de la
politique des installations placées
consiste à ce que nous puissions
l'entreprise contenir autant que faire
se peut incendie à l'intérieur même de
l'entreprise avant que éventuellement ça
a été le cas très rapidement le service
public d'incendié de secours viennent en
renfort donc autre question je voulais
vous poser monsieur le président
quels ont été les mesures de coopération
et de solidarité avec les entreprises
voisines puisqu'il y à des conventions
de solidarité inter entreprises en cas
de risques majeurs comme nous l'avons
connue vous dire aussi que vous avez
évoqué tout à l'heure l'engagement de
l'entreprise lubrizol a participé à
faire en sorte que nous puissions
retrouver un peu de promotion de
l'attractivité de rouen mais je voudrais
simplement vous dire que ça va bien au
delà
de la ville de rouen c'est la métropole
en normandie c'est le département de la
seine maritime c'est la région normandie
qui est qui est concerné enfin dernière
question a été à plusieurs reprises
évoqué dans vos relations avec normandie
logistique
pourquoi l'entreprise lubrizol stocks
des fûts chez normandie de logistique et
deuxième question ce sera la dernière
les fûts stockés au sein de votre
entreprise etait-il tous dans un
entrepôt ou s'il ne l'était pas faisait
t-il l'objet de procédures de sécurité
particulières notamment en matière de
protection contre les incendies
merci monsieur martin monsieur chemin
[Musique]
ok mais un cycle de squash kent merci
pour ce que tu es bien à 2h40 au milieu
de la nuit
nous avions 17 personnes formées qui ont
permis la première trouve les premières
mesures comme et je crois que bourahli
stick qui est une entreprise locale est
venu en coopération je pourrais vous
donner les noms des autres entreprises
qui sont venues et je dois dire toute ma
reconnaissance aux métiers à tous ceux
qui nous ont aidés dans les premiers
instants tous les voisins notre
reconnaissance
le scanner demeure donc bien sûr dans
toute notre réflexion et les mesures que
nous prenons pour assurer la sécurité de
nos opérations est bien née l'idée de
contenir dans un périmètre le plus
restreint possible tout ce qui s'ils
peuvent survenir sur notre site
et bien en termes de systèmes de
protection et 6 m2 de suppression des
feux des extincteurs et experts
donc pendant deux heures donc c'est
tonnes d'eau rôle et j'étais donc
dispersé mais pour ce qui est de
l'essence de ce que cache et normandie
logistique cette zone étant considérée
comme une zone à faible risque il n'y a
pas et dans la zone de stockage lubrizol
il n'y a pas de sources de départ
incendie en principe donc il n'y avait
pas de raison d'avoir de protection
spécifique
10 nous devons tous nous toutes nos
mesures au risque que nous identifiions
et donc moins aux opérations qui sont
considérés comme présentant de faibles
risques
je suis désolé si j'ai été trop rapide
dans mon introduction nous concernant
l'attractivité de la région de roanne
nous en sommes pleinement conscients et
nous voulons absolument soutenir tout ce
qui peut permettre la promotion et
l'attractivité de cette région dans son
ensemble
c'est la fin de cette grande tranche
d'information parlementaire du mercredi
à 18h ne manquez pas allons plus loin
avec rebecca fitoussi qui revient dans
son grand débat sur la question de la
liberté d'expression sur les réseaux
sociaux
quant à nous on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine à 14h mercredi très exactement
pour les questions d'actualité au
gouvernement très bonne soirée sur
public sénat
[Musique]